GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS WILL BEGIN TODAY'S SOMEONE
HEARING ON APRIL THIRTIETH WILL
START BY ESTABLISHING A QUORUM.
ARAMBULA HERE HARPER.
MATHIS RUBIO HERE. WOULD.
BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
TODAY AND PRESENTING A BUDGET
REQUEST OF FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED TO A
ONE TIME FUNDING TO SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR THE PET HEALTH.
CENTER LOCATED IN ALL MONEY
SERVING MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS
TOGETHER WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAU WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
FUNDING FOR CRITICAL SERVICES
THAT WOULD SERVE MANY LOW INCOME
AND UNINSURED RESIDENTS IN THE
AREA.
BUT COMMITTEE HEALTH ALLIANCE OF
PASADENA OTHER WAYS KNOWN AS TAP
CARE WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE AND PROVIDED
PROVIDES HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO
RESIDENTS OF THE EAST AND GIVE
OF ALLEY.
THE HEALTH CENTER WITH THE HELP
CENTER WITH THIS FUNDING SEEKS
TO PROVIDE A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL CRITICAL SERVICES
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
PRENATAL POSTNATAL CARE DENTAL
AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AS WELL AS PRIMARY
CARE VISITS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY INSTEAD OF
SEARCH ABOUT THE THUNDER THING
ON THE AGENDA IS STEVEN OUT
ABRAMSON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL FOR A DEVELOPMENT
FOR TECH CARE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES FOR
CONSIDERING OUR REQUEST TODAY.
CHAPTER RECENTLY CELEBRATED ITS
TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY THIS PAST
WEEK.
AS WE CONSIDER HOW FAR WE'VE
COME IN TWENTY YEARS THE RESULTS
REMARKABLE.
IN OUR FIRST YEAR IS A SINGLE
HEALTH CENTER PASADENA WE
PROVIDED MEDICAL SERVICES TO
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE. WE ARE NOW REGIONAL
NETWORK WITH EIGHT HEALTH CENTER
LOCATIONS IN PASADENA MONROVIA
AND EL MONTE SELF THE MONEY.
WHICH PROVIDES A VAST ARRAY OF
PRIMARY IMPACT SPECIALTY CARE
SERVICES TO OVER FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED ON
DUPLICATE PATIENTS ANNUALLY.
TODAY I'M HERE TO SPEAK TO YOU
ON BEHALF OF CHAPTERS REQUEST TO
A CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WANTED
HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES.
CHAPTER RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY NINE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED TWO DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING TO SUPPORT GENERAL
OPERATIONS ARE PIC HEALTH
CENTER.
OUR NEWEST HEALTH CENTER WHICH
IS LOCATED IN HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED CITY OF EL MONTE.
OPEN THE JULY OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
THE FACILITIES ARE THIRD HEALTH
CENTER LOCATED IN THE EL MONTE
SELF THE MONEY REGION.
THE PET HEALTH CENTERS PRIMARY
SERVICE AREAS THE EASTERN
PORTION OF EL MONTE.
THE NORTHEASTERN PORTION OF
SOUTH EL MONTE AND THE BALDWIN
PARK AREA
THE SERVICE AREAS BEEN DOES NOT
A MEDIC MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
POPULATION AND HEALTH PERSON.
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREA WITH
IN THIS AREA THERE ARE MANY
CHALLENGES ACCESSING HEALTH CARE
SERVICES INCLUDING LACK OF
INSURANCE COVERAGE AN ASTOUNDING
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THE
SERVICE AREA DO NOT HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE. AND A
SHORTAGE OF PROVIDERS IN THE
SERVICE AREA THERE ARE FIVE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
PEOPLE FOR EVERYONE F. T. E.
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN AMONG
OTHERS. THESE BARRIERS HAVE LED
TO POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING DIABETES AND CERVICAL
CANCER DEATH RATES THAT RISE
ABOVE THE NATIONAL BELT
BENCHMARKS. A RATE OF
HYPERTENSION THAT IS ABOVE THAT
OF THE COUNTY AND A HIGH
INCIDENCE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS WHICH CAN OFTEN
AFFECT A PERSON'S ABILITY TO
MANAGE THE PRIMARY CARE
TREATMENT PLANT.
THE GENERAL OPERATING SUPPORT
FUNDS REQUESTED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY WILL
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION OF
SERVICES ARE PACKED HEALTH
CENTER.
PACIFIC WE THE FUNDS WILL ALLOW
CHAPTER TO EXPAND SERVICES THIS
SITE TO INCLUDE FAMILY PLANNING
PRENATAL AND POSTNATAL CARE XRAY
SERVICES AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COUNSELING. AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL FAMILY MEDICINE AND
DENTAL CAPACITY AND THE NUMBER
OF VISITS PROVIDED AT OUR PACK
HEALTH ENTER IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OUR
GOAL IS TO PROVIDE THE FOLLOWING
AT THIS SITE OVER A ONE YEAR
PERIOD.
IT'S THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE PRIMARY CARE
MEDICAL VISITS
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED H.
SPECIALTY CARE MEDICAL VISITS
THREE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHT DENTAL VISITS. AND ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH VISITS IN
TOTAL THIS WILL. WILL LEAD TO
PROJECTED THIRTEEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT VISITS IN
ONE YEAR. THE PROJECTED NUMBER
OF THIRTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT VISITS REPRESENTS A
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
PERCENT INCREASE. OVER THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE MEDICAL VISITS CONDUCTED
AT OUR PECK SITE IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN. DENTAL
SERVICES BEGAN AT THIS FACILITY
IN JULY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THIS PROJECTION OF PATIENT
GROWTH PER PACK IS BASED ON OUR
CURRENT GROWTH RATE WE ARE
CURRENTLY PROVIDING OVER FOUR
HUNDRED MEDICAL VISITS AND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DENTAL VISITS PER
MONTH AT THIS SITE. AND THE RATE
OF GROWTH WE SAW IMPATIENT IT'S
OUR LIFE HEALTH CENTER MONROVIA
WHICH IS OUR NEW IT'S HEALTH
CENTER BEFORE THIS ONE.
TO REALIZE ARE PROJECTED
EXPANSION OF VISITS IMP AT
PACKING HIS GEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE MUST HIRE A TOTAL OF
NINE POINT FIVE NEW CLINICAL
STAFF MEMBERS. REQUESTED FUNDS
WILL PROVIDE GAP FUNDING TO
ALLOW CHAPTER HIGHER THAN THAT
NECESSARY STAFF.
THE STATE ABILITY WILL BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH ENHANCED VISIT
REIMBURSEMENT AS WE BUILT OUR%
PATIENT PRACTICE AT THIS
LOCATION.
CHAPTER IS NOT ONLY CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN INCREASE THE
QUANTITY OF SERVICES PROVIDED
AND OUR PATIENTS SENSE IS THAT
THIS SITE BUT THE QUALITY OF
CARE WE PROVIDE WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE US INTO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THE LIVES OF OUR PATIENTS IN
THE AREA. AN EXAMPLE OF A
CHAPTER PET PATIENT WHO'S BEEN
POSSIBLY IMPACTED BY OUR WORK
IS.
A FIVE YEAR OLD PATIENT HAD
FACIAL SWELLING DUE TO SEVERAL
TOOTH INFECTIONS
HIS MOTHER MIGRATED WITH HER
FIVE CHILDREN FROM HONDURAS
RECENTLY AND DOES NOT HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
THE PATIENT.
WE ARE CURRENTLY ASSISTING THE
PATIENT TO TRY TO OBTAIN
COVERAGE
THE CHILD WAS INITIALLY NON
COOPERATIVE DESPITE USING
NOTCHES NITROUS OXIDE YUBA FEAR
OF DENTAL SERVICES.
CHAPTER WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
THE PARENT AND CHILD AS WELL AS
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNER THE USC
SCHOOL OF DENTISTRY. TO ENSURE
THE CHILD IS ABLE RECEIVE FOR
EMERGENCY TOOTH EXTRACTIONS
UNDER GENERAL ANESTHESIA NOW
THAT THE CHILD'S EMERGENCY NEEDS
HAVE BEEN HANDLED CHAPTER WILL
RESUME PROVIDING ROUTINE DENTAL
CARE FOR THIS CHILD. AND ITS
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS WITHOUT
CHAPTER THIS CHILD WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE HIS
IMMEDIATE AND LONG TERM DENTAL
NEEDS HANDLED DUE TO HIS LACK OF
INSURANCE COVERAGE. IN
CONCLUSION I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
CHAIR ARAMBULA AND THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF SUBCOMMITTEE ONE FOR
CONSIDERING OUR REQUEST I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER IVERSON
ABRAMSON.
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE ONE.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS.
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE MAY
HAVE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF POSSIBLE TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF TO.
COME UP WITH SOME METRICS THAT
WE CAN FOLLOW TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROPOSAL HAS OUTCOMES THAT WE.
CAN SEE WHERE THE STATE
INVESTMENT IS BEING SPENT AND.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
ONE OPEN WOULD YOU YEAH NOW
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CONSIDERATION AND AND THAT
IS THE GOAL OF TAP CARE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE.
WE CAN PROVIDE SERVICES BUT
THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE.
THE MONEY THAT WE'RE INVESTING
OUR HOPEFULLY BE INVESTING IN
THEIR SERVICES AS IS ACCOUNTED
FOR AND.
HOPEFULLY GIVE.
UP REALLY POSITIVE OUTCOME WITH
THE MONEY THAT WE'RE INVESTING
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE ONE
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO
.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE.
I'M HERE UP ON ISSUE TOO ON
BEHALF OF. TEN OTHER ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES MYSELF BUT I ON A
BIPARTISAN REQUEST.
I'M. THE DATA ALL SANTA LETTER
ACROSS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
ALLOCATE THREE MILLION DOLLARS
CONTRACT.
BUT THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
LOS ANGELES TO INCORPORATE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ARE ACCESS
TO.
AND THE NEED FOR LONG TERM CARE
SUPPORT SERVICES IN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH INTERVIEW
SURVEY. IN THE TWENTIETH
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR SURVEY
CYCLES.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS CLOSED
EIGHT MILLION PERSONS WERE
EITHER SENIORS AGE SIXTY FIVE
AND OVER. OR PERSONS UNDER AGE
SIXTY FIVE WHO HAVE DISABILITIES
THIS POPULATION IS EXPECTED TO
GROW SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE PRIMARILY TO THE AGING OF
THE POPULATION BUT ALSO DUE TO
THE GROWING NUMBER OF PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES. INCLUDING
THOSE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
DESPITE THIS UNPRECEDENTED
GROWTH THE NEEDS FOR LTE SS.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT COLLECTED DATA
NEEDS TO ACCURATELY TRACK AND
PLAN FOR THESE NEEDS.
FOR NATIONAL SURVEYS COLLECTED
ON THE PREVALENCE OF
DISABILITIES AND COGNITIVE AND
FUNCTIONAL IMPAIRMENTS THAT ARE
NOT PROVIDE STATE AND COUNTY
LEVEL ESTIMATES OF THE
POPULATION THAT NEEDS AND USES
LTFS. IN CALIFORNIA. NORRIS SAYS
THE NEED THROUGHOUT YES HAS BY
INCOME LEVEL AGE TYPE OF
DISABILITY GEOGRAPHIC REGION OR
RACIAL OR ETHNIC GROUP.
A MODEST INVESTMENT DEVELOPING
BETTER AND MORE ACCURATE STATE
AND COUNTY LEVEL DATA ONE ABLE
THE STATE TO ENGAGE IN BETTER
PLANNING FOR THE L. TSS NEEDS OF
ITS GROWING POPULATION OF
SENIORS. AND PERSONS OF A
DISABILITIES.
THE STATE WILL NOT ONLY BE
BENEFICIAL TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE STATE TO DETERMINE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THOSE WHO
REQUIRE LTSA US IN THE FUTURE.
BALL PROVIDE ABOUT THE DATA FROM
RESEARCHER BUDGET ANALYST AND
PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCATES TO
ASSIST US AS WE LOOK DEVELOP
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING MECHANISMS
TO DEAL WITH THIS LOOMING
PROBLEM.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOCTOR
KEPT.
I'M STEVE QUE FROM.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO PROFESSOR AT THE
INSTITUTE FOR HEALTH AND AGEING.
PLACEMENT IS MICHAEL AND
WORKING.
AND.
LONG TERM CARE WE CALL IT LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS IS
NOT JUST NURSING HOMES NOT JUST
INSTITUTIONAL CARE MOSTLY IT'S
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THEIR HOMES
IN THE COMMUNITIES. AND THEY GET
HELP FROM PEOPLE MOSTLY IT'S NOT
PEOPLE WHO GET HELP FROM PUBLIC
PROGRAMS LIKE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES IT'S PEOPLE WHO GET ON
HELP FROM FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE GET A MIX
OF BOTH.
IT'S NOT JUST ELDERLY PEOPLE
IT'S NON ELDERLY PEOPLE HAVE
DISABILITIES ON AND THE GOAL IS
THE GOAL OF MUCH OF IT IS REALLY
TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES
AND COMMUNITIES IT WHICH IS WHAT
EVERYBODY WANTS HOME THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES. AND AVOID
INSTITUTIONALIZATION AND IT
SAVES MONEY TO.
ARE AND THAT WHAT ELSE YES S.
DOES IS IT HELPS PEOPLE MAINTAIN
THEIR HEALTH THEIR ABILITY TO
FUNCTION THEIR INDEPENDENCE TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE. OTHER SELF
DETERMINATION AND THEIR ABILITY
TO PARTICIPATE IS ACTIVE MEMBERS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND AVOID
THE ISOLATION THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY SENIORS. ARE
OFTEN HAVE.
SO AS WE JUST HEARD THERE'S AN
AWFUL LOT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
IN CALIFORNIA I CAN TELL YOU
THAT ROUGHLY SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
ONE AND TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA NEEDLE TEST'S*
RIGHT NOW. ON BUT I CAN'T TELL
YOU PRECISELY BECAUSE NEITHER
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR THE
STATE DOES DATA COLLECTION WHICH
WE ACTUALLY ACCURATELY MEASURE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO NEED.
OUR EL TSS.
AND THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
STUFF WE DON'T NEED NO ABOUT
THOSE POPULATIONS ONE OF WHICH
IS TO THEY HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO CAN HELP THEM.
RIGHT SO IT ARE YOU KNOW OR ARE
THEY SAY LIVING ALONE WITHOUT
FAMILY NEARBY AND THEY'RE MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO ENTER A PUBLIC
PROGRAM MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
APPLY FOR IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND IF THEY QUALIFY GET
ON. WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
INCOME IS SO WE DON'T KNOW WELL
ARE THEY LIKELY TO QUALIFY DO
THEY NEED TO SPEND DOWN CAN.
.
AND ONE MAJOR VERY MAJOR THING
IS WE DON'T KNOWIN GENERAL.
WHETHER PEOPLE'S LTFS NEEDS ARE
BEING MET OR NOT.
SO IN AMONG PEOPLE NOT IN
PUBLIC PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA WE
ACTUALLY KNOW NOTHING WE DON'T
KNOW.
WHAT PERCENTAGE THOSE PEOPLE
WOULD SAY THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
MET VERSES UNMET IN PUBLIC
PROGRAMS WE'VE JUST DONE A
STUDY?
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE DUELS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR BOTH MEDICARE AL
AND MEDICARE AND EVEN AMONG
THESE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS MOST
OF WHOM ARE GETTING I JUST ASK
IF THEY NEED IT.
FORTY TWO PERCENT SAID THEY DID
NOT GET ALL THE HELP THEY NEEDED
WITH THEIR DAILY ACTIVITIES.
FORTY TWO PERCENT FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING IN MAJOR
PUBLIC PROGRAMS AND BAD THINGS
HAPPEN TO PEOPLE WHEN THEY DON'T
GET ALL THE HELP THEY NEED FOR
EXAMPLE.
THEY TAKE THE WRONG MEDICATIONS
ARE DON'T TAKE THEIR MEDICATION.
THEY HAVE TOSTAY IN BED OR AT
HOME BECAUSE NOBODY IS THERE TO
HELP THEM GET OUT AND
PARTICIPATE IN SOMETHING. THEY
DON'T GET TO THE TOILET ON TIME
THEY END UP ON IN CLOTHES THAT
ARE SOIL THEY DON'T EAT THE FOOD
THEY NEED AND IT HAPPENS A LOT.
SO.
THE OTHER MAIN THING THAT WE
DON'T KNOW IS Y. PEOPLE ARE NOT
GETTING THE HELP THEY NEED WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE BARRIERS ARE
AND IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
BARRIERS ARE WE CAN'T SOLVE IT
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
SOLUTION IS FOR EXAMPLE.
ONE OF THESUPPORTS THAT FAMILY
CAREGIVERS NEED SO THAT THEY CAN
KEEP DOING WHAT THEY DO AND DO
IT BETTER AND MORE EFFICIENTLY.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT
WE DON'T KNOW EITHER ALTERNATIVE
PROGRAMS IS THERE SOMETHING WE
COULD DO A PROGRAM WE COULD
IMPLEMENT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING OTHER THAN AYE CHESS
AT SO THAT PEOPLE WHO NEED.
A LITTLE BIT TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
NEED SUPPORT WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET THAT AT NOT SOME HUGE AMOUNT
OF OF COST.
WE DON'T IF THERE'S SOME
PRIVATE SOLUTION LIKE MAKING
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE AXES
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE WOULD
WANT.
AND COULD AFFORD AND I'VE MET
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS IS WE
DON'T KNOW OUR THEIR SOLUTIONS
LIKE TECHNOLOGY. ARM HOME
MODIFICATIONS
OTHER INNOVATIONS THAT COULD
REALLY HELP PEOPLE AND DECREASE
THE BURDEN OF CARE GIVING AND OF
ONE OF THE STATE TO HAVE TO PAY
FOR THESE SERVICES.
SO WE JUST OR ASKING FOR OUR A
SUPPLEMENT TO ADD QUESTIONS
ABOUT.
BELT YES ASKED TO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH INTERVIEW
SURVEY WHICH IS A VERY ROBUST
WELL RESPECTED EXISTING SURVEY
IN CALIFORNIA. ARM OF THE OF THE
OVERALL POPULATION WHICH
PROVIDES COUNTY LEVEL ESTIMATES
VERY WELL AND IT ALREADY IS VERY
WELL SET UP TO JUST ADD A FEW
QUESTIONS AND THEN. ON THE
PEOPLE YOU SEE EL DE LA WILL GO
AND DEVELOP.
A QUESTIONNAIRE WITH THE HELP
OF AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND
THEN FEEL THE QUESTIONNAIRE
FOLLOWING UP THOSE PEOPLE WHO
IDENTIFIED IN THE MAIN SURVEY AS
HAVING LTFS NEEDS PLUS THEY'LL
BE SOME ADDITIONAL. DETAILED
INTERVIEWS DETAILED PERSONAL
INTERVIEWS WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HIGH LEVELS OF LTO SAYS NEEDS TO
FIND OUT MORE ABOUT THEIR
INDIVIDUAL SITUATIONS.
BOB. I WOULD SAY THIS IS MONEY
WELL SPENT BECAUSE WE REALLY
KNOW SO LITTLE AND THE NEED IS
URGENT RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE BABY
BOOMERS LIKE ME ARE AGING INTO
NEEDING MORE AT INTO HAVING MORE
AND MORE LIKELIHOOD OF NEEDING
AL TSS IN THE NEAR FUTURE. AND
IF CALIFORNIA'S AND START TO
PLAN FOR THIS NOW.
THE BUDGET WE BROKE AND I MEAN
AT SOME POINT WILL BE SO MANY
PEOPLE APPLYING FOR I JUST AS WE
WANT NOT A.
WE NEED AN ALTERNATIVE.
THANK YOU SIR.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TO.
HELLO I FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS WE
ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU AYE JESSICA LEHMAN WAS
TERENCE'S CHO SENIOR DISABILITY
ACTION IN HAND AND HAND. AND WE
WORK WITH SENIORS EVERYDAY AND
PEOPLE DON'T GET THEIR NEEDS MET
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME SOCIAL
NETWORKS THEY USE TO AND PEOPLE
BECOME VERY ISOLATED IT'S BECOME
A HUGE PROBLEM. AND I CAN ALSO
SPEAK FOR MYSELF AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH A DISABILITY AYE
HIGHER ATTENDANCE TO ASSIST ME
EVERYDAY WITH ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING TO MAKE SURE I CAN
LIVE AT HOME. AND NOT HAVE TO GO
IN AN INSTITUTION. AND WHEN I
STARTED DOING NOT I WAS DOING
OFF THE BOOKS BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO DO SO
THERE WAS NO RECORD OF THAT AND
WE KNOW THIS HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME. AND IT'S NOT TRACK AND WE
NEED TO HAVE THE FACTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE GET
WHAT THEY NEED SO PLEASE FIND
THE DATE ON LCS US THINK YOU
MEANT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON NOT MY NAME IS
COLORADO CAMERA YOU KNOW I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH A A RP AND I'M
HERE TO VOICE AARP'S VERY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS.
BUT DID ASK
THIS IS VERY UP PERSONAL FOR ME.
I BECAME AN AARP VOLUNTEER
BECAUSE OF MY EXPERIENCE TAKING
CARE OF MY MOM. MY MOTHER IN LAW
MY DAD.
AND SEE MY ON TAKE CARE MY UNCLE
WHO HAD BEEN.
.
DIAGNOSE IT ALZHEIMER'S TO
FOURTEEN YEARS NOW SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR.
SO.
YOU KNOW LIKE.
ONE A BILL FOR.
I THINK IT'S FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION.
FAMILY CAREGIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
I'VE SPENT THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
OF MY OWN MONEY. AND SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS TAKING CARE OF
MY DAD.
JUST JUST TO ILLUSTRATE I LIVE
IN FAIRFIELD.
AND IN OUR.
APPOINTMENT FOR MY THAT IN NOW
PEYSER FREMONT WILL TAKE ME THE
WHOLE DAY.
BECAUSE I DRIVE FROM FAIRFIELD
PICKING UP BUT THEY WORK.
AND TAKE HIM THERE SO I SPEAKING
ON MY BAD.
NINE BASIC GO.
WE HAD A FUNERAL FOR HIM OR WALK
TO VET.
AND NOW.
.
MY MOTHER IN LAW ALSO PASSED
AWAY IN DECEMBER AFTER A YEAR
LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER. THEY
ARE NOT IN ANY DATABASE AND ALSO
WE NEED THE DATA BASE TO
ACCURATELY PREDICT AND PLAN FOR
THESE NEEDS.
AND I HEARD YOU SAY METRICS
AWHILE AGO AND.
NOW THAT WORD THERE.
SO PLEASE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISS CHAIR MEMBERS DEB ROTH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AND
APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE NOT
PUTTING BANDAIDS ON AN ISSUE WE
KNOW HAS BEEN COMING BUT
INSTEAD.
WE ARE.
APPLYING THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS TO
MAKE SMART CHOICES SMART
DECISIONS FOR THE FUTURE THANK
YOU THINK YOU MEANT.
WE'RE GOING TO.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TRY TO MAYBE
MOVE THE MIKE DOWN SO THE PEOPLE
IN THE FRONT ROW TIAN AARON ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR ELDERS
INDEPENDENCE WHICH IS I PAY PACE
PROGRAM IN THE EAST BAY. AND
ALSO BE HAVE EAST BAY
INNOVATIONS WHICH PROVIDE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE. WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES RIGHT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS OUR
PROPOSAL ON IT IS TIME FOR US
TO.
START DOING SOME PLANNING QUITE
IF NOTHING ELSE IN REGARDS TO
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR SENIORS
ARE TALKING TO A BOOMER HERE
RIGHT. WHO'S LIVING AT ARMS AND
IT IT'S TIME FOR US TO DO THIS
THANKS.
THANK YOU AGAIN YOUR TO HUMBLE
SHE IS ALSO A FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SO YEAH.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CRISTINA BOSS
HAMILTON WITH YOU W.
REPRESENTING HUNDRED THOUSAND I
JUST US WORKERS IN TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BUDGET REQUEST WE WANT
TO GET AWAY. FROM CRISIS
AND LURCHING FROM CRISIS TO
CRISIS AND I JUST US AND INSTEAD
DO SOME SMART PLANNING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LAUREL MILDRED
BUT THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS WE REPRESENT THIRTY SIX
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS AND
SIXTEEN REGIONAL COALITIONS
AROUND THE STATE. ADVOCATES
PROVIDERS LABOR AND HEALTH
INSURERS WE TRY TO BE THE BIG
TENT FOR LTFS WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
MAKE NO MISTAKE WE DON'T MEET
PEOPLE'S LTFS NEEDS WE PAY FOR
THOSE COSTS IN THE HEALTH SYSTEM
WE NEED TO GET A HANDLE ON IT
THANK YOU. ACUMEN.
MY NAME IS ACTUALLY NECESSARY
AND OF RECESS I AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PILIPINO WORKER CENTER AND ALSO
ONE OF THE STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKER COALITION. A WE
REPRESENT ESPECIALLY CARE GIVERS
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND WE
WANT TO FIND OUT YES S. DATA
BECAUSE WE SEE THEM NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITY ARE CARE GIVER SEE THE
NEEDS. AND MANY OF THEM ARE
AGING THEMSELVES AND SO WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL AYE
INDIVIDUALS NEEDS FOR AL TFC
LTFS I MET.
AND ACCURATELY DEPICTED THANK
YOU THINK YOU MEANT.
HEY GOOD A THING OF THE. EVERY
CAREGIVERS COMES TO THEIR OWN
WEEDS A DIFFERENT HISTORY AND
CHALLENGES SO. I AS A CAREGIVER.
I SUPPORT THIS FUND LDS ES.
AND ALL DATA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO WE CARE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE
CARRIED THEM AND.
WE NEED TO SOMEBODY TO CARE FOR
US TO SELL WE NEED A CARE TO AS
A CAREGIVER AT PINK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SEVENTY SEVEN
MONTH YET THEY A WOMAN'S
COLLECTED THIS SAN FRANCISCO.
I SUPPORT.
BROWN'S. FTS S. VALYA.
HELLO I'M GONNA GET ME NOT
BECAUSE THE YOUNG MOSTLY COME
FROM THE OF THE MONTH TO WORK OF
POLLUTION. IN.
ONE WAS COLLECTED FROM SAN
FRANCISCO IN MY SUPPORT BY PHONE
LTSA THIS. OUR DATA THINK YOU.
HI PETER COUNCIL WITH CAL PACE
THAT'S THE A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROGRAMS OF PAUL
COULD TO CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE LPS AS DATA
PROPOSAL. THINK IT'S A VERY.
WISE AND MODEST INVESTMENT OF.
FUNDS IS RELATIVELY LIMITED
AMOUNT OF FUNDS THAT WILL
PRODUCE ENORMOUS BENEFITS.
OUR PROGRAM SO I SEE PEOPLE
EVERY DAY THAT ARE FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T HAD ACCESS TO A TIMELY
AND APPROPRIATE EL TSS.
WE TEND TO GET THEM FAIRLY FRONT
FAR ALONG IN THE PROCESS I THINK
THE STATE WILL BE ESSENTIAL TO
IDENTIFY THESE POPULATIONS AT
RISK.
AND DEVELOP BETTER INTERVENTIONS
SO THAT THEY GET MORE TIME WHEN
APPROPRIATE CARE.
FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORTED
THANK YOU SIR.
RON SCHMIDT MARABLE POSE
ACCOUNTING. AND I SUPPORT.
AB OUT TSS AND THE DATA AND I'M
AMAZED THAT ONLY ASKING FOR
THREE MILLION BECAUSE I
PERSONALLY THINK THAT THAT.
RURAL COUNTIES LIKE MARIPOSA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IRAN.
UNDERSERVED.
THAT.
PLEASE CONSIDER.
NANCY MARASH WITH THE CONGRESS
OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS AND I.
DITTO EVERYTHING THAT HAS BEEN
SAID BUT I WANNA I WANNA MAKE
MAKE THIS A LITTLE BIT REAL I'M
A PERSON THAT COMES FROM A VERY
LARGE FAMILY. AND RIGHT NOW I
HAVE TO GENERATIONS BETWEEN MY
PARENTS AND MY SIBLINGS THAT ALL
FALL INTO THIS CATEGORY OF
POTENTIALLY NEEDING. SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS
AND.
.
JUST EL AS A YOUNG MEMBER
YOUNGER MEMBER OF THAT FAMILY.
I SEE HOW VERY QUICKLY OUR
FAMILY ARRANGEMENT OF CARING FOR
EACH OTHER. COULD BE COMPLETELY
DERAILED.
BY SOME OF THOSE.
CONNECTED TO FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS YOU KNOW WERE A
SURGERY ERA. A HEALTH CRISIS
AWAY FROM NOT BEING ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR FAMILY AS IT IS
RIGHT NOW SO I'M THIS DATA IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
TO GET THE RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND.
.
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS BECAUSE
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT CHAU
LANDSCAPE IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND DOESN'T SUBURBS THANK YOU
ARGUMENT.
HELLO AND NICKEL THE TEARS ON
BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION. TODAY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S IN CALIFORNIA. I
THIS IS A SIZEABLE POPULATION
THAT DOES NOT AYE REFLECTS THE
CALIFORNIA IS NOT REFLECTED IN
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH INTERVIEW
SURVEY. VIA THE TELEPHONE THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF INCLUSION OF
NEW LTFS QUESTIONS PINK. BECAME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MIGHTY
YANKEE YOUNG. AND TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING JOBS WITH JUSTICE.
IT IS A OF COALITION OF FORTY
DIAPERS COMMUNITY AND LABOR
GROUPS WORKING TOGETHER IN THE
BAY AREA. AND ALSO WE HAVE A
CHAPTER IN THE NORTH BAY.
THIS IS ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES.
AND WE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU SUPPORTING AND.
FUND OUT T. S. S. DATA THANK YOU
THINK INFORMATION IS POWER.
HI MY NAME IS FOR HIM LONGTIME
NO AND I'M WITH SENIOR
DISABILITY ACTION. I WANNA SAY
THANK YOU FOR PAYING ATTENTION
TO PASS.
ISSUE HAVE. WE REALLY HERE TO
SHOW THAT WE.
WHEN THIS TO HAPPEN SO I'M HERE
TO HIS PRESS BY SUPPORTERS TO
THE.
.
FUN FOR THE L. D. S. S. DATA AND
SO I THINK THAT.
MAYBE SOME OF YOU GONNA BENEFIT
FROM THAT TOO SO. LET'S DO IT.
HUMAN.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KATHY BAR HIM FROM U. D. W.
PLASTER COUNTY. ARMS ARE CARE
GIVER. AND A HALF OF MY SON AND
OF OTHER BY DISABLED ELDERLY
AND.
I KNOW PERSONALLY THE COMMUNITY
THAT I LIVE IN WHICH IS A SENIOR
COMMUNITY. THAT I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY KNOWS EXISTS BUT I DO
KNOW THAT THEY ALL LIVE. ON
SOCIAL SECURITY ALONE THAT'S IT.
AND SO ON I'M I'M DEFINITELY
SURE THEY'RE WELL UNDERSERVED.
THANK YOU THE PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS.
HOW?
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BRIAN NELSON ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED BALL. MANY OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THE CLIENTS
WHO DEPEND ON THE SPOT VALUABLE
SERVICE.
HERE TODAY SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR.
IT AFTERNOON LISA COLEMAN WITH
CHALCO AT THE CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO HAVE BEEN
ONE OF THE ORIGINAL MEMBERS OF
THE COALITION THAT CAME FORWARD
ASKING FOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALLER SUPPORT THE HALLMARK OF
THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IS
PREVENTION.
AND THIS DATA REQUEST IS IN OUR
OPINION A GREAT EXAMPLE OF THAT
MOTTO THAT. WE SAVE MONEY BY
INVESTING IN THE BEGINNING.
LISA.
YOU CAN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHEN
HAMPTON NUMBER OF LEADING EDGE
CALIFORNIA WHICH REPRESENTS OVER
FOUR HUNDRED NOT FOR PROFIT
PROVIDERS. FOUR WILL HOUSING
CARE AND SERVICES RIGHT
CALIFORNIA. I OBVIOUSLY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL OUT WE CERTAINLY SEE.
.
THE ISSUES THAT ARE THAT ARE
COMING DOWN THE PIKE WITH WITH
THE AGING OF OUR POPULATION WE
THINK THAT PLANNING AND YEAH
FUNDING THAT PLANNING NOW. TO
PLAN FOR A BETTER FUTURE IS
OBSOLETE CRITICAL TO US ME PORTS
OVER TRANSPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR.
CAROL SEWELL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING WE'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND TO YOU
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST CRITICAL ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING AND WE KNOW YOU GET
THAT'S OF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL LINE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE RETIRED
AMERICANS WE REPRESENT ABOUT A
MILLION. SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA.
.
WE DESPERATELY NEED UNIVERSAL
LONG TERM CARE.
PART OF THE SITUATION IS THAT
LONG TERM CARE AND SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES AND IS INCREDIBLY OF
FRAGMENTED IN CALIFORNIA.
LEADING TO A LOT OF DUPLICATION
OF SERVICES AND THINGS BEING
DROPPED.
AND.
UNIFYING THIS WOULD MAKE A MUCH
BETTER SITUATION ALSO.
.
A BIT BABY BOOMERS ARE HAVING
THEIR THEIR OWN KIDS LATER AND
LATER IN LIFE AND SO AS AS THESE
BABY BOOMERS ARE HAVING TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR PATIENTS THE KIDS
THEMSELVES ARE STARTING.
TO GET NEGLECTED SO WE REALLY
NEED THIS.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IT TO SOME LIKE KELLY
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
.
I WOULD LIKE VIA GOVERNMENT TO
HAVE A SENSE THAT THIS FIX OF
WITH SOME PEOPLE LIKE ME HAVE A
NEED A FAR HEALTH CARE TIME TO
TIME NOT ALL THE TIME NOTHING
MAJOR BUT THEY EVERY TIME I HAVE
A PROBLEM.
BROKE LIFE FOOT AND A FULL
MONTHS I HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT HOW
TO GET THE CARE AND HOW TO PAY
FOR IT THEN IT PASSES BUT. I'D
LIKE TO BE AT THE PART OF THE IN
THE PART OF THE.
STATISTICS THAT THIS PERSON
LIKE ME EXISTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. HUT KIMBERLY
INVITING NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR DOMESTIC WORKERS A
WE'RE HERE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THE UP.
ITS BUDGET REQUEST WE BELIEVE IN
THE. NEED FOR THE TRANSFORMATION
OF THE LONG TERM CARE INDUSTRY
AND WITH THAT WE CAN'T DO THAT
WITHOUT DIGNITY FOR DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND JUST AS IMPORTANT
THE DIGNITY OF THOSE THAT
RECEIVE THE CARE. SO WE'RE HERE
TO SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ADAM GREEN.
I AM A POLITICAL VOLUNTEER
OFFICER FOR YOU DO W..
AND I WAS RAISED.
WITH THE ATTITUDE FAMILY TAKES
CARE FAMILY.
VOLUNTEER SERVICE HOST GARRY
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS MY FAMILY THE SOMEHOW
I AM VERY BIG SUPPORT.
AVI MULTI US US FUNDING
AND DATA
SO PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
THEN MISTER CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
LEAP LAST OF THE FILIPINO WORKER
CENTER. REPRESENTING OVER
THOUSANDS OF CARE GIVERS.
AND.
SO WHEN ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM
WILL BE THERE.
SO I SUPPORT.
THIS THIS WHOLE HANDING OUT IS
S. AND OUR DATABASE VERY
IMPORTANT SO SOUND RESEARCH.
WILL GIVE US INFORMATION AND
THEY'RE RIGHT.
WAIT THE GIVEN ROBERT PROGRAMS
FIVE CONSTITUENTS SO AS TO HAVE
SAID INFORMATION IN POPPIES
SUPPORT THINK YOU THINK YOU
MEANT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CITY
IF ADAMS AND I GUESS I'M THE
LAST PERSON I FROM SAN DIEGO.
IT IS A BEAUTIFUL* COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO.
I AM LURKER DEAVER FROM MY
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTERS SHE
WAS SAW SHE WAS BORN PRE. VERY
PREMATURE AND IDEA.
TAKING OVER FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS
AND ASSIST WITH THE HIATUSES
PROGRAM. I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF U.
D. W. AND I'M ALSO THE STATE
QUITE PRESIDENTE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOME CARE
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S OUT YOU KNOW OUR OUR
METERS OR JOB YOU GUYS DID A
GREAT JOB YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW SERVING IN IN IN IN
THIS IT ALL OUT ARM.
COUNTY AND YOU KNOW WE REALLY UP
APPRECIATE IF WE CONSIDER THE
LPS AS WE FIND IT RIGHT BECAUSE
THIS IS OUR FUTURE.
NETWORK WERE GETTING ALL SIXTY
PERCENT RETURNING SIXTY FIVE
EVERY MINUTE AND THAT I KNOW
THAT.
YOU NOT THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
TIME FOR ME AS A FAMILY MEMBER
THAT HAD THAT SITUATION FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS THAT SHE'S BEEN.
AND I TO CSUS PROGRAM AND I KNOW
I HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO.
THEY CAN GO MY DAUGHTER YOU KNOW
WE MENTIONED ABOUT MEDICATION
MENTION ABOUT MEDICAL DEVICES
MEASURE MY ABOUT.
YOUR RESOURCES WE NEEDED YOU WE
NEEDED TO FIND OUT THE ASSIST
NOW THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
ACUMEN.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TO BRING IT UP TO THE.
YES MA'AM YEAH FIREWALL.
ABSOLUTELY THAT I'M.
THANK YOU HAPPY TO.
OOOH WILL WHEN I MONIQUE HARRIS
OF HAND IN HAND.
MOON .
I'M LOU KEYHOLE THERE OR.
DEFINITIVO IS TO.
ORANGE SOON THERE ARE A KEY I'VE
BEEN A
PLAYER HOME CARE TENANTS.
WHO?
NO.
I'M GOOD TUNES OR IN THIS ROOM.
THIS.
WHO WAR I HAVE TO MEMBERS OF MY?
NINA SO
WORKING GROUP WHO.
ROLL ON.
IN THE ONE SO PLEASE SUPPORT OF.
THANK YOU MA'AM FAIR ADVOCACY IN
YOUR VOICE
MMHM AND.
THE OTHER ROOM.
MY NAME IS KEVIN SEEM.
I'M.
KNOWING PRUNE.
NINE.
I'M.
ON.
AND. WHEN.
SOON FOR THE.
VERY.
IN JUNE. OR.
AND.
GO. ON.
HERE.
WHO?
WHO? THE MOON.
THEN I'M THROUGH MOVE I DON'T
WANT TO GO.
BIRD FLU.
MOVE ARE YOU. FROM. PENA.
ON WHO.
HOME HIRING.
LEANN TO.
URBAN.
MMHM.
THROUGH.
IN.
WHO?
MOVE YOUR.
ALL.
NO WHO.
WHO?
LOU O..
THROUGH THEN.
I HOPE YOU'LL PAY FOR IT.
MOON MOON AND THE OF.
WHO?
I OF WILL.
AND MOVE.
GOOD.
NO. ROOM.
OH I'M NO I'M I'M. A FOOL.
HE.
I'M.
LEANN. LEANN
A LOT OF.
WHO I'M
EARNED FOR HER PROOF? PROOF
HEREIN THE AYE MELISSA CHRIS
COOPER WITH HAND.
WE DO FULLER. IRV GOOD EARTH.
BLUE.
PART OF THE LCS THAT.
YOU.
THANK YOU MONTH.
I'M FLOOD THE PREGNENOLONE
FILLED WITH AND THEN THEN.
I WOULD LOVE BREWING FOR THE
GUM.
DO DECLARE PRODUTO GROWTH.
OPAL MINING FOR FIRM YOU.
TF THAT FOOD FOR YOU.
AND THE OF IT TO.
INDEED GET AND. BRCKO.
WHEN DE YEAH WHO ARE DIFFERENT.
ROOM.
AND SO DO WILL. GIVE FIFTH ROOM.
MEDIUM FILMING AND FOODS.
DO HAVE TO DE DO AND IF THE
GIRL.
WOULD WE NEED TO DO FOR THEM.
DELEON YEAH IF IF THE COMMUNITY.
THERE.
KNOW WHAT.
AND THEN GIVE THEM A.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI AND MICKEY BROWN BUT THERE.
AND I'M WITH HAND IN HAND THAT.
EMPLOYERS NETWORK.
AND I'M ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND EASY DOESN'T
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE PROVIDE EMERGENCY BACKUP
CARE ASSISTANCE FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED AND. AND TEN CARE. AND THE
CITY OF BERKELEY AND WE ARE
OVERWHELMED WITH AND OUR REQUEST
FOR PEOPLE OF THAT PARTICULAR
FOR SENIORS. WHO NOT HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED AN ORDER TO GET THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED?
SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT.
TO.
THING THAT TO.
FIND THAT THEY THAT FAR OUT TSS
EVIDENCES.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
ANY FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ISSUE TO.
SEEING NONE I BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS AND.
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON WERE.
PROPOSAL TODAY IS WELL RECEIVED
THE HE ADVOCACY THAT WE HEARD
PARTICULARLY BY THOSE FROM HAND
TO HAND IS MOVING.
KNOWLEDGE IS POWER AND IT'S
TIME FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION. TO DEAL
WITH BOTH THE AGE WAVE OR SILVER
TSUNAMI OR HOWEVER YOU WANT TO
FRAME IT.
BUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MUST
HAVE THAT DATA LOOKING FORWARD.
ANYONE ELSE.
I JUST LIKE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I TO.
APPRECIATE THE ADVOCATES WHO
COME FORWARD MANY TRAVELED MANY
MANY MILES I KNOW TO BE HERE.
AND AND IT COULD BE MORE TRUE
THAT THAT DATA IS IS IS AND
KNOWLEDGE IS POWER AND AND
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SORELY
LACKING LOW NUMBER OF LEVELS
WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTHCARE.
AND AND SERVICES FOR PEOPLE IN
THE STATE AND SO.
I PRETTY BRING THIS FORWARD
THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE TO OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THREE THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN CHRIS
WHEN YOU'RE READY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY.
THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
WOULD MANDATE THAT MEDI CAL
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS.
WHEN MEDICALLY NECESSARY FOR THE
MANAGEMENT AND TREATMENT OF
DIABETES.
THE PROPOSAL.
MAY LOOK FAMILIAR AS IT IS
IDENTICAL TO A BILL I CARRIED
LAST YEAR A. B. FOR FORTY SEVEN.
WHICH WOULD HAVE SOUGHT TO
ACCOMPLISH THE EXACT SAME.
THE BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BY
PORTERS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES THE LEGISLATURE. BUT
WAS ULTIMATELY VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE G. H. C. S.
ALREADY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
COVER CGM.
AND IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO.
SINCE THAT TIME DEPARTMENTS
CONTINUOUS CERTAIN THAT THEY ARE
CRAFTING GUIDELINES
TO MAKE SEE GEMS AVAILABLE FOR
MEDI CAL PATIENTS THAT NEED
THEM.
WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING THAT SHE
JAMS ARE ALREADY AVAILABLE FOR
MEDI CAL PATIENTS THAT NEED
THEM.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
DEPARTMENT MAINTAINS THAT THIS
CHANGE WILL GIVE MEDICARE
PATIENTS ACCESS TO SEE GM
WITHOUT THE NEED TO MAKE CGM A
COVERED BENEFIT.
AGAIN WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE.
WHY WON'T DHS MAKERS SEE GEMMA
COVERED BENEFIT IF THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE TECHNOLOGY IS
AVAILABLE TO ALL?
OF THOSE THAT NEED.
THE REALITY IS.
THE PROBLEM IS MADE IT AS HARD
AS POSSIBLE TO THE MEDI CAL
PATIENTS TO ACCESS HE JAMS SO
THAT THEY CAN SAY ALL THE RIGHT
THINGS WHILE CREATING A DE FACTO
BAN ON COVERAGE.
DEPARTMENT SO COMMITTED TO THIS
STRATEGY MACHINE CHAIR THAT.
LAST YEAR AT THE VERY SAME TIME
THAT I WAS RUNNING MY BILL THEY
UNILATERALLY OVERRULED AND
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
WHO REJECTED THEIR INITIAL
DECISION TO DIE COVERAGE FOR A
PATIENT.
SO PATIENTS ARE COVERAGE A
DOCTOR AGREED.
DENIED COVERAGE APPEALED THAT
DECISION TO AN LJ IN LJ AGREED
WITH THE PATIENT
AND THE DEPARTMENT CAME AND USE
THE UNILATERAL AUTHORITY TO
REVERSE THAT DECISION.
MEMBERS TWO POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE DIABETES AND
HALF OF THIS POPULATION IS ON
MEDICARE.
THE RATE OF MEDICARE PATIENTS
WITH DIABETES IS DOUBLE THAT OF
THOSE WITH EMPLOYER SPONSORED
HEALTH INSURANCE.
EVERY COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLAN IN
CALIFORNIA COVERS CGM FOR THE
TREATMENT MANAGEMENT OF
DIABETES.
CG ENDS ARE ALSO COVERED BY
MEDICARE.
COVERED CALIFORNIA.
THE MEDICAID PROGRAMS OF MORE
THAN THIRTY OTHER STATES
NINETY PERCENT OF MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN SERVICES PROGRAM.
MEDICAL STANDS ALONE DENYING CGM
ACCESS TO THEIR PATIENTS.
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MYERS ARE
CLINICALLY PROVEN TO BE THE BEST
TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL TO MENTION
TREAT DIABETES. THEY ARE THE
STANDARD OF CARE FOR EVERY OTHER
PATIENT POPULATION CALIFORNIA
EXCEPT THOSE ON MEDICARE.
WHO IN MANY INSTANCES OF THE
MOST IN NEED OF THIS CRITICAL
TECHNOLOGY?
COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS ARE NOT
REQUIRED BY LAW TO COVER THESE
DEVICES AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
THEY CERTAINLY ARE NOT COVERING
THEM OUT OF THE GOODNESS OF
THEIR HEARTS.
THEY'RE COVERING CGM BECAUSE
THAT RESULTS IN BETTER HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR THE PATIENT
POPULATIONS REDUCES
COMPLICATIONS RESULTING IN
HOSPITALIZATION AND ULTIMATELY
SAVES THE PLANTS MONEY.
CALIFORNIA COULD BENEFIT FROM
THE SAME COST SAVING SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE COST OF
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS WITH
DIABETES IS BORNE BY THE
TAXPAYER.
SO EVEN A MODEST REDUCTION IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS WOULD SEE THE
STATE COME OUT AHEAD FINANCIALLY
CERTAINLY PAY FOR ANY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS. I ASK
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
DEPARTMENTS MAKE CLEAR THEIR
INTENT INTENTION TO CONTINUE
DRAG THEIR FEET ON ADOPTING
COVERAGE CRITERIA. IT'S TIME FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO STEP IN AS WE
ATTEMPTED TO DO LAST YEAR TO
FINALLY BRING AN END TO THIS
DISCRIMINATORY POLICY. THIS
PROPOSAL SUPPORTED BY THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AMONGST OTHERS.
I HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TODAY WHEN IT COMES.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR ABOUT
AND WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE
SEVERAL OTHER FOLKS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT BEGIN. DOCTOR LEVINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DOCTOR MATTHEW LEVINE AND I
THINK A PRACTICING
ENDOCRINOLOGIST FOR THE PAST
THIRTEEN YEARS. CURRENTLY
WORKING AT SCRIPPS CLINIC IN SAN
DIEGO. I'M ALSO THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND PRESIDENT ELECT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
CLINICAL ENDOCRINOLOGIST.
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF A COALITION OF
PHYSICIANS.
DIABETES NURSE EDUCATORS
PATIENTS AND THEIR CAREGIVERS
AND WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE TO PASS OUR
PROPOSAL TO MAKE CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS CGM. A COVERED BENEFIT FOR
MEDI CAL PATIENTS WITH DIABETES.
THE EPIDEMIC THAT IS DIABETES IS
GROWING AND ITS IMPACT ON MEDI
CAL COSTS IS ENORMOUS. ACCORDING
TO A DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TWENTY FIFTEEN REPORT
MEDI CAL SPENDING ON ADULTS
TREATED FOR DIABETES TOTALED
MORE THAN THREE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS ROUGHLY
FOURTEEN PERCENT OF TOTAL
SPENDING ON NON DUAL ELIGIBLES.
THE MOST COSTLY FIVE PERCENT OF
THE DIABETIC POPULATION
GENERATES ROUGHLY THIRTY SIX
PERCENT OF DIABETES SPENDING AT
AN AVERAGE COST OF TWELVE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE DOLLARS PER MEMBER PER
MONTH.
APPROXIMATELY FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHICH IS AROUND ONE
AND SEVEN ADULTS HAVE DIABETES
AND AMONG U. S. STATES
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
INCIDENCE OF DIABETES CASES
ANNUALLY. DIABETES IS THE
SEVENTH LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
IN THIS STATE AND IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
ADULT BLINDNESS KIDNEY FAILURE
AND AMPUTATION OF THE LOWER
EXTREMITIES.
ONE OF THE FACETS OF DIABETES
CARE IS MANAGEMENT OF
HYPOGLYCEMIA OR LOW BLOOD SUGAR
WHICH CAN BE A SIDE EFFECT OF
CRITICAL LIFESAVING TREATMENTS.
TWENTY SIXTEEN DATA FROM THE
JOURNAL DIABETES MEDICINE SHOWS
THAT TWENTY NINE PERCENT UPS OF
YOUR LOW'S RESULT AND AMBULANCE
AND EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES
FURTHER DRIVING UP THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS.
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS
FUNCTION BY CONTINUOUSLY
MONITORING TISSUE FLUID GLUCOSE
LEVELS A SURROGATE MARKER FOR
BLOOD SUGARS AND USE ALARMS AND
ALERTS TO INFORM PATIENTS WHEN
BLOOD SUGAR IS EITHER EXCEEDING
OR FALLING BELOW SAFE LEVELS.
NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE ENDOCRINE SOCIETY AGREE THAT
EXPANDING COVERAGE FOR CGM CAN
LEAD TO IMPROVED OUTCOMES FOR
PAPAL TRIP TO MEET PEOPLE WITH
DIABETES OR DEEMED CANDIDATES
FOR THIS BY THEIR TREATING
PHYSICIAN. ANOTHER STUDY
PUBLISHED JUST THIS MONTH IN
DIABETES CARE DEMONSTRATES THAT
CGM IS COST EFFECTIVE IN TYPE
ONE DIABETES PATIENTS RESULTING
IN IMPROVED BLOOD GLUCOSE
CONTROL AND LESS HYPOGLYCEMIA.
AS AN ANECDOTE I WOULD LIKE TO
BRIEFLY MENTION JOHN A PATIENT
OF MINE WITH DIABETES
JOHN UNFORTUNATELY SUFFERED FROM
A TIME FROM DEBILITATING SEVERE
HYPOGLYCEMIA SUBSEQUENT TO IS
NEEDED INSULIN TREATMENTS.
HE REQUIRED FREQUENT PARAMEDIC
ASSISTANCE AND EMERGENCY ROOM
CARE HIS LIFE AND WORK WERE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED HOWEVER.
HE NOW HAS THE ABILITY THROUGH
THE USE OF CG AND A BETTER
RECOGNIZE IMPENDING LOW OR HIGH
BLOOD SUGARS AND TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION SHOULD BE NEEDED HE HAS
NOT REQUIRED AMBULANCE NOR
EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES IN OVER
ONE YEAR. AND IS UNDER MUCH
BETTER CONTROL OVER ALL.
IN CONCLUSION PUBLIC PAYER SUCH
AS MEDICARE AND EVERY MAJOR
COMMERCIAL PLANNING CALIFORNIA
EXCEPT FOR MEDI CAL CURRENTLY
COVER CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORING TECHNOLOGIES BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE THEIR VALUE IN
IMPROVING OUTCOMES.
PLEASE PASS THIS IMPORTANT
BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH CAN HELP
SAVE LIVES AND SAVE STATE
SPENDING IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY AND I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRAINING A SELECT SEARCH
TOOL CARS AT LEAST SACRAMENTO
COUNTY TEAM USA TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TO APPROVE
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD MAKE CGM A
COVERED BENEFIT MEDI CAL BUT
MAKING CGM AND MEDI CAL COVER
BENEFIT. KIDS LIKE LARA CCS
PROGRAM ON NOW WILL KNOW THAT
THEY CAN KEEP THEIR CGM AS THEY
MOVE INTO ADULT MEDI CAL.
I'M A FORMER CALIFORNIA FOSTER
CHILD WITH TYPE ONE DIABETES
A WAS DIAGNOSED EIGHTEEN MONTHS
THAT THIS AUTOIMMUNE INCURABLE
DISEASE.
DESPITE HAVING TEA TYPES OF
INSULIN TESTING UPWARDS TO
TWELVE TIMES A DAY AND MARK TO
INJECTIONS.
SHORTLY AFTER I WAS DIAGNOSED I
SHOULD MOVE FOR MY BIOLOGICAL
PARENTS
LIKELY ONE FOSTER PARENT WAS A
TYPE ONE DIABETIC AS WELL SO
MADE THE TRANSITION A LITTLE
EASIER.
ABILITY TO FOSTER HOMES BEFORE
WAS PLACED WITHIN ADOPTED BY MY
DAD'S.
TOGETHER WE DECIDED IT WAS TIME
TO GET AN INSULIN PUMP THE PUMP
ALLOWED ME TO CUSTOMIZE MY BASAL
RATE AND FREEDOM FROM MANY
OBJECTIONS.
BUT I STILL HAD CHALLENGES WITH
LOW AND HIGH BLOOD SUGARS.
MY DOCTOR PRESCRIBED A
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORING
SYSTEM A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO TO
HELP ME KEEP MY BLOOD SUGARS AND
WITHIN THE SAFE RANGE. IT HAS
BEEN AMAZING.
MY PARENTS ABLE TO MONITOR MY
BLOOD GLUCOSE FROM A DISTANCE
LIKE FROM WORK EVER RECEIVE
UPDATES EVERY FEW MINUTES.
HAVING BE DEXCOM HAS ALLOWED ME
TO COMPETE SUCCESSFULLY IN
PATENTS BEER CHAMPION HORSE
RIDER OWNER AND BREEDER OF MY
OWN NIGERIAN DWARF GOATS HEARD.
FORMER MENTOR TO FOSTER YOUTH
THE CLASH
TO AN AFFRONT TO YOU THE
QUESTION OF THE SORORITY ANYBODY
SIMPLE THINGS LIKE OVER TO
FRIENDS HOUSES AND HAVE
SLEEPOVERS WITHOUT ANY WORRY.
BUY DEXCOM HAS ALARMS THAT
ENABLE ME AND OTHERS TO IT TO
SEE QUICKLY TO PROVIDE LOW AND
HIGH BLOOD SUGARS.
THESE ALARMS ALERT MY PARENTS
BECAUSE HONESTLY SOMETIMES I
BECOME DEAF TO IT.
I'M ABLE TO GET REPORTS
ACCURATELY ADJUST MY BASE RATES
NOT ABLE TO TEST LESS OFTEN.
THOUGH I AM VERY BUSY NOW MY
LONG TERM GOAL IS TO ATTEND UC
DAVIS LIKE MY DAD EXPERT.
WE COME A LARGE ANIMAL
VETERINARIAN.
I ALSO JIM ADJOINING THEIR
HUNTER JUMPER QUESTIONING TEAM.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THIS THAT I ASK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TO
APPROVE LANGUAGE SO THAT I AND
OTHERS.
COVER BY CCS WILL CONTINUE TO
PURSUE OUR DREAMS WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION THINK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY STORY.
THANK YOU AS WELL FOR YOUR
POISON ADVOCACY.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE THREE.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT AS
OUR LEGAL AID ADVOCATES HAVE
REPORTED CLIENTS DIFFICULTY IN
ACCESSING THIS DESPITE BEING
MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCE FROM HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
SIR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALL OF IRAQ
RIGHT CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS WENDY CHAD I OF
A NINETEEN YEAR OLD TWO ND
DAUGHTER.
UNDERSTANDING FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WHAT A DIFFERENCE
CONTINUOUS MONITORS CAN BE AND
WHAT THEY CAN DO TO HELP PROTECT
GLUCOSE TRENDS GIVE BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND BETTER
OVERALL. CARE FOR OUR CHILDREN
AND ADULTS LIVING WITH T. ONE
D..
POINTS THIS OUT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR ME TODAY
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS ALSO
ALLOW US AS PARENTS TO LIVE IN
LESS FEAR AND BE MORE PRODUCTIVE
IN OUR LIVES SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
WE CAN.
THOMAS ERIC'S IN SUPPORT OF MY
DAUGHTER ANOTHER CC ESSE.
PARTICIPANT AND SPORT. THANK YOU
SIR.
STEPHANIE KLEIN FROM CARMICHAEL
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
DOCUMENT.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTY CASTILLO I
AM A NURSE DIABETES EDUCATOR AND
OF ALL THE LIQUID TYPE ONE
DIABETES FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
PRIOR TO SEEGM ACCESS I A.
EXPERIENCED EVENTS OF SEVERE
HIGH AND SEVERE LOW BLOOD SUGARS
THAT REQUIRED EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
AFTER HAVING ACCESS TO SEE IN
THERAPY I WAS ABLE TO LEARN THE
RHYTHMS OF MY BODY. WHICH I WAS
ABLE TO KEEP MY BLOOD SUGARS
SAFE AND MAKE TREATMENT
DECISIONS APPROPRIATELY WITH
INSULIN.
DOING SO WITH ALL ALLOWED ME TO
MEET MY OWN PERSONAL GOALS WHICH
I WAS ABLE TO OBTAIN LAST YEAR
RUNNING A MARATHON WHICH WOULD
HAVE NEVER BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT
CGM THERAPY.
SO I WAS AFFORDED THIS GREAT
TOOL TAKE CARE FOR MYSELF SO I
CAN LIVE WELL EVERYONE SHOULD
GET THIS OPPORTUNITY THERE
SHOULD BE NO DISPARITY AMONG
ANYONE. TO LIVE LIFE FULLY AND
SAFE AND WELL WITH THAT TYPE ONE
OR TYPE TWO DIABETES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
LOOKING GRADUATES.
HI MY NAME IS SUZANNE WELLNESS
AND I M. AND ALSO IN OUR AND
CERTIFIED DIABETES EDUCATOR. AND
I AM HERE ON REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF DIABETES
EDUCATORS.
I ALSO LIVE WITH TYPE ONE
DIABETES I'VE HAD IT FOR THE
PAST THIRTY YEARS. I WAS.
BLESSED TO BE INTRODUCED THROUGH
THE CGM IN TWO THOUSAND SIX SO
I'VE WORN THIS FLOOR WIDE AND.
TWELVE YEARS.
IT IS ALLOWED ME TO ON. MATT
WELL JUST CONTROL MY BLOOD
SUGARS IT'S ALLOWED I CARRY THIS
DEVICE WITH ME ALL THE TIME.
I HAVE A CONNECTED TO MY IPHONE.
I CAN LOOK AT THIS EVERY MOMENT
OF THE DAY AND KNOW WHAT MY
BLOOD SUGARS ARE.
YOUR BLOOD SUGARS THOUGH IT'S
THEY STAGNANT THROUGHOUT THE
THROUGHOUT THE DAY THEY CHANGE
AND IT ALLOWED ME. TO SEE THE
TRENDS AND MAKE THOSE CITING
CHANGES LIKE AVOID HYPOGLYCEMIA
OR AVOID THE HIGHS AND BRING IT
DOWN.
BUT THE HARDEST THING FOR ME IS
AS A DIABETES EDUCATOR NOT BEING
ABLE TO GIVE THAT. THIS TOOL TO
MY PATIENTS
SADLY ONE OF MY AND THIS IS ONE
STORY OF MANY WE SHARED BUT
SADLY ONE OF MY PATIENTS WAS ON
THE MEDI CAL.
COVERAGE DIDN'T WAS DENIED THIS
TOOL NUMEROUS TIMES.
HE DIDN'T GATHERED AND TELL
CLOSE TO THE END OF HIS LIFE
WHEN HE FINALLY GOT IT AND THE
LOOK IN HIS EYES WHEN HE GOT
THIS WAS AMAZING IT WAS A TOOL
LIKE HEAT I WISHED HE WOULD HAVE
HAD IT BEFORE. AND THE HARDEST
THING FOR ME AS I SAID IS ALL
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT CURRENTLY
ARE BIG THAT NIGHT THIS.
SHOULD NOT BE HAPPENING.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU. TO
HAVE THIS INCLUDED IN THE MEDI
CAL BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AARON KELLY AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION REPRESENTING NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PEDIATRIC
SUBSPECIALTY PHYSICIANS WHO CARE
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS
LIKE ALEXIS.
AS PART OF THE CHILDREN
SERVICES PROGRAM IN STRONG
SUPPORT EGGMAN.
HI AMLEE FATES REPRESENTING THE
DIATRIBE FOUNDATION.
IMAGINE A PILOT FLYING A PLANE
BLINDFOLD ADDED AND ONLY GETTING
TO TAKE OFF THE BLINDFOLD ONCE
EVERY FOUR HOURS.
THAT'S WHAT MANAGING DIABETES
WITHOUT SEJAM AS LIKE AS WE KNOW
IT IS THE STANDARD OF CARE. AND
ALMOST ALL PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS AND MEDICARE
COVER IT
NOT ONLY IS IT COST EFFECTIVE AS
WE'VE HEARD.
IN TERMS OF REDUCE SAYING THAT
MONEY SPENT ON HOSPITALIZATIONS
DUE TO SEVERE HYPOGLYCEMIA.
SWALLOWS LACK OF PRODUCTIVITY
AND LONG TERM COMPLICATIONS BUT
IT ALSO IMPROVES SHORT TERM
QUALITY OF LIFE.
BEING ABLE TO MEASURE YOUR TIME
IN RANGE AND BLOOD SUGAR
THROUGHOUT THE DAY IS THE METRIC
THAT REALLY DICTATES A PERSON'S
QUALITY OF LIFE WITH DIABETES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ACUMEN.
HELLO I'M LISA MURDOCH
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL I HAD A BROTHER
WHO PASSED AWAY DURING AN
INCIDENT OF A SEVERE
HYPOGLYCEMIA TWENTY YEARS AGO.
I WOULD HAVE LOVED FOR HIM TO
HAVE THIS TECHNOLOGY AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY ELSE
WHO NEEDS IT HAS ASKED.
THE GAME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS STEEL I
DROVE UP FROM SAN DIEGO FOR THIS
HEARING.
.
I'VE HAD TYPE ONE DIABETES FIFTY
EIGHT YEARS.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY WHEN I WAS
DIAGNOSED BY PAUL WOULD DRIVE ME
TO THE HOSPITAL SATURDAY MORNING
THAT DROP BUT TELL ME TUESDAY
AFTERNOON WHAT WHAT MY SATURDAY
MORNING BLOOD SUGAR WAS AS IF I
COULD DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT. BY
THE YOU KNOW.
THE CGM IS A TREMENDOUS
IMPROVEMENT IT SAY'S SAVE MY
LIFE MANY TIMES.
SINCE I STARTED ON IT IN ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND INCLUDING LAST
NIGHT I ALMOST DIDN'T MAKE IT TO
THE HEARING BECAUSE OF AN
INCIDENT YESTERDAY SO. YOU SEE
MY LIFE LAST NIGHT AND I THINK
EVERYONE SHOULD.
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS TECHNOLOGY
IF THEY HAVE DIABETES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR.
I.
HELLO MY NAME IS LORRAINE STEEL
I AM THE PROUD SPOUSE OF KRIS DE
L. FROM SAN DIEGO.
AND.
FOR THE PERSON WITH TYPE ONE
DIABETES IT IS A LIFE SAVER. FOR
THE CAREGIVER THE SPOUSE THE
FAMILY MEMBER IT IS SUCH PEACE
OF MIND
YOU CAN'T BELIEVE HOW
CHALLENGING IT IS TO WORRY ABOUT
YOUR LOVED ONES.
DIABETES AND THE AND LOW BLOOD
SUGARS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. AND. I
HAVE HAD
PROBABLY THOUSANDS OF EPISODES
IN THIRTY THREE YEARS OF
MARRIAGE WHERE WE HAVE.
I'VE HAD TO PULL MY HUSBAND OUT
OF THE LIFE
THREATENING LOW. I'VE HAD
PARAMEDICS AT OUR HOUSE TOO MANY
TIMES TO COUNT.
BUT MUST SAY THAT THAT HAS
REALLY CHANGEDWITH THE CGM.
AND I SEE OUR RIFF SAN DIEGO
PARAMEDICS FAR FEWER TIMES EACH
YEAR. I KIND OF MISS THOSE HUNKY
FIREMAN IN MY BEDROOM AT THREE
IN THE MORNING. FROM TIME TO
TIME BUT THE REALITY IS.
IT IS SAVING MY HUSBAND'S LIFE
THE CGM AND IT IS A SHAME IF
THERE ARE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
NOT ABLE TO GET.
THIS LIFESAVING TREATMENT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH HERE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KRISTA MCEWAN AND I'M FROM SAN
DIEGO I'VE HAD TYPE ONE DIABETES
AND HOW FAR.
COMING UP ON FOURTEEN YEARS.
DIABETES IS A CHALLENGING
DISEASE BECAUSE OUR MANY FACTORS
ON THE PACK MY BLOOD SUGAR.
SO MANY OF THE OTHER FEELS LIKE
IT CAN ALMOST CONSUMES ME.
FINGER PRICKS.
CANNOT PROVIDE THE SAME BENEFITS
OF A CDM.
HAVING. CONTINUOUS UPDATES ON
MY.
ON HOW MY BLOOD SUGARS DOING HAS
CHANGED MY BEHAVIOR IN THE WAY
THAT I MANAGE MY DIABETES
BETTER.
BECAUSE IT IS MORE TANGIBLE.
THIS OF I SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR A VULNERABLE
POPULATION.
SUCH AS THE MEDI CAL PATIENTS.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT QUALITY CARE
AND APPROVING THIS FUNDING BUT
IT KEEP US ON THAT PATH.
THANK YOU
THEY CAN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS USE
LEER CAME OVER HERE FROM SAN
DIEGO TO SHOW SUPPORT. AND I
REALLY CAN'T.
SAY ANYTHING BETTER THAN ALL
THESE OTHER PEOPLE ON THIS ISSUE
HAVE SAID FOR THE FACTS OR
STATISTICS SAID.
.
BUT THAT MEANS SAID EVERYBODY IN
HERE PROBABLY HAS.
AT SOME POINT OF THEIR TIME AT
A LEVEL ONE OR FAMILY MEMBER
FRIEND.
THAT IS.
.
CREE DIABETIC MAYBE DIABETIC
AND.
THIS WILL AFFECT.
PRETTY MUCH SOMEWHERE YOU'LL
KNOW YOU'RE GUARANTEED.
IN SOME WITH THIS CG.
M. GIVES THESE PEOPLE A NEW
LEASE ON LIFE AND RELIGIOUS.
IS LIFE CHANGE I YOU'VE HEARD
PEOPLE THAT I DON'T HAVE TYPE
ONE HER TOO BUT.
YOU CAN SEE HOW IT REALLY
CHANGES PEOPLE'S LIVES AND.
JUST THE FACT THAT TO SAVE SO
MUCH MONEY IS.
ONE HUGE THING IN.
DIDN'T SOME THAT'S REALLY GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO BE ALIVE
ISN'T OF THIS.
PRAYER THE NEXT
WE'RE JUST IMPORTANT SO.
PLEASE GIVE.
ALL THESE PEOPLE JUST THAT.
STANDARD MEDICAL.
RIGHT TO HAVE A.
THE MONITOR.
AND.
THERE'S COMMON SAYING WHAT GETS.
.
WHAT GETS MEASURE GETS MANAGED
AND THIS IS CAMERAMAN'S ME THAT
WHAT GETS?
MONITORED GETS.
MANAGE SO PEOPLE CAN JUST.
LIVE A SOMEWHAT NORMAL LIFE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU SIR.
TIM MADDEN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE MAYOR
COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ALL THE REASONS
STATED THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUES THREE.
WE HAD SEVERAL QUESTIONS WITHIN
THE AGENDA AND I WAS WONDERING
IF WE COULD HAVE.
RA NAME BELOW FROM THAT THE
AIDS HE ASKED. THOSE QUESTIONS.
HELLO THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR NAY MAILLOT
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO THERE WERE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS THAT I DE EACH CS WAS
ASKED TO RESPOND TO. AS I'M JUST
GONNA KINDA COMPREHENSIVELY
COVER QUESTIONS SO CURRENTLY CDM
IS NOT A COVERED MEDI CAL
BENEFIT AS HAS BEEN STATED
TODAY.
I'M IT IS CONSIDERED TO BE A NON
COVERED BENEFITS SO THERE ARE
PROCESSES IN PLACE WHEREBY FOR
NON COVERED BENEFITS UNDER THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM. PEOPLE CAME
REQUEST UP PHYSICIANS CAN
REQUEST THOSE SERVICES USING PAR
AUTHORIZATION ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE WARRANTED IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH AYE SUPPORTERS
OF THIS PROPOSAL. IS THAT WE'RE
WORKING TO PUT OUT SOME
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA AND OUR
MEDICAL PROVIDER MANUALS TO HELP
EDUCATE THE PROVIDERS HOW TO
SUBMIT REQUESTS FOR THE SERVICES
USUALLY USING SPECIAL HANDLING.
REQUIREMENTS OF THOSE AYE
TARBERT QUEST
AND TOWARDS OUR TREATMENT
AUTHORIZATION REQUEST BECAUSE
THIS WOULD BE SOMETHING ABOUT BE
PAR AUTHORIZED UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT. AND IN ORDER TO DO
THAT PROVIDERS WOULD HAVE TO
SUBMIT THE TAURUS ELECTRONICALLY
SO WE'RE LOOKING TO RELEASE AN
AUTOMATIC CAO PROVIDER BULLETIN
AROUND MID MAY. SOME CRITERIA TO
HELP PROVIDERS IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS IS THAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO SUBMIT THOSE CARS SO THAT
THOSE POWERS CAN THEN BE
DIRECTED. TO MEDICAL STAFF
WITHIN THE PROGRAM TO LOOK AT
THE REVIEW AND.
MAKE DETERMINATIONS BASED UPON
MEDICAL NECESSITY THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE CCS ELIGIBLE CONDITIONS WHO
MAY BE AUTHORIZED FOR THE
SERVICES AND ONCE THEY ONCE THEY
AGE OUT OF THE CCS PROGRAM. THAT
HOW IT THOSE SERVICES BE COVERED
AGAIN BASED UPON THE
SUBSTANTIATION UP PROMESAS CITY
ONCE THE A DOT OF THE PROGRAM IT
WOULD BE PAR AUTHORIZED. AND
THEN THAT REQUEST WILL COME INTO
THE DEPARTMENT WITH THE
DOCUMENTATION TO DEMONSTRATE
MEDICAL NECESSITY. BECAUSE IT'S
A NON COVERED BENEFIT TODAY IT
IS LIKELY THAT THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE MEDICAL
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE NOT RECEIVED
THIS BENEFIT. BUT AGAIN WE'RE
LOOKING AT WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
ADDRESS THAT THROUGH.
.
CLEAR DIRECTIONSFOR HOW TO
REQUEST SERVICES FOR BENEFITS
OUT AMONG COVERED UNDER THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM AND WE HAVE NOT.
BECAUSE AGAIN THAT THE WAY IT'S
ADMINISTERED UNDER OUR PROGRAM
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY DISPARITIES
IN TERMS OF REQUEST COMING AND
OR HOW SERVICES ARE BEING
AUTHORIZED.
THE OTHER THING I DID WANT TO
MAKE MENTION OF.
IS THAT WITH THE MEDICAL
POPULATION TODAY ABOUT EIGHTY
PERCENT ARE ON MANAGE THROUGH
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS SO
OUR MEDICAID MANAGED CARE PLANS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT HE COVERED
BENEFIT. DO HAVE THE ABILITY
SHOULD THEY DESIRE TO MAKE THIS
BENEFIT AVAILABLE TO THE
BENEFICIARIES THAT THEY SERVE
BUT THEY DO HAVE AT THEIR
DISPOSAL. THE ABILITY TO MANAGE
THAT CONTINUUM OF CARE NEEDS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH CHRONIC MEDICAL
CONDITIONS INCLUDING DIABETES
AND SO THERE WAS A QUESTION
ABOUT HOSPITALIZATIONS AND SO.
THAT'S KIND OF THE CORNERSTONE
OF THE WORK THAT MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS DO AS HELPING
TO MANAGE AND THAT I'M LEAST
RESTRICTIVE WAY LEAST COSTLY
MANNER IN TERMS OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH CHRONIC MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
AND WHAT THAT I WELCOME ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS SO.
.
THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF THAT
THAT.
I'M STRUGGLING WITH BUT.
.
MAYBE I'LL GIVE MYSELF A MINUTE
AND ALLOW DOCTOR WOULD TO GO
FIRST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR.
COMMENTS AB COUPLE COUPLE
QUESTIONS SO.
.
I MISTER GRAY TALKED ABOUT A
CASE WORD AND.
WHERE DR?
DESCRIBES FOR PATIENT.
WENT TO ALL WHICH UNIT
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE THEY
OVERTURNED THAT. SEEM TO BE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT MEDICAL
CERTAINTY OR OUR MEDICAL NEED IN
A CASE LIKE THAT BUT I AM
CURIOUS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THESE PRETREATMENT THESE
PRIVATIZATIONS.
HOW WHAT'S THE PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE THAT? A FLAW APPLY FOR A
PRE AUTHORIZATION THAT ACTUALLY
GET THE DEVICE.
I DON'T HAVE THAT DATA I CAN
MAKE THAT AVAILABLE.
YOU YOU CAN OKAY I CAN GO BACK
AND HAVE STAFF LOOK AT A AND I
AM PUZZLED YOU KNOW WITH WITH.
LIKE THE YOUNG LADY HERE.
THE ELOQUENTLY YOUNG LADY OF
WHAT I.
.
YOU KNOW SHE'S GONNA SHE'S GONNA
FACE A POINT WHEN SHE TURNS
EIGHTEEN AND IS NO LONGER
COVERED WITH CCS.
PEOPLE OF TYPE ONE DIABETES
DON'T AGE OUT OF TYPE ONE
DIABETES.
SO WHY WOULD THEY HAVE TO THEN
GO TO ANOTHER PROCESS.
TO ASSIST TO ASCERTAIN THE
MEDICAL NECESSITY FOR THE DEVICE
THAT THEY'VE BEEN USING. UNDER
THE CCS PROGRAM I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT SO BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THE BENEFIT IS COVERED
TODAY SOMEONE AT THE NON COVERED
BENEFIT ABOUT WHEN WE LOOK AT.
CGM IT WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND
FOR MOST DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT THAT IS COVERED BY THE
MEDIC CAO PROGRAM. PAR
AUTHORIZATION IS REQUIRED SO
IT'S JUST THE SUBSTANTIATION AND
RECOGNIZE SEEN. WHEN INDIVIDUALS
ARE COVERED UNDER THE MATTER HOW
PROGRAM WHEN THEY ARE UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE AS A CHILD
THEY ARE CONSIDERED. I'M
ELIGIBLE UNDER WHAT WE CALL E.
PIASKI T. EARLY PERIODIC
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS.
AND TREATMENT SERVICES SO THOSE
SERVICES HAVE AN EXPANDED
MEDICAL NECESSITY REQUIREMENT
THAT IS NOT THE SAME FOR ADULTS
ONCE THEY EIGHT OUT OF. BEING
TWENTY ONE AMBIEN AT BEING
CONSIDERED A CHILD UNDER THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM SO THERE'S A
DIFFERENT STANDARD OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY BUT AS AN ADULT WE DO
LOOK AT. WHAT WAS SAPE
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED AND THEN
BASED UPON WHAT'S COVERED UNDER
OUR PROGRAM FOR A IN THIS
INSTANCE IF IT'S AMONG COVERED
BENEFIT? AGAIN WE WOULD LOOK AT
THE SUBSTANTIATION OF SAY PRIOR
NEED AND THEN USE THAT
INFORMATION TO THEM MAKE A
DETERMINATION OF ONGOING MEDICAL
NECESSITY.
SO THEN I GUESS MY FINAL
QUESTION IS.
.
WHITE Y. SCOUT IS SO MANY OTHER
STATES HAVE THIS IS PART OF THE
PROGRAM AND THEIR PROGRAMS WHY
WHITE Y. WHEAT Y. WE NOT DOING
THIS WE SPEND SO MUCH MONEY ON
TREATMENT.
AND INSTEAD OF PREVENTING SOME
OF THE EPISODES THAT DRIVE
PEOPLE TO EMERGENCY ROOMS THAT
BRING OUT FIRST RESPONDERS.
WHAT WHAT WHAT AM I MISSING HERE
WHITE WHAT? WHY IT WHY ARE WE
NOT INVESTING IN THESE THESE
KINDS OF DEVICES THAT CAN REALLY
HELP PEOPLE THEIR QUALITY OF
LIFE AND SAVE US MONEY ON THE
OTHER END I'M I'M? A MISSING
SOMETHING HELP ME UNDERSTAND SO
I THINK PART OF IT IS LOOKING AT
BECAUSE THERE'S MANY DEVICES
THAT ARE OUT THERE IN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY WE IS THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT IS A PUBLICLY
FINANCED PROGRAM. WE'RE LOOKING
AT THOSE DEVICES THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE TO INDIVIDUALS.
SEE THAT HAS BEEN DETERMINED
BASED UPON SAY PEER REVIEWED
JOURNALS EVIDENCE BASED MEDICINE
SO THIS IS SOMETHING AGAIN
BROUGHT TAR TENSION WE'VE HAD
THE DISCUSSIONS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
THIS WHAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DO IS USE THE DATA THAT WILL
COME INTO LAST ONCE WE PUT OUT
THIS INFORMATION. FOR HOW ON
PROVIDERS CAN REQUEST THIS
BENEFIT TO GET MORE INFORMATION
IN TERMS OF HOW WE MAY LOOK TO
COVER THIS IF IT IS DETERMINED
EITHER THROUGH THIS BODY OR
THROUGH OTHER MEANS OF US
COVERING THIS AS A COVERED
BENEFIT UNDER THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM.
BUT.
OKAY AND I'D SPOT COMMEND YOU MR
GRAY AFTER YOUR PERSISTENCE ON
THIS I MEAN YOU HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR AND. I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS.
I'M GONNA ADD MY BIASES WELL
AND.
IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME I'D LIKE
TO SHARE A PERSONAL STORY MY
FATHER IN LAW SUFFERS FROM
DIABETES THAT.
HE GOT FROM EXPOSURE TO AGENT
ORANGE IN THE VIETNAM WAR. AND
HE.
.
STRUGGLES OFTENTIMES TO HELP TO
CONTROL HIS BLOOD SUGARS AS
WELL.
AND BUREAUCRACY THROUGH THE
VETERANS ADMINISTRATION HAS.
FORCED HIM TO GO OUTSIDE OF THE
SYSTEM TO PURCHASE A CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITOR HIMSELF.
AND WHAT I'M HEARING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT NOW HAS ECHOES OF
THAT SAME BARACK.
AND I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
WHEN WE HAVE A EVIDENCE BASED.
A MONITOR THAT'S IN FRONT OF US
THAT REALLY DOES HELP TO.
EXPAND SERVICES INCREASED
TREATMENT INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE DISEASE
PROCESS. WIRE WE AS A STATE NOT
FUNDING THIS PROGRAM NOW.
AND WHAT DO YOU NEED FROM US AS
A LEGISLATURE TO SHOW OUR
INTEREST IN THE STATION. IN THIS
ISSUE AND WANTING TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE.
NOW COVER THIS AS AN ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFIT.
I MEAN I THINK THE INTEREST HAS
BEEN CLEARLY DEMONSTRATED HERE
IN THIS HEARING AND AND THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED TO THE DEPARTMENT.
.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FURTHER INFORMATION TO OUR.
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF SO THAT WE
MAY UNDERSTAND THE COST THAT IS
BEFORE US AND MAKE SURE THAT.
ANYTHING ANY INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED PRIOR TO MY REVISION IS
PRESENT SO THAT WE CAN. GIVE
THIS PROPOSAL.
UP ALL THE DUE DILIGENCE THAT
IS NECESSARY.
YES
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
APPRECIATE THE.
IN DEPTH DISCUSSION IMPORTANT
ISSUE ARE.
SOME OF THE ANSWERS FRANKLY AT
THAT WE GET OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PARTNERS.
PARTICULAR ISSUE JUST BECOME
INSULT INSULTING TO OUR
INTELLIGENCE
I INSULT TO THIS COMMITTEE. A.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT BOTH TUGS
AT OUR HEARTSTRINGS BUT ALSO
MAKES SENSE FOR OUR WALLETS WE
SAVE MONEY WE SAVE LIVES.
TOM THIS IS ALSO A PERSONAL
ISSUE.
FOR ME AS YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR
I HAVE TO MEMBERS OF MY
IMMEDIATE FAMILY.
WHO HAVE SUFFERED FROM TYPE ONE
DIABETES MY MOTHER GOT UP SIXTY
EIGHT TIMES A NIGHT FOR MANY
MANY MANY YEARS?
UP UNTIL MY SISTER WENT TO
COLLEGE AND I THINK SHE STILL
GETS UP AND CHECKS THE. NOW
MONITOR ON THE CELLPHONE.
THANKS TO THIS SITE.
NEW AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGIES BUT
TO DENY THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AYE IS IMMORAL. A
IT'S COSTING THE STATE MONEY AYE
EVERY OTHER PRIVATE SECTOR
PROGRAM AND MOST OTHER STATES
WOULD BE DOING THIS IF THAT
WEREN'T TRUE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THE COMMITTEE'S APPROVAL
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. WHEN
THIS COMES FOR YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
AND WITH THAT WE WILL ISSUE
THREE OPEN.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SKIP AHEAD TO
ISSUE SEVEN
.
AND FOR THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO
ARE WAITING I APOLOGIZE BUT WE
HAVE A WITNESS WHO NEEDS TO
LEAVE.
SO APOLOGIES
.
I
WITH READY AT THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS MY NAME IS
FRED NO WHEREIN WE HAVE
REPRESENTED THE A LS ASSOCIATION
FOR OVER TEN YEARS. WE HEARD
TODAY FOR A BUDGET REQUEST. I
THINK EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS VERY WELL THAT A DIAGNOSIS
DIAGNOSIS OF LOU GEHRIG'S
DISEASE IS A REAL TOUGH.
TOUGH DIAGNOSIS ENDA WITH ME
TODAY IS FRED FISHER THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
ASSOCIATION.
AND OUR GOOD FRIEND RUSTY SEE
LEX WHO WAS RECENTLY DIAGNOSED
WITH A LS.
WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS OF PATIENTS WHO HAVE A
LS ARE GROWING IN CALIFORNIA.
THE CASELOAD IS GROWING FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS ONE IS PEOPLE
ARE LIVING LONGER. AND JUST
OVERALL WITH EACH WITH THE
OVERALL INCREASE IN THE
POPULATION. OF THE NUMBERS ARE
GROWING AND THE ASSOCIATION
WHICH PROVIDE SO MANY ESSENTIAL
SERVICES TO PEOPLE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH THE DISEASE. IS
NOT ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THAT
GROWING DIM DEMAND. ITEM I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT. WE'RE
DISTRIBUTING A MEMO FROM MAYOR
STEINBERG OF SACRAMENTO. A HE
WAS A WONDERFUL A CHAMPION OF
OF.
OF HOURS WHEN HE WAS THE SENATE
PASSED A BILL IN FIFTY IN THEM.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SENATE BILL
FIFTY NO THREE THAT SET FORTH IN
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE THE
OPTIMAL MODEL OF CARE. WHICH THE
LS ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN ABLE TO
REPLICATE AROUND THE STATE.
AND.
.
MAYBE I'LL JUST TURN OVER TO
MISTER FISHER AND TELL FROM
THEIR.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING.
CHILDREN ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO THE LARGEST
AIR LESS PATIENT POPULATION IN
NORTH AMERICA.
AND THE A OR ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S THE COUNTRY'S
LARGEST PROVIDER OF COMMUNITY
AND HOME BASED SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S AIRWEST COMMUNITY.
SP FIFTEEN NO THREE SPONSORED BY
SENATOR STEINBERG ESTABLISHED AN
EVIDENCE BASED
SYSTEM OF CARE. THAT IS
CURRENTLY THE ONLY WAY TO
MEANINGFULLY IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE AND LENGTH OF LIFE.
PEOPLE LIVING WITH A LESS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO WERE
DIAGNOSED AS WELL AS THOSE WHO
ARE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
CAREGIVERS.
THE SYSTEM IS BASED ON A SET OF
ROBUST CLINIC COMMUNITY AND HOME
BASED SERVICES CREATING ACCESS
TO A FULL WRAPAROUND MODEL OF
CARE.
AND LONGER AND DIE TYPICALLY
WITHIN THREE YEARS AFTER
DIAGNOSIS IN THEIR HOMES.
THE SYSTEM WHICH IS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN AIRWEST
ASSOCIATION CERTIFY TREATMENT
CENTERS AND AFFILIATED MEDICAL
CLINICS WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP.
WITH OUR COMMUNITY BASED CARE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IS COVERED BY
MEDICARE AND OTHER THIRD PARTY
PAYORS. THIS COVERAGE ONLY
AMOUNTS TO ABOUT TEN PERCENT.
THE COST.
THE REMAINDER IS COVERED BY
PHILANTHROPY.
WHICH MEANS THAT THE AWACS
COMMUNITY IS UNDERWRITING ABOUT
NINETY PERCENT OF THE COST OF
THEIR CARE.
THE DRAMATIC GROWTH IN THE AIR
WEST PATIENT POPULATION A STRAIN
THE SYSTEM TO THE BREAKING
POINT.
PHILANTHROPY BRIAN FROM THE
AWACS COMMUNITY CANNOT KEEP PACE
WITH THE GROWING DEMANDS FOR
SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA'S NOW WARRANT LEADER
NEUROGENIC DISEASE SCIENCE.
AND IS NOW WORLD LEADER IN A
LESS CARE.
IT CREATES A FULL BENCH TO
BEDSIDE PLATFORM.
THROUGH WHICH EFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS AND CURES ARE TESTED
FOR A O. S. AND RELATED
DISORDERS.
THOSE LIVING WITH THIS DISEASE
NEED THE STATE'S HELP IN
UNDERWRITING THE SYSTEM OF CARE
THAT WILL ENABLE THE SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY TO PURSUE PROGRESS.
WHILE ENABLING THE ONE IN FOUR
HUNDRED WHO WILL BE DIAGNOSED.
INCLUDING VETERANS WHO CONTRACT
A WEST AT TWICE THE RATE OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BENEFIT FROM
THE ONLY TREATMENT THAT WILL
HELP THEM LIVE LONGER AND
BETTER.
THE SYSTEM OF CARE THAT S. BE
FIFTEEN OH THREE ESTABLISHED.
AND ARE BUDGET REQUEST WILL
ASSIST IN FUNDING.
Q. A MISTER CHAIRMAN RUSTY SEAL
ACCEPT PATIENTS WITH IOS.
AT THIS TIME LAST YEAR IN EACH
OF THE PREVIOUS THIRTY YEARS I.
CAME BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE
WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESSES.
IRONICALLY THOSE ARE PERFECT
PARALLEL IN THAT CHAIR STEINBERG
OF COURSE WAS ARE CHAMPION FROM
ON HOW. THE FIRST STEP HAD BEEN.
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS CREATING
THE SYSTEM A CURRENT STATUTE THE
NEXT STEP WAS FUNDING AND THAT'S
WHAT HE AND I DID TOGETHER FOR
MANY YEARS. BUT THE PARALLEL
EXTENDS THE FACT THAT WE KNEW
WITH PEOPLE NOW UNLESS IT'S
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
AND WHAT THEY'LL LAST WENT
ALRIGHT FACE WHEN ALL OF US WHEN
THEY LOST FACE. IS THAT THERE IS
A FUNCTIONAL RATING SCALE ON
TWELVE ASPECTS OF DAILY LIVING.
AND WE DECLINE AN AVERAGE POINT
A MONTH.
SO EVERY MONTH WE HAVE A NEW
CHALLENGE
OF SOMETHING THAT WE USED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT WE CAN'T
ANYMORE.
AND HOW DO WE MANAGE OUR LIFE
AND HOW TO WE ADJUSTED. ON THAT
NEW CHALLENGE.
THIS EL LAST CLINIC MODEL WHERE
EVERY THREE MONTHS WE SEE THE
CLINIC TEAM. OF.
YEAH SIX PEOPLE SAY YES OVER
THREE HOUR VISIT. WHEN I FIRST
STARTED GETTING THOSE BENEFITS
LAST SUMMER I HAD NO IDEA THAT
IT WASN'T ALL COVERED BY
INSURANCE WAS ONLY WHEN I
LEARNED THAT.
PHILANTHROPY SO I THANK FRED AND
I THINK THE AIR LOS ASSOCIATION.
FOR MAKING THIS CARE POSSIBLE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I BENEFITING
FROM HIGH ABOVE. MUCH BETTER
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT I WOULD NOT
HAVE WITHOUT IT BUT IT'S
APPARENT THAT FUNDING IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. AND.
YOU KNOW WE FACE THE CHALLENGES
OF DETERIORATING HEALTH AND. IN
MANY MANY WAYS ARM REMARKED Y.
BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE RIGHT NOW
I'VE HAD TO LEARN I CAN'T WERE
CLOSED WITH BUTTONS.
BOB I CAN'T OPEN CLOSE BUTTON
RESERVE PERSONAL THINGS LIKE
THAT THESE A PART OF THE.
ADAPTATIONS WE LEARN.
AND.
AS WE GO THROUGH THIS AND THE
TEAM HELPS SNOW WHAT CAN YOU DO
ARM HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU MANAGE
YOUR LIFE AND AND FUNCTIONS SO.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THING.
FOR THOSE OF US WITH THIS VERY
VERY SERIOUS DISEASE AND SO I
HOPE THAT THAT YOU'LL LOOK.
POSITIVELY ON THIS FUNDING
REQUEST.
THANK YOU REST THE ONLY THING I
WOULD JUST ADD IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO REPLICATE THIS STEP
PROGRAM ALONG THE LINES OF THE
ALICE HYMERS DISEASE PROGRAM IN
THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC OUT THERE
ARE SOME PARALLELS THERE. IS
THIS THIS WOULD BE A NEW PROGRAM
AND.
.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THIS AGAIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SEVEN.
SEEING NONE I'LL BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE HAVE.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD MY TWO
CENTS YOU HAVE BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR MENTAL HEALTH YOU ARE ALSO
CHAMPION NOW FRAILES
THANK YOU FOR ADDING YOUR VOICE
IN YOUR ADVOCACY TO THE SECULAR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ARMS FROM MY.
I THINK. WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SEVEN OPEN AND THANK YOU ALL.
WE WILL RETURN TO.
AS WERE MISSING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA.
DOT.
WE WILL RETURN TO ISSUE FOR
THEIR YOUR THANK YOU SIR.
JUSTICE AND THE SOCCER GAME HERE
TO PASSED.
BUT IT.
IT.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ACCOMMODATING.
.
I SCHEDULE ON THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR YOUR CLOSE ATTENTION
DAHLE THESE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES COME BEFORE YOU THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY. AS
THE CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
WANNA.
I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BUDGET ITEM WE ALL KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF MEDICAL
INTERPRETERS I KNOW YOU KNOW.
PERSONALLY FROM YOUR PRACTICE.
.
AT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU DID. ON I WAS SPEAKER
ATKINS ON ENACTMENT OF AB SIX
THIRTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CONDUCT.
A STUDY OF ESTABLISH A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR MEDICAL
INTERPRETATION SERVICES FOR
LIMITED ENGLISH MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. AND THEN IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE ALSO HAVE AN
APPROPRIATION FOR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE FOR THE STUDY IN
PILOT PROJECT.
UNFORTUNATELY.
AND THIS IS REYES THE AYE GOOD
AMERICANS TURN WITH ME MAYBE
SOME OTHERS OF OUR COLLEAGUES.
THE PROGRESS HAS BEEN SLOW.
OF FOR EXPENDITURE OF THAT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND
GETTING THAT THE STUDY IN THE
PILOT PROJECTS UP AND RUNNING.
SO I'VE HEARD THAT THERE ISN'T
ANY COMMITMENT FROM GET CS TO
IMPLEMENT ANY PILOT PROJECTS
UNTIL AFTER THE COMPLETION OF
THE STUDY.
AND JUST TO REMOVE ANY AMBIGUITY
WE WANT TO CLARIFY THAT IT'S
OKAY TO DO BOTH THINGS
CONCURRENTLY THE STUDY AND THE
PILOT PROJECTS WE ALSO WERE
ASKING FOR A TWO YEAR. EXTENSION
OF TIME TO COMPLETE THE PROCESS
FROM JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TO JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO WE ALL KNOW
THE GREAT IMPORTANCE OF MEDICAL
INTERPRETERS. AND I THINK THESE
ARE A COMMON SENSE
REASONABLE STEPS TO TAKE TO HELP
MAKE SURE WE WE MOVE FORWARD IN
CALIFORNIA WITH. ARE A STUDY IN
PILOT PROJECTS A MEDICAL
INTERPRETERS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BUDGET ITEM
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
SUBCOMMITTEE OP BRIAN NELSON ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA I
MENTION THIS ISSUE IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIA SUSPECT WHO
SPEAK ENGLISH LISTA WELL. ALSO
WANNA JOIN HIM AND.
COMMENDING.
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS.
THE COMMITTEE ITSELF ARE FOR OF
BEING ON THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
ISSUE IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
AT A TIME WE'RE HAVING THESE
KEY DEBATES IN LEGISLATURE ABOUT
EXPANDING UPON THE WITH GREAT
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE IN TERMS
OF PROVIDING GREATER HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE.
OUR OVER THE PAST EIGHT YEARS
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT HOUSE ME
AND OUR PARTNERS IN THE SPACE
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIANS SEEKING
ACCESS TO QUALITY AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE HAVE AN EFFICIENT
MECHANISM IN PLACE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR PROVIDERS
TO ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM
DELIVERS THE BEST POSSIBLE
HEALTH OUTCOMES. REGARDLESS OF A
PATIENT'S LANGUAGE OR ETHNICITY.
NOW WHEN THE BILL PASSED THE
BUDGET PROCESS TWO YEARS AGO WE
ARE EXCITED TO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF STAKEHOLDERS TO PROVIDE
VALUABLE MEDICAL INTERPRETATION
SERVICES.
TO THOSE CALIFORNIA'S INDEED AND
WERE ALSO. ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEE IF THE PROGRAM COULD
WORK.
OUT WE BELIEVE THAT THESE FOR
OUR MINOR ADJUSTMENTS MENTIONED
BY MISTER BONTA.
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ALLOCATED BY THIS
BODY.
DO NOT RUN OUT BEFORE SERVICES
CAN BE ARE OFFERED IN ADEQUATELY
STUDY.
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OFFER
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE SITE. THANK
YOU SIR.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE FOR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST KIMBERLY
CHANNEL HALF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK STEVEN WAS
ONE OF THE ORIGINAL CO SPONSORS
ON LEGISLATION AND IN THE STATE.
THAT REQUIRED.
ALL INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO
LANGUAGE INTERPRETATION SERVICES
AND AS MISTER ALLISON NOTED.
THE.
WORRY PLEASE LAST YEAR TO SEE.
MOVEMENT ON THIS.
TO ENSURE. THE EXPANSION OF
THIS PARTICULAR EFFORT OUT WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGED IN THE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS AND.
AS NOTED WERE DISAPPOINTED IN
THE.
FEEDBACK WE RECEIVE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT WE WEIGHED IN WITH
COMMENTS AND.
THUS FAR ONLY RECEIVED.
SOME.
INTERACTION FROM THE DEPARTMENT.
AND.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT.
THIS PROPOSAL CLARIFIES.
OF THE PILOT PROJECT IN THE
STUDY TO FOR TOGETHER DO SUPPORT
IT.
THE AGREEMENT.
WE ARE ABOUT AS OF HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA ON ECHO.
OUR COLLEAGUES AT SEA PEN THEN
ALSO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET ASK
YOU CAN.
FOR WENT AWAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS AND.
I WILL AGREE WITH YOU SOMEONE
OVER BONTA I THINK WE CAN WALK
AND CHEW GUM AT THE SAME.
I THINK THIS.
IS WELL RECEIVED AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEFORE US.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENTS WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE FIVE.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AS CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE RARE
DISEASE CAUCUS I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
IN SUPPORTING A BUDGET REQUEST
FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
CLINICAL PILOT PROJECT TO
DEMONSTRATE BOTH THE PRINT
PRECISION DIAGNOSTIC AND
FINANCIAL VALUE OF CLINICAL
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING.
FOR THE MEDICAL PROGRAM.
THE OBJECTIVE OF THIS PILOT
PROJECT WILL BE TO TEST A
MINIMUM OF ONE HUNDRED MEDI CAL
NEONATAL ANOTHER PEDIATRIC
PATIENTS SUFFERING FROM ON.
DIAGNOSE DISEASES THAT OF REMAIN
UNDIAGNOSED OR HAD MULTIPLE
DIAGNOSES
HUSING CW GEASS TO PRODUCE
PROCESS PRECISE CONDITION
DIAGNOSES AND TARGETED TREATMENT
PATHWAYS.
THE PROJECT WILL BE ACCOUNTABLE
AND TRANSPARENT BY REPORTING
TEST RESULTS QUARTERLY INCLUDING
HOW DIAGNOSES WERE REVISED AND
TREATMENT PASSED PATHWAYS
ALTERED THE PROJECT WILL
DEMONSTRATE THE VALUE. IN MEDI
CAL COMPARED TO CURRENT
STANDARDS OF NEWBORN AND
PEDIATRIC HEALTH CARE
ASSESSMENTS SCREENINGS ARE TASKS
ADDITIONALLY THIS CLINICAL PILOT
PROJECT WILL DEMONSTRATE THE
MEDICARE WOULD BENEFIT
FINANCIALLY. AND MEDICARE
PATIENTS WOULD BENEFIT
CLINICALLY FOR IMPROVEMENT
ACCELERATED ACCESSIBILITY AND
COST EFFECTIVE AND.
EFFECTIVENESS OF ADOPTION OF
DEBBIE GS WHEN COMPARED TO
SUBSTANTIAL EXPENDITURES FOR
PATIENT DIAGNOSTIC ODYSSEYS AND
COSTLY INEFFECTIVE TREATMENTS IT
WILL ADVANCE PRECISION MEDICINE
IN CALIFORNIA BY DEMONSTRATING
THE CURRENT COST EFFECTIVE
AVAILABILITY OF TECHNOLOGY. TO
IDENTIFY DIFFICULT TO DIAGNOSE
GENETIC CONDITIONS IN THE
MEDICAL POPULATION TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY GUIDE CLINICIAN
TREATMENTS THE CHIEF OF GENOMICS
MEDICINE AT UC DAVIS SAID IT
SIMPLY IN A RECENT ARTICLE MEDI
CAL AND OTHER FORMS OF STATE A.
REALLY VIEWED XIN GENOMIC
SEQUENCING AS EXPERIMENTAL SO
IT'S NOT BEING COVERED.
GENOMIC SEQUENCING IS NOT
EXPERIMENTAL ANYMORE THIS
REQUEST WILL ESTABLISH A PROOF
OF CONCEPT FOR THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. SO IT MAY CONSTANTLY
MOVE FOR WITH ESTABLISHING IT AS
A COVERED BENEFIT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE APPROVE THIS
REQUEST AND ALONG WITH A SUM IN
MY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
WE ALSO HAVE A DOCTOR DAVID
DIMOCK. THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF
THE INSTITUTE FOR GENOMIC
MEDICINE READY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IN SAN DIEGO JOHN AND
JOHN VALENCIA RESENT RESENT
REPRESENTING ALUMINA
HEADQUARTERED IN SAN DIEGO. AND
LARGE FAR NAY IS THAT DOCTOR
LARGE FURNACE TIME AT THE M.
GAVE AT RATED CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA WOULD.
THANK YOU SOME OF THE REMAIN
CHINA OUGHT TO BE A A CO CHAIR
OF THE. CALIFORNIA RARE DISEASE
CAUCUS WITH YOU AND WHICH WILL
EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL I
THINK WE CAN REALLY BENEFIT THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM FINANCIALLY AS
WAS MENTIONED COULD BENEFIT. OF
PATIENTS
CLINICALLY IN MY OWN DISTRICT IN
OAKLAND CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IS
THE EAST BAY'S LARGEST PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTY CARE CENTER. AT BUILT
JUST FOR KIDS EGGMAN
CIRCUMSTANCES ARISE THESE
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE BEST.
STANDARD OF CARE THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM CAN REASONABLY PROVIDE.
IN THE PAST I THINK
GENOME SEQUENCING HAS BEEN SEEN
AS AN INVESTIGATIONAL OR
EXPERIMENTAL AND WE SHOULDN'T
SEE IT ASAP. ANYMORE THIS IS A A
A PILOT PROJECT THAT CAN REALLY
DEMONSTRATE THE TRUE VALUE. ADD
TO OUR OUR PATIENTS IN MANY CAL
SO I I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS I THINK IT'S A
MODEST PROPOSAL WITH THE
POTENTIAL FOR TREMENDOUS IMPACT
FOR OUR PATIENTS TO SAVE MONEY.
AND PROVIDE GREAT CLINICAL
OUTCOMES AND RESPECT WE ASK THAT
YOU CONSIDER SUPPORTING THANK
YOU.
SIR.
I'M DAVID ULTIMA CLINICAL
GENETICISTS BY TRAINING AND
MEDICAL DIRECTOR THE GENOME
INSTITUTE.
THE PROPOSAL IS A RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD WHAT TO SEQUENCE
THE MINIMUM OF HUNDRED CHILDREN
AT LEAST TWO OTHER CENTERS.
AT OUR INSTITUTION WE HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF PHILANTHROPY THAT HAS
ENABLED US TO STOP THE PROGRAM
PERSONAL TOLL WITH PROPOSING.
WE JUST RECENTLY PUBLISHED A
PRELIMINARY DATA ON OFFICE FORTY
TWO CHILDREN THAT WE SEQUENCED.
WE DEMONSTRATED CONSERVATIVELY
EIGHT HNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN COST SAVINGS.
ONE SIX PERCENT OF OUR CHILDREN
AROUND A Q. OUR. HOME SUCCESSFUL
MEDI CAL FROM INFANTS.
AND. IT IS WORTH NOTING THE
GENETIC DISORDERS WOULD
REPRESENT ABOUT SIX TO SEVENTEEN
ADMISSIONS TO NICK HUGHES AND
CALIFORNIA ON A GIVEN DAY.
THIS PROPOSAL IT'S TRANSPARENT
IN PROVIDING QUARTERLY CHECK
INS.
ON WE WILL MEAN TO STICK WITH AS
MANY CHILDREN AS WE CAN THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES TOM.
THE SET UP THE CONTENT IN THE
BOND HOSPITALS.
WHICH OF THE PARENTS UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY ARE GETTING THAT TELLS
INFO. AND INCLUDES FUNDING TO
PROVIDE DATA COLLECTION TO
UNDERSTAND THE FINANCIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF GENOMIC
SEQUENCING AND NANITES.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US MY NAME
IS LOW THE FARMHOUSE I AM ONE OF
THE PHYSICIANS AT THE.
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE FOR
GENOMIC MEDICINE.
I AM TRAINED IN INFECTIOUS
DISEASE IN PEDIATRIC HEMATOLOGY
ONCOLOGY. I'D ORIGINALLY BECAME
A PEDIATRIC ONCOLOGIST BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT THOSE WERE THE
SICKEST OF THE SICK CHILDREN BUT
THE REALITY IS THIS THOSE
CHILDREN. HAVE A LOT A LARGE
CARE NETWORK AND THEY'VE HAD
GREAT OUTCOMES DUE TO THE
SCIENTIFIC ADVANCES THAT WE HAVE
MADE.
MANY CHILDREN WITH GENETIC
DISEASE ARE NOT DIAGNOSED IN THE
NEWBORN PERIOD AND DIE FOR
UNKNOWN REASONS THESE WILL BE
CHILDREN THAT DIED OF CULTURE
NEGATIVE SUBSETS OR OR ANOTHER.
ARBITRARY DIAGNOSIS.
WE FOUND THAT WITH THE
APPLICATION OF A RELATIVELY
LIMITED SET OF EXCLUSION
CRITERIA TO IT LEMONADE CHILDREN
SUCH AS THOSE WHO HAVE ISOLATED
PRE MATURITY. OR INFECTION
WITHIN WITHIN IDENTIFIED
ORGANISM.
IF WE SEQUENCE EVERYBODY ELSE
THAT'S LEFT OVER THAT DOESN'T
HAVE A CLEAR DIAGNOSIS WE STILL
COME UP WITH A GENETIC DIAGNOSIS
IN ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PERCENT TO
A THIRD OF THE PATIENTS.
BEFORE GENETIC DISEASE WAS EVEN
SUSPECTED.
THIS ALLOWS US TO INTERVENE THIS
ALLOWS US TO HELP THESE
CHILDREN.
WITHOUT A DOUBT THIS PROPOSAL
WILL SAVE LIVES THERE WILL BE
CHILDREN IN THE STUDY THAT WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE DIED OR BEEN
NEUROLOGICALLY DEVASTATED. WHO
WILL BE SAVED?
PEOPLE BECOME VERY NERVOUS
ABOUT.
DOING A WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCE ON
A NEWBORN IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
WILL MEAN FOR CHILDREN LATER IN
THEIR LIVES WE ONLY I'D TRY TO
IDENTIFY THE REASON WHY THAT
PATIENT IS SICK RIGHT NOW. WE
DON'T ANALYZE FOR IF THERE IS AN
INCREASED CHANCE THAT THEY'LL
GET BREAST CANCER WHEN THEY'RE
FORTY FIVE. IF THERE'S AN
INCREASED RISK OF ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE WE LOOK FOR AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY IS THIS
PATIENT SICK IN THE HOSPITAL
RIGHT NOW AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO
HELP THEM.
THANK YOU SIR MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS JOHN VALENCIA
REPRESENTED ALUMINA AND A GLOBAL
LEADER IN JUNE HUMAN GENOMICS
HEADQUARTERED IN SAN DIEGO. I
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION TO THE CO CHAIRS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE RARE
DISEASE CAUCUS FOR SPONSORING
THIS PROPOSAL ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA. KICKED
OFF THE INTEREST AS BOTH MEMBERS
OF STATED THIS IS WHAT THE
COMMITTEE SO OFTEN ASK FOR AND
THAT IS A PROOF OF CONCEPT
BEFORE A LARGER INVESTMENT. ON
THIS SMALL INVESTMENT WE
EXPECTED EXTRAORDINARY RETURN WE
PRESENTED TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE AS
WELL AS THIS COUNTERPART IN THE
SENATE WHICH WILL HEAR THE
MATTER LATER THIS WEEK. A
DETAILED PROPOSAL ALONG WITH THE
BUDGET TO SHOW THE EXPECTED
INVESTMENT AND THE RETURN BEFORE
THE BROADER REQUEST OF COVERAGE
WITHIN THE PROGRAM. IT'S A TOOL
THAT IS HERE AND NOW IT SOUNDS
FUTURISTIC BUT IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S NOT ONLY BEEN INNOVATIVE
IT'S BEEN REFINED AND WE SHOULD
MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO THE PROGRAM
THE COVERS FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
BIRTHS. IN THE STATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE PROUD A
PROPOSAL THANK YOU SIR WE WILL
NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
FIVE.
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU OLIVER A
GREAT CALIFORNIA LIKE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION.
PROUD PARTNER CALIFORNIA RARE
DISEASE CAUCUS
I WANT TO THANK THEM BOTH FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD.
GENTLEMAN EARLIER SAID IF YOU
CAN MEASURE IT YOU COULD TREAT
IT AYE THIS IS VERY SIMILAR.
THE THE AMOUNT OF UNDIAGNOSED
RARE DISEASES THAT COULD BE A
TREATED EARLIER ON IN LIFE.
OR HAVE TREMENDOUS VALUE IF YOU
CAN DO SOME GENOME SEQUENCING
SEVEN STRONG SUPPORT OF PROPOSAL
AND OUT LOOK FORWARD TO IT
MOVING FORTY. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY COMMENTS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
I ONLY HAVE ONE QUESTION IF IF
I MAY DOING.
WORKING A LITTLE BIT OF MATH
WHILE I WAS HERE BUT. FOR TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND ONE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT'S TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER GENOMIC SEQUENCING.
AND.
MINDER STANDING IS THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS NOW MORE COST
EFFECTIVE THAN THAT FIGURE AND
SONG TRYING TO.
WONDER.
.
IS THERE.
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT STATE
DOLLARS ARE PAYING THE ACTUAL
PRICE FOR THE GENOMIC
SEQUENCING?
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW YOU GOT
TO TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
YEAH BUT SO.
THE REPORTER QUESTION SO.
TO BE CLEAR WAS TOLD UNITS
SEQUENCING HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING COST IT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE TO
DO A RAPID JEAN OF TRENTON
RESULT ROUNDED THREE TO FOUR
DAYS. RATHER THAN A MONTH OR TWO
MONTHS BECAUSE IT'S RENTS HAVE
KILLED MICE FOR SPEED PROBLEM
COSTS ABOUT ONE POINT.
SECOND ONE WHICH I THINK IS
PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANT THAT
ACTUALLY GETTING A DIAGNOSIS ON
A GENOME IS ONLY THE BEGINNING
OF THE JOURNEY.
AND IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
GENETICALLY AND FORMATS AND TO
THINK ABOUT THE TIME TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTATION OF CHANGES IN
MANAGEMENT.
AS WE LOOK GOING TO BOTH ON THE
CHILDREN'S ON TO OAKLAND.
THEY HAVE GOOD GENETICS
DEPARTMENTS ON BUT DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE PENALTY ON
THE FLIGHT TO. RESPOND TO JIM
RESULT AS CURRENTLY SIGN UP.
THERE IS A NEED TO PROVIDE
GENETIC COUNSELING IN THE NECK
IS OUT THOSE INSTITUTIONS WHICH
REQUIRES PERSONAL TO DO THAT.
AND FURTHERMORE THE COST
ANALYSIS IN AND OF ITSELF IS
VERY LABOR INTENSIVE TO REVIEW
THROUGH MEDICAL RECORDS. AND TO
DEVELOP WHAT WE CALL
COUNTERFACTUAL TRAGIC
TRAJECTORIES THAT'S TO SAY.
TRYING TO ESTABLISH WHAT WOULD
HAVE HAPPENED IN A RARE DISEASE
SITUATION IF WE HADN'T DONE THE
GENOME SEQUENCE
SO THE BUDGET INCLUDES THE
COUNSELING. ASSISTANCE WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF PRECISION
MEDICINE AS WELL AS THE GENOME
SEQUENCING. IN ITSELF FROM A
TENT IN THE BUDGET TO SAY AT
LEAST ONE HUNDRED. WE ARE NOT
FOR PROFIT WE WILL TO THIS AT
COST RECOVERY SO IF WE HAVE THE
ABILITY WOULDN'T BUDGET WE WILL
STICK WITH SMALL CHILDREN. THANK
YOU. AND IT EXCELLENT ANSWER.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS WE
WILL HOLD TO ISSUE FIVE OPEN AND
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF
.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER ACOSTA
FAIR PATIENTS.
DOUG ELLIN TAKE OUR TURN AND GET
RID OF HERE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BUT CURRENTLY THERE ARE MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION AND PAID
FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PP I SEE IS ESTIMATED THAT
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE NUMBERS OF
SENIORS IN NEED OF IN HOME CARE
SERVICES WILL HAVE DOUBLED TO
OVER NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
NOT TAKING IT WOULD COUNT THOSE
WILL BE IN NURSING HOMES
SOMETHING THAT MOST MIDDLE AND
LOW CUT INCOME FAMILIES CANNOT
US HOT NOT AFFORD.
THE COST FOR ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES AND NURSING HOMES
CONSUME SIXTEEN NINE POINT SEVEN
AND ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
PERCENT RESPECTIVELY
RESPECTIVELY. OF THE MEDIAN
ANNUAL INCOME OF CALIFORNIANS
SOMETHING THAT MEDICARE MEDICAID
OR UNABLE TO. COVER EFFECTIVELY.
THE CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER IS
ALREADY OF PROGRAMS IN PLACE
THAT CAN BE ADDED ON TO BY
CREATING INCENTIVE BASED PILOT
PROGRAM FOR YOUNG ADULTS.
I AM REQUESTING THAT THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE APPROVED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO FUND THE
CALIFORNIA CARE CORPS PILOT
PROGRAM. ESTABLISHING A
WORKFORCE FOR THE ELDERLY.
THE PROGRAM WILL WORK
SYMBIOTICALLY WITH THE CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS TO PROVIDE
RESPITE CARE TO THOSE IN NEED OF
IN HOME CARE FROM LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES THAT ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR HSS.
IDEALLY THE PROBLEM THE GEAR FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE INTERESTED
IN PURSUING A CAREER IN THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD BY PROVIDING
EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS AS WELL AS
A MONTHLY STIPEND.
THIS PROGRAM WILL ACT AS A
TUNNEL BETWEEN SCHOOL AND HEALTH
CARE FIELDS FOR STUDENTS TO GAIN
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE.
AS WELL AS ENCOURAGE THEM TO
MEET THE GROWING NEEDS OF OUR
AGING POPULATION BOTH NOW. AND
IN THE FUTURE.
UNFORTUNATELY MY COAUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMAN.
EDUARDO GARCIA HAD TO HAD TO
LEAVE ARE BUT I DO HAVE.
AT ME HEALTH OKAY THEREBY HOPE
A PRONOUNCED IT RIGHT AGAIN. HOW
FROM THE YOUTH A MOVEMENT
AGAINST ALZHEIMER'S PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT AND ALSO ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS THANK YOU?
THANK YOU FOR THE INTRODUCTION
AND I WANT TO EXPRESS MY THANKS
ABOUT THAT SOME WOMEN ACOSTA AND
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA I'M FOR THEIR
BUDGETARY REQUEST. I'M CHAIR DR
RAMBLA AND.
ESTEEMED MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE
HOUSE THAT YOU DAY I AM THE
ORIGINATOR OF THIS BUDGETARY
REQUEST AND ASPIRING PHYSICIAN
AND SERVICE THE CEO AND
COFOUNDER OF THE YOUTH MOVEMENT
AGAINST ALZHEIMER'S AND
NONPROFIT THAT STARTED RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND IS NOW
THE NATIONAL LEADER AND YOU
THOUGHT BECAUSE HE AGAINST THIS
DISEASE.
STUDENTS AND AS MILLENNIALS WE
ARE WORRIED THAT THE COST OF
CARE WILL OUTGROW MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
DECADES. AND ARE INVESTED IN
VOTING FOR A LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
TO GLOBAL CHALLENGES THAT IF NOT
ADDRESS NOW WILL BE UNIVERSALLY
IMPACTFUL AS WE REACH OUR
FORTIES AND FIFTIES.
AND TODAY WE ARE CREATING JUST
SUCH A SOLUTION THIS BUDGETARY
REQUEST CALLS FOR A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA CARE COURT. A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PILOT THAT
INCENTIVIZE HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE GRADUATES TO WRITE FULL
TIME CARE TO SENIORS WITH
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT.
FOR.
AND THE MANY.
UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS WHO
DON'T QUALIFY FOR AMAZING AND
MUCH NEEDED PROGRAMS LIKE I JUST
SAYS THIS OFFERS A MUCH NEEDED
BREAK.
THOSE WITH THE DISEASE ARE
OFFERED A YOUTHFUL PARTNER TO
INJECT SPIRIT AND ENERGY IMPROVE
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE.
YOUNG INDIVIDUALS LIKE MYSELF
ARE OFFERED TREMENDOUS LIFE
PERSPECTIVE AND A SKILL
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH OUR GROWING AGING
POPULATION. AND A POTENTIAL
FUTURE CAREER IN CARE SERVICES.
THIS IS A FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETARY ASK
CALIFORNIA IN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM BENEFIT FROM REDUCED
BURDEN ON MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND AS CURRENT CARE GIVERS RE
ENTER THE WORKFORCE. IF THE AND
THIS CURRENT CAREGIVERS REENTER
THE WORKFORCE
IF JUST FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
RECIPIENTS OF THIS PROGRAM GO
BACK TO WORK I MEDIAN SALARY THE
STATE WILL BE PAID BACK TEN
PERCENT OF COST SIMPLY THROUGH
STATE TAXES.
IN ADDITION WE WILL HAVE AN
ADVISORY BOARD THAT WILL ENSURE
OPTIMAL IMPLEMENTATION OF A
PILOT.
OUR NONPROFIT RECENTLY LAUNCHED
YOUTH CARE
AN INTERGENERATIONAL RESPITE
CARE PROGRAM AT USC.
AFTER A TWO YEAR GRANT FUNDED
PILOT AT UCLA.
WE PARTNER TRAIN COLLEGE STUDENT
VOLUNTEERS AND OLDER ADULTS WITH
EARLY TO MID STAGE DEMENTIA IN A
COMMUNITY BASED SETTING FOR SIX
HOURS A WEEK.
DURING WHICH TIME CARE GET
FAMILY CAREGIVERS ARE GIVEN A
BREAK.
WE HAVE QUANTIFIABLE DATA TO
SHOW BENEFITS FOR ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED.
THIS BUDGETARY ALLOCATION
CREATES A DIRECT COMPETITOR FOR
OUR BUSINESS
YET OUR ORGANIZATION IS
SPONSORING THIS EFFORT AND IS
INSPIRING OTHERS TO CREATE SUCH
SIMILAR COMPETITORS BECAUSE THE
CARE MARKET IS NOT A ZERO SUM
GAME.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE DEMAND
IS MUCH HIGHER THAN THE SUPPLY
AND THAT WE CANNOT SIMPLY RELY
ON FOR PROFIT CARE FOR THE FILE
ON THE FOR PROFIT CARE INDUSTRY.
TO SERVE ALL FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION OF CALIFORNIA'S UNPAID
FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
IT IS TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
LEAD THE COUNTRY ONCE AGAIN JUST
LIKE IT DID IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR THROUGH THE CREATION OF THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AND
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO THROUGH THE
CREATION OF THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE ACT.
THAT WE ARE STATE THE
UNDERSTANDS THAT CARE GIVER ARM
ARE AMONGST AMERICA'S UNSUNG
HEROES AND WE ARE A STATE THAT
IS INNOVATING SAYS
INTERGENERATIONAL SOLUTIONS
BASED IN COMPASSION FOR THOSE
WHO ARE AMONGST OUR MOST
VULNERABLE.
ESTEEM COMMITTEE TODAY I REQUEST
YOU TO PASS THIS BUDGETARY ASK
AND JOIN ORGANIZATIONS VISION AS
TOGETHER WE CAN CREATE A FUTURE
WORTH REMEMBERING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE SIX.
NIKOLAY TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THE GAME.
QUIRK SORTS CUTS BEING IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLYMAN EDUARDO
GARCIA.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS FOR
ANY COMMENTS THAT WE MAY HAVE.
SEEING NONE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THIS IT'S. NICE
TO HAVE SOME YOUTH ADVOCACY
ESPECIALLY ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
I THINK WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
ISSUE SIX OPEN THANK YOU THANK
VERY MUCH MISTER.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
EIGHT
.
SO AGAIN RENEE MONOLOGUE
DEPARTMENT OF SO I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO RESPOND
TO A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA.
AND THIS IS RELATED TO THE
TENTACLE PROGRAM WHICH IS UNDER
MY PURVIEW IN THE DEPARTMENT.
AND SO THE AND A COMMITTEE HAS
ASKED FOR I'M INFORMATION ON
THAT CHALLENGES AND PROGRESS
MADE ON BURKE GUARDIAN THAT
IDENTICAL PROGRAM. AS WELL AS
TO.
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO THE OUT
PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING.
SO FIRST I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE CHALLENGES SO THERE HAVE
BEEN QUITE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF CHALLENGES IN OUR PROGRAM.
INCLUDING NEGATIVE AUDIT
FINDINGS LOW UTILIZATION RATES
FOR CHILDREN ESPECIALLY IN TERMS
OF ACCESSING PREVENTIVE
SERVICES.
CHALLENGES WITH PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION BOTHAROUND HIM
MOMENT PRETEND CHEN AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS AND
CONFUSION OVER COVER BENEFITS AS
WELL AS ONGOING MEDIA ATTENTION.
WE HAVE.
RECOGNIZE AND ACKNOWLEDGE THESE
CHALLENGES BUT.
IN TERMS OF OUR EFFORTS IN TERMS
OF ADDRESSING THESE CHALLENGES
WITH LEGISLATIVE REPORT I AM
PLEASED TO REPORT OUT ON THE
FOLLOWING.
SO ONE WITH.
.
THE LEGISLATURE WE DID WORK
RECEIVE RELIEF FOR DENTAL
PROVIDERS FROM A. B. NINETY
SEVEN PROVIDER PAYMENT
REDUCTIONS AND ALL OF THESE
THINGS COLLECTIVELY HAS HELPED
TO ON.
TURN THE TIDE IN TERMS OF OUR
PROGRAM BUT I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE UP FRONT THAT THERE
ARE STILL QUITE A BIT OF WORK TO
BE DONE.
WE ALSO HAVE THE ODD DENTAL
TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVE ON
THAT AGENDA DID OUTLINE THE
COMPONENTS OF THAT. AND AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT IS A SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN THE PROGRAM. TARGETED TOWARDS
PREVENTIVE SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN.
I'M AND MAP UP PROJECT IS OVER A
FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
I'M WE ARE CURRENTLY AND I'M
YEAR THREE OF THE PROJECT.
AND PART OF THIS EFFORT IS
LOOKING AT THE INCREASED
UTILIZATION OF PREVENTIVE
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN. AND SINCE
THE INCEPTION OF THE PROJECT WE
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE OF SEVEN
PERCENT IN TERMS OF PREVENTIVE
SERVICE UTILIZATION. MOVIE NOT
FROM APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SEVEN
POINT EIGHT THREE PERCENT TO
FORTY FIVE PERCENT IN TERMS OF
UTILIZATION OF SERVICES.
WE'VE HAD.
WITH LEGISLATIVE.
AUTHORIZATION RESTORATION OF
ADULT DENTAL SERVICES THOSE WENT
INTO A FACT
ON JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE'VE ALSO HAD THE PROP
FIFTY SIX INVESTMENTS IN THE
DELTA CAO PROGRAM. I'M OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A BUDGET YEAR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND ANOTHER
SEVENTY MILLION THAT'S PROPOSED.
IN THE UPCOMING BUDGET.
WE HAVE ALSO WORKED ON.
THE I. SPLITTING OUT OF OUR
DENTAL FISCAL INTERMEDIARY
CONTRACT THAT HAD HISTORICALLY
BEEN HELD BY DELTA DENTAL AND SO
WE HAVE NOW A SEPARATE FISCAL
INTERMEDIARY CONTRACTOR AS WELL
AS A NEW ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
I'M CONTRACTOR. AND THIS
CONTRACTOR IS I'M CRITICAL IN
TERMS OF HOW WE'RE ADMINISTRATOR
PROGRAM BECAUSE APPROXIMATELY
NINETY PERCENT NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE DEN ACCOUNT
PROGRAM HAS OPERATED UNDER. A
FEE FOR SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND WE DO HAVE I MANAGED CARE
INTO COUNTY SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES. SO THE ASL CONTRACTOR
HAS.
SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITIES
WITH OVERSIGHT BY THE STATE IN
TERMS OF INCREASING OUTREACH TO
PROVIDERS BOTH IN AREAS WHERE
THERE ARE LOW UTILIZATION RATES.
AS WELL AS WORK EFFORTS TO
UNDERTAKE TO HELP INCREASE
PROVIDER PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROGRAM. THERE ALSO DIRECTED IN
TERMS OF DOING OUTREACH TO
BENEFICIARIES AND PROVIDING CASE
MANAGEMENT AND CARE
COORDINATION.
FOR BENEFICIARIES WHEN PROBLEMS
ARISE.
AND THEN THEY ALSO ARE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE US WITH ANYA OUTREACH
PLANS FOR BENEFICIARIES AND
PROVIDERS.
WE'VE HAD ADMINISTRATIVE
SIMPLIFICATIONS ONE BEING WITH
STREAMLINED PROVIDER.
APPLICATIONS WE ARE SEEING THE
NEW I'M APPLICATIONS INCREASE
PROVIDER MOMENT WE'VE HAD LIKE
FORTY FOUR NEW APPLICATIONS
COMING INTO LAST.
WE'VE ALSO WORKED ON AYE A
DECREASING.
THE DENTAL TAR I.
PROCESSING TIME LINES AND FOR AN
AVERAGE OF FIVE DAYS BEFORE IT
WAS AROUND TEN TO FIFTEEN DAYS
IF NOT LONGER. AND RIGHT NOW
BASED UPON DATA THAT WE HAVE
FROM OUR ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
ORGANIZATION WERE SEEN THAT
TARA'S ARE BEING AT HOME
APPROVED IN AN AVERAGE BETWEEN
ONE TO THREE DAYS. DEPENDING
UPON THE DELIVERY SYSTEM OR
ABOUT THE PLAN AYE AND WHAT'S
THE SERVICES ARE BEING
REQUESTED.
AND I'M ALSO LOOKING TO MOVE OUR
DENTAL PROVIDER APPLICATIONS
INTO AN ONLINE APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT'S CURRENTLY BEING
PILOTED. FOR OUR MEDICAL I'M.
PROVIDERS PROOF AYE THAT
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROGRAM.
WE ALSO HAVE INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY IN TERMS OF
REPORTING THANKS AGAIN TO
LEGISLATION BY MEMBER WOULD.
UNDER AB TWO TWO OH SEVEN
WHEREBY WE ARE DOING MORE UP
REPORTING.
EXCUSE ME ON ON PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT WERE DEVELOPED
WITH STAKEHOLDER INPUT. AND ALL
OF THIS INFORMATION IS POSTED ON
AND MEDICAL DENTAL PROGRAM WEB
PAGE THAT WE CREATED
SPECIFICALLY. TO GIVE
INFORMATION ON OUR DENTAL
PROGRAM.
DATA IS ALSO AVAILABLE ON THE.
.
OUR AGENCY I'M OPEN DATA PORTAL
AND IT DOES INCLUDE DATA BY
COUNTY AGENT ETHNICITY.
THERE HAS BEEN EXTENSIVE
BENEFICIARY OUTREACH
FOR POPULATIONS ARE NOT I
UTILIZING SERVICES AND FOCUSING
OUTREACH ON UNDER UTILIZING
COUNTIES INCLUDING I'M
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AYE ZERO TO
AGE THIRTY. AND IMPROVE THE
MESSAGING IN TERMS OF COVER
BENEFITS AND HOW TO ACCESS SUCH
BENEFITS UNDER OUR PROGRAM.
INCLUDING WORKING ON A REVISION
OF THE META CAO BENEFICIARY
PROVIDER HANDBOOK WHICH IS ALSO
POSTED ON OUR WEB PAGE.
AND WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT.
.
THROUGH AGAIN LEGISLATION BY
SENATOR CANNELLA THAT THERE IS
THE DESIRE TO HAVE A GOAL OF
ACHIEVING SIXTY PERCENT OR
HIGHER. IN TERMS OF UTILIZATION
FOR SERVICES AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT OUR STARTING POINT FOR THAT
WAS FORTY SEVEN PERCENT BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE GOAL THAT WE HAD
SET FOR OURSELVES. WITH THE DTI.
.
PROJECT BECAUSE WE WERE STARTING
AT A LOW OF APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
SEVEN PERCENT SO OVER THAT FIVE
YEAR PERIOD WE WERE LOOKING TO
INCREASE UTILIZATION BY TEN
PERCENT.
AND AGAIN.
WE ARE SEEN INCREASES IN
UTILIZATION FOR CHILDREN THROUGH
THE EFFORTS OF THE DTI. AND THEM
WERE ALSO.
LOOKING AT AND MONITORING I'M
UTILIZATION FOR ADULT
BENEFICIARIES RIGHT NOW IT'S TOO
EARLY TO TELL I'M A WET THAT
UTILIZATION IS LOOKING LIKE IN
TERMS OF THE RESTORATION OF THE
ADULT DENTAL BENEFIT. JUST
BECAUSE OF THE TIMING OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION. BUT WE.
ARE TRACKING AYE UTILIZATION
FOR PREVENTIVE SERVICES FOR
ADULTS WHICH IS APPROXIMATELY
TWELVE PERCENT. AND THEN JUST AN
ANNUAL DENTAL VISIT FOR NY TYPE
OF THE DEVIL SERVICE FOR ADULTS
IS APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE
PERCENT. BUT THAT DATA IS LIKELY
TO CHANGE AS WE CONTINUE TO GET
CLAIMS RUN OUT FOR OUR PROGRAM.
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF OUR
CONCERNS IN TERMS UP WRITER
PARTICIPATION IN OUR PROGRAM.
AND AS OF MARCH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND OUR FEE FOR SERVICE GENERAL
PROGRAM WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY SIX HUNDRED SERVICE OFFICE
LOCATIONS. AND APPROXIMATELY
NINE HUNT NINE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX RENDERING
PROVIDERS I'M IN OUR PROGRAM IN
THIS IS INCLUSIVE OF PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING AND BOTH ARE DIEM
SEE. AN OUR FEE FOR SERVICE
DENTICLE PROGRAM AND LIKE I SAID
EARLIER WHILE WE HAVE MADE SOME
GAINS IN OUR PROGRAM WE DO
RECOGNIZE.
THAT THERE IS STILL ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE INVESTMENT SEDATE HELP TO
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS.
.
THAT WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN
INCLUDING LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
IN TERMS OF PROP FIFTY SIX
THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT.
THAT SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AND
THE TYPES OF SERVICES THAT ARE
AYE SUBJECT TO THOSE PAYMENTS
SO WE ARE REVIEWING UP PROPOSALS
THAT HAVE COME INTO THE
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL.
PROCEDURE BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THOSE PAVEMENTS I'M
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT.
ADDRESSING THOSE AND COMING
BACK WITH MAY REVISE IN TERMS OF
THE DIFFERENT SERVICES THAT
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE USE OF
PROP FIFTY SIX.
I'M THAT STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
INCLUDE LOOKING AT THE INCLUSION
OF ADULT PART I PREVENTIVE
SERVICES. PERIODONTAL SERVICES
EXTENDED APPOINTMENT TIMES AND
THEN GENERAL ANESTHESIA PARITY.
AND THEN WE'LL LOOK AT THOSE I'M
FOR ANY OTHER PROPOSALS THAT ARE
ALSO PRESENT ON TODAY FOR
CONSIDERATION. AND THEN AGAIN
WE'RE LOOKING AT.
AS WE'RE FOCUSING ON THOSE
SERVICES THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO THE PROP FIFTIES
PAYMENTS. LOOKING AT AREAS WHERE
THERE IS UNDER UTILIZATION AND
THEM FOCUSING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS WHERE WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY'LL BE THE GREATEST BENEFIT.
OUT FOR OUR COVERED
BENEFICIARIES.
THINK THE SMALL OFTEN. DR KUMAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JACK MARIN STAYED DOWN
DIRECTOR.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO GIVE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE ORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM THE.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
MISSION IS TO PROMOTE OR OF
HEALTH AND REDUCE OR DISEASES.
OF IT AT LEAST A STATE OR OF HOW
PLAN IN JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND IT PROVIDES A
ROADMAP. OF ORAL HEALTH
PRIORITIES FOR THE NEXT TEN
YEARS FOR THE STATE TO ADDRESS.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
RESEARCH AND PREVENTION TOBACCO
TAX ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
PROVIDES FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT
OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO.
IMPLEMENT THE STATE OR HOW PLAN
THEY HAVE STRUCTURED SIX
COMPONENTS TO IMPLEMENT THE
PLAN.
OF THE ARE STRENGTHENING THE
CAPACITY OF THE STATE ORAL HAVE
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
WE ARE PROVIDING EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
SUPPORTING ALL SIXTY ONE LOCAL
OF JURISDICTIONS WE HAVE FOR A
PROCESS TO FIFTY EIGHT
APPLICATION SO FAR.
YEAH GRANTED EXTENSIONS TO BUY A
ONE LOCAL HOW JURISDICTION. AND
TO APPLY FOR THE GRANT.
THEY'RE OUT IN THE PROCESS OF
HIDING STYLE FRIEND CONSULTANTS.
AND THIS IS A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
GIVES FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL HOW
JURISDICTIONS ARE DESIGNED THAT
PROGRAM BASED ON THEIR NEEDS.
IN GENERAL WE'RE ASKING THE
GRANTEES TO FOCUS ON REDUCING
ORDER DISEASES AND UNTREATED
DISEASES AND CHILDREN AND OTHER
WILD. A VULNERABLE POPULATION
GROUPS.
INCREASING DENTAL VISIT TRAITS
ESPECIALLY IN CHILDREN PREGNANT
WOMEN PEOPLE WITH DIABETES AND
ORDERED ADULTS.
ADDRESSING COMMON RISK FACTORS
SUCH AS POOR DIETARY CHOICES AND
PROMOTING TOBACCO CESSATION.
SCREENING PREFERABLE
ESTABLISHING LINKAGES AMONG
PEOPLE PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITY
RESOURCES IS A PRIORITY.
THEY ARE ESTABLISHING A TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER
AT UCSF SCHOOL OF DENTISTRY TO
HELP ON THE LOCAL HOW
DEPARTMENTS.
AND THE HAVE A COMPONENT THAT'S
FOCUSED ON COMMUNICATION AND
ORAL OUTLET TO SEE VIETNAM THE
PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING PLEASE
SOURCES FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
AND.
ARE AT ONE OF OUR KEY OBJECTIVE
IS ASSESSMENT. OF THE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF FOR.
GATHERING DATA THROUGH VARIOUS
SURVEYS THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
WHERE THERE IS A GAP WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF DESIGNING.
SURVEYS TO FILL THE GAPS.
OF.
THEN THE FINAL COMPONENT IS
FOCUSED ON SPECIAL PROJECTS
VIVID LIKE TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF SPECIAL POPULATION GROUPS A
CHANCE OR DID I DON'T.
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES PREGNANT
WOMEN HOME LAST ANOTHER
POPULATION GROUPS WE HAVE IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
DEMONSTRATION PRAGUE PROGRAMS.
TO ASSESS THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
AND COST.
THERE IS A QUESTION ABOUT.
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE UNDERSTAND THAT
CONCERNS AND BE HAVE PROPOSED
AND ADMINISTRATIVE MECHANISM.
TO ALLOW FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
THANK YOU BIGGER DOCTOR KAMARCK.
CLEAR GLASS WATER.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIOTT.
TO YOU KNOW COMMENT.
WE HAVE A KATIE ANDREW WAS WELL
AS BRIANNA PITMAN AND KIMBERLY
CHAN CAN WE CREATE A LITTLE BUT
A SPACE FOR THEM UP. HERE
.
I.
CALF NOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF PRE
INDEPENDENCE FUNDS ARE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION.
I WANTED JUST SAM KEEP MY
COMMENTS DIRECTLY TO THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX.
DONE THE COUNCILMEN ALL
PAYMENTS.
I MEAN SPECIFICALLY OUT FOR THAT
AND THE NEW MONEY THAT HAS IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
SEVENTY MILLION. I'M WE REALLY
THINK THAT THEY SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON PREVENTION AND
PERIODONTAL CARROTS ARE GOING
TREATMENT CARE I'M AS RENEE
MENTIONED EARLIER. I'M WE HAVE
GIVEN THAT PROPOSAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT BUT WOULD URGE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE.
TO PUSH THE.
DEPARTMENT REALLY FOCUS ON
THOSE TWO TWO PLACES
I'M THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
POTENTIAL LONG TERM SAVINGS
COSTS FOR THE STATE BOTH ON THE
PREVENTION AND THE PERIODONTAL
CARE SIDE.
BUT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY DOUBLE
DISEASES VERY MUCH PREVENT
PREVENTABLE AND WE DO HAVE THE
DTI FOCUSING ON CHILDREN ZERO TO
TWENTY.
THERE THERE IS NOTHING FOR
ADULTS AND WE KNOW THAT THE DTI
IS GOING AWAY AND SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE DEPARTMENT TO SORT
OF LONG TERM LUCK.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MAINTAIN
SOME KIND OF INCENTIVE?
FOR PREVENTION FOR CHILDREN A
MINUTE ESPECIALLY FOR THE
PERIODONTAL CARE I WAS THE ONE
AREA I'M OF THE ADULT DENTAL
BENEFITS THAT WERE RESTORED.
THIS YEAR WHICH WERE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT DID NOT
RECEIVE A SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT
IN THERE'S A LOT OF BACKLOG I'M
AND IN NEED. OF FOR ADULTS AND
SO THAT'S REALLY AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S A LOT IN NEED I AM AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR FOLKS
WHO HAVE CHRONIC DISEASE. AND
AND THEN I WOULD ALSO AND JUST
MAKE A COMMENT AROUND STABILITY
AND CONTINUITY INTO CAL IS A
PROBLEM AS PROGRAM THE TIDE I'M
A LOT OF CHALLENGES AND IT'S
BEEN UNDER FUNDED YOU HEARD A
LITTLE. BIT OF THE HISTORY THERE
I'M THE DTI AND THE PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO
SEE THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD ON OUT REACHED OUR MEMBERS
TO GET THEM INVOLVED. BUT I
THINK IT'S GONNA TAKE AWHILE TO
UNDO THE DAMAGE THAT'S BEEN DONE
TO THE PROGRAM FRANKLY AND I
THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED SOME TIME
AND THE ABILITY TO EVALUATE THAT
AND. I KNOW WE TALKED LAST MONTH
THE BEGINNING IN MARCH FIFTH
ABOUT.
THE CONTINUITY OF THOSE
PAYMENTS OUT WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT WHICH IS YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT SEEING A START STOP.
FOR THOSE THOSE PAYMENTS THAT
ARE GOING TO PROVIDERS BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY GONNA DISINCENTIVE
EYES THEM TO MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
THE PRACTICE WHICH IS REALLY
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE.
I THINK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KIMBERLY
CHEN ON PATH CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK.
THEY WANT IT ECHO A SOME OF THE
COMMENTS.
THAT I'M STATEMENT.
SPENCER NOTED.
A PARTICULARLY ON THE NEED FOR
PREVENTIVE SERVICES.
MISSY PEN IS THE CONVENER OF
THE STATE ORAL HEALTH NETWORK
AND AS PART OF THAT WE CONDUCTED
A LISTENING TOUR ACROSS THE.
STATE ON.
HEALTH THINGS WERE GOING NOW
THAT WE HAVE A RESTORED ADULT
DENTAL BENEFITS AND PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX AND.
AS ONE PARTICIPANT NOTED WE
NEED FROM THE STATE A BUSINESS
MODEL FOR PREVENTION SERVICES
BECAUSE FOR PAID FOR PATIENTS
ACCESS TO PREVENTION IS HOW WE
WILL IMPROVE OUTCOMES AND. HELP
TO REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES I
WANT TO SHARE A PARTICULAR
STORY.
FROM FRESNO WE LEARNED THAT.
THERE WAS IN FACT AN UPTICK IN
UTILIZATION AND ACCESS FROM
ENROLLEES AND WE ASK WHY HOW IT
WAS HAPPENING WE LEARNED THAT
CAN THE COUNTY WAS ACTUALLY
HIRING.
SALES PEOPLE TO WORK ON OUT
REACHED A WORKING WITH.
UP PROVIDERS ONE ON ONE SHOWING
THEM THE BUSINESS CASE FOR.
TAKING A JOB AT THE DEAD COW
PATIENTS NOW WITH THE PROVIDER
UP PAYMENTS FROM PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX AND WE WOULD ARGUE
THAT WE WOULD NEED MORE OF THIS
AND TO PROVIDE THAT STABILITY
SHOWING THAT. PREVENTION IS
GOING TO BE PART OF THAT
COVERED.
BENEFITS AS WELL.
THAT RECEIVE THOSE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS.
.
AT MOVING FORWARD WE LOVE TO
ALSO SEE.
THAT GREATER TRANSPARENCY.
AND.
DISCUSSION OF EVALUATION.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHETHER THIS IS
ACTUALLY INCREASE INCREASING
UTILIZATION WE HAVE GREAT
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE BUT UP TO
DATE WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN A WHOLE
LOT OF INFORMATION IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
MOVING FORWARD. ON HOW WILL
ADDITIONAL CODES BE.
SELECTED A WHAT WILL BE THE
PROCESS.
IN SHARING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THAT.
DO WE HAVE A TIME LINE FOR
THESE THINGS MOVING FOR AND IN
TERMS OF REALIZATION AS
STRUCTURE YOU KNOW.
NO UNDERSTANDING THE
DEMOGRAPHIC UP BREAKDOWN OF
UTILIZATION.
I THINK THAT'S ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE AND.
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THOSE
ADJUSTMENT FORK.
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF AKB ANDREW
CHILDREN NOW I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
FROM CPA AND SEE PAN.
IN THE NEED FOR TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND EVALUATION
THE PROP FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS.
WE ALSO STRONGLY AGREE WITH THE
NEED TO INCENTIVIZE PREVENTION.
AND PERIODONTAL SERVICES. AND
WE HAVE CONCERNS AROUND THE
SUSTAINABILITY OF INCENTIVES FOR
PREVENTIVE STARTED SERVICES I'VE
FOR BENEFICIARIES AGES ZERO TO
TWENTY ONCE THE DTI CONCLUDES IN
TWENTY TWENTY.
AND SO WE ASK THAT YOU SEE US
CONSIDER USING PROPERTY SIX A
PEROT PAYMENT FUNDS TO CONTINUE
PRIORITIZING PREVENTIVE DENTAL
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN.
AS WELL AS CONSIDER THE
ADDITION OF CODE DE EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY YEAR.
WHICH ALLOWS FOR THE REMOVAL OF
ORTHODONTIC APPLIANCES
CONSTRUCTION RETAINER PLACEMENT
FOR THOSE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THAT HAVE INCOMPLETE BUT
APPROVED TREATMENT AND
AUTHORIZATIONS THEY HAVE AGED
OUT OF THE FOSTER YOUTH SYSTEM.
.
LASTLY I JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS.
AB TWENTY TWO OF SEVEN A PET.
.
THAT WHICH WE KNOW AIMS TO
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY IMPROVE
DENTAL CARE CORONATION WITHIN
THE DON'T HELP PROGRAM.
OF IN PART BY CALLING FOR MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE HEALTH PLANS TO
REQUIRE THEIR PROVIDER NETWORKS
TO PROVIDE DENTAL SCREENINGS
REFERRED TO DENT CAL PROVIDERS
AND PROVIDE DENTAL RELATED. CARE
COORDINATION IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT AT THIS POINT
THERE'S NO MEASURE TO TRACK
ADHERENCE TO THAT AND SO WE
WANTED TO. USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LIFT THAT UP AND
URGED THE A CS TWO AND DEVELOP
MEASURES SO THAT WE CAN TRACK IT
PARENTS TO THOSE PARTICULAR
PROVISIONS AND AB TWENTY SEVEN.
THINK YOU
WE GIVE.
DO NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ISSUE EIGHT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF OUR
FULL ADULT RESTORATION AND DTI
ACCESS REMAINS TO BE A CONCERN
AS SEEN. BY RECENT DATA FROM
BEACH CS THAT SHOW THAT THE
NUMBER OF DEAD TO CALPERS
FIGHTERS HAVE ACTUALLY DECLINED
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. WHEN YOU
WOULD EXPECT THE NUMBERS TO
INCREASE. IN ADDITION WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO SEE A GREATER FOCUS ON
PREVENTION FOR ADULTS AND GUN
TREATMENT AS IT'S APPALLING THAT
TWO OF THE TOP TEN. DEADLY CAO
SERVICES FOR ADULTS IS
EXTRACTION.
ON.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE FIVE COUNTY SOME OF
WHICH ARE IN MISTER WOODS
DISTRICT. AYE THAT HAVE NO DEAD
TO CAL WHATSOEVER AND SO TENER.
A SOAP BADEN SUBLIMINAL RATES
COULD COULD BE DIRECTED THERE AS
WELL. AND AND LASTLY IN REGARDS
JACK AB TWO TWO ZERO SEVEN I
WILL BE WE APPRECIATE THAT BILL
MOVING FORWARD IN LATIN WHICH
REQUIRED IT MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO COORDINATE DENNY
CAO BENEFITS FOR THEIR ENROLLEES
BY INCLUDING TANNIC. DENTAL
SCREENINGS I WE'D LIKE TO SEE
HERE ABOUT PROGRESS AS WELL AS
HOW I TEACH THE ASSISTANT
FORCING THAT
THE KEY.
IF YOU.
MILLION DOLLARS OF HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA AND WE APPRECIATE.
THE DIRECTORS.
.
COMMENT ABOUT REVIEWING THE
PROPOSALS THAT THE DEPARTMENT'S
COTTON AND COMING BACK IN MAY
REVISE.
WITH SUGGESTIONS AND.
AND.
FOR INVESTMENT AND HOW TO USE
THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS I'M WE
HOWEVER.
DO REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
UTILIZATION AMONGST CHILDREN
CONTINUES TO BE LOW WITH LESS
THAN HALF OF CHILDREN GETTING
PREVENTIVE CARE AND VERY LITTLE
CHANGE IN THE NUMBER OF DENTAL
PROVIDERS. THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO MONITOR
PROVIDER PARTICIPATION AND
DENTAL UTILIZATION THE DENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE RESTORATION OF THE
DENTAL BENEFIT. AND OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP THAT
FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS.
HEALTH ACCESS ALSO.
AS A PART OF THE ORAL HEALTH
NETWORK ALONG WITH THE PEN AND
WE WANNA.
ECHO KIM AYE CHAN'S COMMENTS AS
WELL AS LINDA IS.
ON PREVENTIVE AND PERIODONTAL
TREATMENT.
AND I HOPE THAT TO SEE THOSE.
DENTAL CODES FUNDED THROUGH
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AS WELL
THANK YOU THE COMMAND.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VIVICA RIGHT NOW ANDERSON I'M
WITH PDI SURGERY CENTER
RELOCATING IN CINEMA CAO ME
WHERE TO UPPER TORRANCE SURGERY
CENTER. WHERE CLINICS FROM
THIRTY THREE ARE COUNTY SEND
THEIR CHILDREN EVERYDAY WE SEE?
TAM CHILDREN IN EACH OR I MEAN
NOT FIVE MINUTES OR TEMPER DAY
AND IT'S USUALLY A THREE AND A
HALF YEAR OLD WITH A WOOD AROUND
FOURTEEN CAVITIES.
WE HEAR A LOT FROM THE FAMILIES
THAT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO FIND IT
DOWN TO CAL PROVIDER IN THEIR
COUNTY THAT WE'LL SEE A CHILD'S
ZERO TWO THREE. AM SO WE DO URGE
THAT THE. WE DO URGE THE
DEPARTMENT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET MORE AND RELEASED WE ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF DENTISTS THAT WE
ARE IN CONTACT WITH WHO HAD
HADN'T REALLY FIGURED OUT THAT
THERE WAS.
ENHANCED REIMBURSEMENTS I THINK
OUTREACH BUT CONTRACTOR THAT'S
DOING OUTREACH TO ENROLLEES
CENTER PROVIDERS MORE OF THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. BUT WE ALSO
SEE DISABLED PATIENTS ARROGANCE
OF A COURSE EVERYONE WHO I AM.
HAS LISTEN TODAY THERE'S YOU
KNOW THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE
SHOULD BE TREATING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES OR ON PEOPLE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS OR PEOPLE ON
MEDICARE ANY DIFFERENTLY THAN%
OUR OWN THREE CHILDREN OR OUR
OWN CHILDREN I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN AND I FEEL STRONGLY.
THAT THE KIND OF ACCESS THAT I
HAVE JUST KID WE HAPPEN TO HAVE
PRIVATE INSURANCE. THEY'VE HELD
MY HAND WHEN I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
MILK IN A SIPPY CUP WAS NOT BAD.
BUT BAD.
WHEN IT'S CONSTANT AT THE SAME
THING WITH I'M A LOT OF THE A
LOT OF THE FAMILIES THEY GET
APPLE JUICE AND THEY THINK APPLE
JUICE IS GOOD IT'S IN THE WEEK
PACKET. BUT THEY PUT IT IN THE
SIPPY CUP AND THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT REALLY HARMS THEM SO I
THINK IT'S EASY TO SAY THEY'RE
DOING IT WRONG BUT WE ARE NOT AS
THE STATE. SUPPORTING FAMILIES
ON MEDI CAL OR DOWN TO COUNT IN
THE SAME WAY THAT WERE
SUPPORTING OF FAMILIES ON ON A
TO PRIVATE INSURANCE WE'VE SEEN
IT IN DIFFERENT THAT I PREVIOUS
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF THAT THEM.
THE TESTIMONY TODAY I THINK IT'S
JUST TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
A STAND. THERE'S NOT TWO
DIFFERENT STANDARDS DEPENDING ON
WHAT INSURANCE YOUR OWN AND THAT
ALL FAMILIES AND ALL PATIENTS
BETWEEN THE TWO THAT THE QUALITY
OF CARE BECAUSE. EVERYONE
MATTERS SO I'M THINK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK.
IT COULD BE REPRESENTING WESTERN
DENTAL. THE STATE'S LARGEST
PROVIDER OF.
SERVICES TO DONNA CALAVERA
MILLION VISITS THIS YEAR.
BOB WE JUST WANT TO SAY WERE
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF MOVING
THE PROGRAM FURTHER ALONG.
USING THE PROPOSALS THAT CDA
AND SEE PAN AND ITS ALLIES
ABROAD LONG WE THINK.
DARIO AND.
AND PREVENTIVE CARE ARE
IMPORTANT NEXT STEPS IN A
PROGRAM THAT IS GETTING BETTER.
THERE IS AN UP TICK IN PROVIDERS
OF THIS YEAR OVER LAST YEAR OF
ALMOST A THOUSAND AND.
IN THE FEE FOR SERVICE CATEGORY
SOMETHING IS HAPPENING THAT'S
BETTER NEEDS TO HAPPEN. FASTER
AND NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH GREATER
VOLUME BUT.
WE'RE ON THE WAY AND I ALSO WANT
TO.
GIVE HAVE TIPPED TO THE
DEPARTMENT SHATTUCK IS ALSO MUCH
BETTER.
POLICY AND BUSINESS PARTNER FOR
PROVIDERS THEN IT MAY HAVE BEEN
FOUR YEARS AGO LOT MORE DIRECT.
A LOT MORE COLLABORATIVE LOT
MORE INCLUSIVE IT'S BETTER THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
CLEVELAND REPRESENTING WRITTEN
CARRY ME OF PEDIATRICS OUGHT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF CHILDREN'S
NOW.
A RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
FLUORIDE VARNISH ON IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN A A. P. RECOMMENDED ON.
MAY THE ONLY RECOMMENDATION THAT
YEAR WAS FOR CHILDREN TO HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR OF FLUORIDE
VARNISH.
SO WE ON SUPPORT.
THEY CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARE SIMEON GANTA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK AND WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SEE PAN AND
ITS PARTNERS RECOMMENDATION.
TO PROVIDE DENTAL CODES FUNDED
THROUGH SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE EIGHT HELP BRING UP TO
THE DYESS. AND WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH DOCTOR WOULD BUT I
MAY HAVE THE DEPARTMENT COME
BACK IN FRONT IF I MAY.
LA EL ENDS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
AND DOCTOR WOULD WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
YEAH I'D JUST LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF OF THE
PROPOSAL'S WE HEARD.
FOR SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS OF
RELATED PREVENTION AND
PERIODONTAL TREATMENT.
IF WE'RE EVER GOING TO BEND THE
COST CURVE ON ON ISSUES WE'VE
GOT TO FOCUS ON PREVENTION.
AND.
AND THEN PERIODONTAL TREATMENT.
OBVIOUSLY SYMPTOM OF OTHER
CONDITIONS AS WELL AND.
CHALLENGES THAT DIABETICS FACE.
BUT ALSO.
OTHER HEALTH CONDITIONS AS WELL
AND SO.
.
I MEAN COURAGE TO HEAR FROM SOME
THAT THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
PROVIDERS COMING OUT.
IN AND PARTICIPATE IN A MEAN
COURAGE TO HEAR THAT THERE IS.
IMPROVEMENT IN THE WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT BUT I I I JUST YOU KNOW.
WITH MAYBE WERE INCHING UP ABOVE
BUT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THAT WE'VE
REALLY TURNED THAT CORNER THERE
AND. AND FUNDAMENTALLY STILL THE
THERE REALLY.
HIGH CASA DELIVERING CARE.
TO PEOPLE IN THIS PROFESSION
MAKE THE DATA CAL RATES THAT
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL THAT WE FIND
A WAY TO STICK CONTINUE TO
SUPPLEMENT THOSE ARE INCREASES
BECAUSE.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT FINANCIALLY
SUSTAINABLE FOR MOST PEOPLE AND
PRIVATE PRACTICE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES.
.
I COULD GO INTO THE STORIES OF
MY OWN PRACTICE WE'VE HEARD HIM
HER MOM BEFORE BUT YOU KNOW YOU
CAN ONLY DO. YOU CAN ONLY
PROVIDE CARE AT A LOSS FOR SO
LONG BEFORE YOU LOSE THE ABILITY
TO PRIDE CARE.
SO.
SO. IT'S
IT'S A CHALLENGE GOING FORWARD
BUT I AM ENCOURAGED AND WOULD
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE FOCUS ON ON
THE CODES THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
IT. PREVENTION.
AND AND APPEARED ON THE
TREATMENT.
THINKING.
I WANTED TO ECHO MANY OF THE
SAME COMMENTS.
BOTH PROVIDER PARTICIPATION AND
UTILIZATION OUR FITNESS
NECESSARY FOR US TO ACTUALLY
PREVENT DISEASE.
I'M I'M A BIT STRUCK LOOKING AT
THE FACT THAT TWENTY ONE PERCENT
OF ADULTS UTILIZED CARE EACH AND
EVERY YEAR THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER AND.
HAVE CONCERNS THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS WE ARE NOT THERE YET IS
OUR RATES.
AND SO JUST WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
DEPARTMENT TO REALLY WILL WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
ADVOCATES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE INFORMATION
BEFORE US AT THE ME REPURPOSE.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
EIGHT OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NOT
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BURR'S
MY NAME IS MICHELLE GIVENS AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE COUNTY EXECUTIVE HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO REQUEST AND. ROLL OVER
ABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ROLL OVER LOCAL
ORAL HEALTH PROGRAM FUNDING FROM
ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT.
AND AS DOCTOR KUMAR STATED
THERE'S I HAVE ROUGHLY EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR THAT'S BEEN SET
ASIDE FOR GRANTS TO LOCAL ORAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
INTENDED TO CREATE AND EXPAND TO
CUT THE CAPACITY AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO CONDUCT.
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AND
LINKAGES TO ADD DENTAL PROVIDERS
THE GRANTS ARE PROVIDED FOR A
FIVE YEAR PERIOD WITH FUNDING
SPREAD EVENLY.
OVER THE COURSE OF EACH YEAR
AND ACCORDING TO GUIDELINES THAT
WERE RELEASED BY THE LOCAL ORAL
HEALTH PROGRAM FUNDING CANNOT BE
ROLLED OVER FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
HOWEVER WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND HAVING ONLY SIX
MONTHS FOR EXAMPLE TO EXPAND A
FULL YEAR IS WORTH ABOUT HOW
OUT.
FUNDING ALLOCATION IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND WE FIND OURSELVES
CHALLENGE TO REALLY EXPAND THE
GRANT FUNDS IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
AND WE STAND TO LOSE ACCESS TO
CREATE CRITICAL RESOURCES THEY
CAN GO BACK INTO THE PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE. AND
UTILIZING THE PROGRAM AT ITS
MAXIMUM CAPACITY IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE EARLIER YEARS
OF THE PROGRAM ARE REALLY CARED
AT AND CAN'T BUILDING THE
STAFFING CAPACITY THE INTERNAL
CAPACITY IN DOING THINGS SUCH AS
ASSESSMENT SEN. ON COMMUNITY
HEALTH NEEDS ASSESSMENTS AND SO
FORTH AND BUILDING WHAT AND A
COMMUNITY IMPROVEMENT PLAN WOULD
LOOK LIKE THE LATTER YEARS FOCUS
MORE ON INVESTMENTS OF
STRATEGIES AT PROMOTING EVIDENCE
BASED STRATEGIES CONDUCTING OUR
REGION IMPLEMENTATION. AND
HEALTH AND EDUCATION LITERALIST
LITERACY CAMPAIGNS AND.
I WOULD ALSO JUST MENTION THE
ABSENT THE ABILITY TO ROLE OVER
THE FUNDING IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT AND USE
FUNDING WOULD GO BACK AND AND BE
USED FOR THE INTENT OF
FURTHERING THE PROPOSITION BUT
IT DOES NOT GUARANTEE THAT THE
FUNDING WE GO BACK TO THE LOCAL
ORAL. HEALTH PROGRAM NOR DOES IT
GUARANTEE THAT WE GO BACK TO THE
PARTICULAR JURISDICTION THAT
WOULD HAVE LOST THE FUNDING. AND
SO I REQUEST TODAY AND IS
MODELED AFTER OTHER PRACTICES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY HAPPENING FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE TOBACCO PROGRAM
WHERE IT ALLOWS THE ABILITY TO
ROLL OVER FUNDING FOR UP TO
THREE YEARS AND MOVING FORWARD.
AND AGAIN WE ARE JUST REALLY
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT THAT THE
FUNDS ARE USED PURELY FOR THE
ENTIRE AND THAT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WERE ABLE TO MAKE GREAT
DECISIONS AND THAT.
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING IS
GOING TO BE SUSTAINABLE.
I THINK YOU WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE NINE.
KIMBERLY CHEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK WHERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
STEVEN IS ONE OF THE IS THE
COMPUTER FOR THE STATE ORAL
HEALTH NETWORK.
IN OUR WORK TALKING TO FOLKS
AROUND THE STATE ON FOLKS ARE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS WORK TO.
TO FINALLY DEVELOP ALL OF ORAL
HEALTH PLAN FOR COUNTIES AND IT
WOULD BE A SHAME FOR ON THE WORK
TO BE DISRUPTED ON. THAT IF IT
WERE NOT FOR THIS PROPOSAL BEING
ADOPTED SO WE ORDER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
I BRING UP INSTANCE OVER THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL I WE WERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS SUPPORTERS OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX AND WE ARE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS I'M
MONEY GOING TO. DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR ORAL HEALTH
NEEDS REALLY DO SEE THIS AS SORT
OF A GAME CHANGER ALL OVER THE
STATE TO IMPROVE I'M ORAL
HEALTH.
NOT JUST IN THE DENTAL PROGRAM
BUT FOR EVERYBODY VERY CONCERNED
THAT THE MONEY MAYBE I'M YOU
KNOW I'M NOT BE FLOWING THE WAY
WE'D LIKE IT TO AND THAT WE KNOW
WE'RE HEARING FROM. SOME LOCAL
FOLKS THAT THEY'RE HAVING ISSUES
GETTING THE MONEY OUT THE DOOR
AND ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT IT
MIGHT BE DIVERTED TO SOME OTHER
PURPOSE WHEN IT WAS CLEARLY THE
INTENT OF THE VOTERS THAT. THIS
MONEY I'M GO TO ORAL HEALTH
THANK YOU BECAME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS VERENIGDE TING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL THANK
YOU MA'AM.
WENT AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
MY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN THE COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
AND CLINICS IN SUPPORT.
KATIE ANDREW CHILDREN ALLEN
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
NEVER COME RIGHT OUT ANDERSONOF
PTI SURGERIES SUMMER ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED.
HUMAN.
SIMEON GANT CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE NINE OH BRING IT UP TO
THE DYESS FOR ANY COMMENTS.
I. WILL ADD MY OWN TO START
THEN.
I AGREED WITH THE COMMENT ABOUT
VOTER INTENT IT WAS THE INTENT
FOR US TO SEND THIS MONEY DOWN
TO THE COUNTIES AND FOR THEM TO
SPEND IT RESPONSIBLY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOUR PROPOSAL IS
MODELED AFTER WHAT WE DO WITH
OTHER HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
AND I'M QUITE SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
YOU PRESENTED HERE TODAY.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
NINE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TEN
.
A LOT ISSUE I'M COMMENTING ON A
DESTRUCTIVE THERE.
.
SO DOES THE PROPOSAL FROM AS CDA
TO.
PUT SALUTE I MEAN FLUORIDE AS A
MEDICAL COVERED BENEFIT. STF IS
A TOPICAL AYE MEDICAMENT THAT
YOU CAN ESSENTIALLY PAINT ONTO
TEETH IN A HOUSE THAT. CAN SLOW
OR STOP ON THE GROWTH OF CAVITY
SO IT'S ESSENTIALLY A GAME
CHANGER IN THE FIELD OF
DENTISTRY.
IT IS CURRENTLY BEING USED BY
THE DEPARTMENT IN THE DOMAIN TO
PILOT DTI. DOESN'T ELEVEN
COUNTIES FOR KIDS UNDER SIX AND
ONLY SOME OF THOSE KIDS HAVE THE
HIGHEST NEED.
SO WE USE FEEL LIKE THAT IT IS
M. IT'S IMPORTANT ENOUGH THAT
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR ALL THE
DATA CAL BENEFICIARIES. NOT JUST
THOSE IN THOSE ELEVEN COUNTIES
AND WE KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS LOOKING EVALUATING THAT S.
I'M BUT THERE'S A LOT OF DATA
THAT'S ALREADY OUT OF THE OUT
THERE. THE LAST TWO CD INTERNALS
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY LOOKED
AT THIS THEIR SUBSTANTIAL
RESEARCH THAT'S BEEN DONE AND WE
KNOW THAT IT WORKS AND SO WE
THINK THAT IT SHOULD BE AN
OPTION I'M FOR THE PROVIDERS AND
AND CAL JUST BECAUSE IT IS SUCH
A.
NEW OPPORTUNITY AND CAN REALLY.
THINGS ON A COST SAVINGS FOR
YOU KNOW USING THIS AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO TREATMENT
ESPECIALLY ON VERY YOUNG KIDS
AND YOU KNOW THOSE WHO ARE.
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE IN CANTON
YOU KNOW HOLD THEIR MOUTH OPEN
LONG AFTER STEVE TRADITIONAL
TREATMENT.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TEN.
KITTY ANDREW CHILDREN OUT IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK HIM.
BRENT SPENCE WITH THE WEST
HEALTH INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
PERFECT RIGHT NOW ANDERSON OF
PTS ORDER SOME ALSO SUPPORT ACHE
GUMP JUST WITH THE CAB CARRY UP
KIND OF HOW I'M FAMILIES ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE SURPRISED WHEN
THEY GET THE SILVER CAPS.
WHAT WE'VE ALREADY SEEN FROM CUT
CLINICS THAT HAVE SENT US THE
KIDS WITH FLORA IS THAT THE
PARENTS DON'T KNOW THAT?
I'M GONNA GET BLACKENED FROM
THE SILVER IS I THINK IT'S JUST.
AGAIN OVERALL BUT WE JUST
EDUCATE THE FAMILIES THAT.
YOUR. IF YOU DON'T BRUSH IF YOU
DON'T IF YOU DON'T COME IN
EARLIER IF WE'RE NOT GIVING YOU
MORE THAT DENTISTS TO GO TO ALL
THESE THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM BUT ALSO
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THAT. YOU
KNOW THERE'S DISCOLORATION FROM
THE SILVER AND YES THE SILVER
CAPS IS IS THE OTHER OPTION WAS
GONE FAR LONG SO I JUST. I THINK
THAT WE CAN'T DO ENOUGH I'M
ASKING FOR A PR CAMPAIGN PUBLIC
AWARENESS OF HOW BIG A PROBLEM
THAT THE CASE SO THANKS.
I COMMEND.
WITH THAT WILL BRING IT BACK UP
THE DYESS DOCTOR WOULD.
YEAH JUST LIKE THE SAP FIRST OF.
SAW THIS SERVE AT AT NYU COUPLE
YEARS AGO I'M OF TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO AND.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THE VALUE
OF THIS.
AND THE POTENTIAL.
FOR SAVING THE.
A LOT A LOT OF.
A LOT OF A LOT OF DOLLARS AT
THE END OF THE LINE. THERE AT
THE DOWNSIDE IS THAT IT DOES
MAKE THE CHIEF LOOK BLACK.
IN THOSE AREAS WHERE THERE IS
TO QUE BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
IT A REST THE DECAY AND AND
THOSE IN IN SOME THOSE CASES AND
SOME OF THESE POPULATIONS IS
JUST SO HARD TO GET THEM.
INTO TREATMENT THAT IT WOULD BE
A HUGE PUBLIC SERVICE.
TO DO.
TO TO HAVE THIS AS A AS A
COVERED BENEFIT SO I COULDN'T
ENCOURAGE US ONE ENOUGH QUITE
FRANKLY.
WELL WITH THAT.
WE LOOK TO YOU DOCTOR WOULD FOR
ADVICE REGARDING DENTAL ISSUES
AND APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT HERE
TODAY.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE TEN
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE ELEVEN
.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE I AM BUT
DOCTOR PAUL GLASS BUT I'M A
PROFESSOR AT UNIVERSITY CIVIC
SCHOOL OF DENTISTRY IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
.
HAVE AT A FORTY YEAR CAREER
WORKING PRIMARILY IT WITH A
FOCUS ON PEOPLE WITH.
SPECIAL WORD NOW REFER TO
SPECIAL DENTAL CARE NEEDS AS A
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC MEDICAL
MENTAL BEHAVIOR OR DEVELOPMENTAL
CONDITIONS THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO RECEIVE
DENTAL CARE OFTEN IN A NORMAL
MANNER. I STARTED MY CAREER
WORKING IN A VERY CLICK AWAY IN
A HOSPITAL I DIRECTED HOSPITAL
JOURNAL PRACTICE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM.
I SAW MANY PEOPLE WHO WERE
ADMITTED TO THE OPERATING ROOM I
WAS THERE PROVIDING DENTAL
TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD.
YEARS OF NEGLECT.
ENDED UP IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE WERE SPENDING LOTS OF MONEY
TO REPAIR THINGS THAT HADN'T
BEEN ADRESSED FOR A LONG TIME.
I SAW PEOPLE IN THE HOSPITAL WHO
DIED. OF DEADLINE FACTIONS
OFTEN THE DEATH CERTIFICATE
DIDN'T SAY DEADLINE FACTION AT
SAID DUH. OF DISSEMINATED SEPSIS
OR ITS EDNA ARE CARDIAC ARREST
OR BRAIN ABSCESS BUT I KNEW THAT
THEY WERE DYING FROM DOUBLE
DISEASE.
I'M SINCE THAT TIME MY CAREER
TAKEN A SHIFT AND I NOW.
DIRECTOR OF POLICY ADVOCACY
CENTER AT THE UNIVERSITY
PACIFIC'S WITH DENTISTRY IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
VARIOUS WAYS OF TRYING TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO PEOPLE. IN
POPULATIONS HAVE TROUBLE GETTING
DENTAL CARE IN THE NORMAL DENTAL
CARE SYSTEM. FROM AMONG THEM AS
WE WORKED ON.
SOMETHING CALLED A VIRTUAL DEL
HOME SYSTEM WHICH USES
TELEHEALTH CONNECTED TEAMS TO
GET ALLIED THEM PERSONNEL INTO
COMMUNITIES AND HAVE THEM
CONNECTED BY A TELEHEALTH SYSTEM
INTO DENTISTS.
IF I HAD A OF A SLIDE SHOW HERE
THE SHOW YOU A PICTURE OF A
YOUNG MAN WHO'S IN A.
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY IN SAN
MATEO WHO HAD HAD ALL OF HIS
PREVIOUS DENTAL CARE DONE IN A
HOSPITAL OPERATING ROOM.
HE WOULD WALK INTO DENTAL OFFICE
HE'D BE NERVOUS TO DENNIS WOULD
LOOK AT AMOUNTS I CAN'T WORK ON
THIS PERSON NEEDS TO BE UNDER
GENERAL ANESTHESIA. AND YET IN
HIS OWN HOME WITH A DENTAL
HYGIENIST USE IT WILL TAKE
COMPLETE RECORDS CLEANEST TEETH
BUMP DO SMALL FILLINGS THAT ARE
ALLOWED NOW USE THINGS LIKE
SOBRE DIE MEAN FOR IT HE MAY
NEVER HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
HOSPITAL AGAIN. AND YET HIS
HISTORY HAS BEEN SPENDING HUGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY IN A HOSTILE
SITUATION FOR SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN DO AT A FRACTION OF THE
COST.
NOW.
THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE IDENTICAL
SYSTEM THAT ISN'T ORGANIZED TO
SUPPORT THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY
ADELA CALLOUS PRIMARILY A
PIECEWORK SYSTEM IT PAYS FOR THE
FILLING. AND IS WILLING NO
DIFFERENTIATION IN TERMS OF THE
OF THE PERSON WHO NEEDS THAT
FEELING. THAT PEOPLE WHO WHO
COULD ACTUALLY RECEIVE DEL CARE
WITH A LECTURE TIME SITTING IN
THE CHAIR DOING THINGS MORE
SLOWLY THERE'S NO EXTRA
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THAT. SOMEONE
WHO TAKES A FOUR FIVE CALLS TO
THEIR PHYSICIANS TO WORK OUT THE
MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS OR WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH CONSENT ISSUES THAT
ARE PRESENT IN NORMAL PEOPLE
THERE'S NO. BUT EXTRA
COMPENSATION FOR ANY OF THOSE
KIND OF ACTIVITIES SORES RESULT.
AS YOU ALL KNOW IN THE SYSTEM
WHERE MANY PROVIDERS WHERE HER
ACCEPTING GONNA CALCULATOR DOES
BARELY GETTING BY. TO TAKEN AT A
PERSON WHO'S GONNA TAKE TWICE OR
THREE TIMES A FOUR TIMES AS MANY
HOURS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
TREATMENT FOR THEM. IT BECOMES
COMPLETELY UNDOABLE
SO THIS PROPOSALBEFORE IS TO BE
ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE CONDITIONS
THAT DO TAKE EXTRA TIME TO
PROVIDE REIMBURSEMENT.
FOR THEM I THINK THAT TOUGH THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT SOME YOU KNOW
IT'S HARD TO QUANTIFY ALL THE
SAVINGS IN THIS BECAUSE SOME OF
THEM ARE AND. ARE IN OTHER KINDS
OF BUCKETS AS YOU ALL KNOW THE
WAY WE WE DO OUR ACCOUNTING IN
THE WORLD. UP BUT YET I THINK
THAT WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL FOR
NOT ONLY.
SAVING A LOT OF MONEY BY
PROVIDING EARLY AND EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE IF YOU
COULD PROVIDE. THE UP PROVIDERS
A LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA
REIMBURSEMENT TO TAKE THE EXTRA
TIME TO BE ABLE TO SEE THESE
POPULATIONS. I THINK THIS
PROPOSES A VERY WISE USE OF
PUBLIC MONEY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE ELEVEN.
BRENT SPENCER WITH THE WEST
HEALTH INSTITUTE ACTUALLY THE
SPONSORS OF THIS POLLS BEFORE
YOU.
WE PREDICTED RATIONS IMPORTANT
A PROPOSAL TO HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN NEED AS DESCRIBED
DOT LASSEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
WENT AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE'VE HEARD OF
ACCESS ISSUES FOR THIS
POPULATION SO DO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I BREATHE HIM INSTANCE ARE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT AND
WE DO HAVE SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES
THAT WE FACE WITH THAT AND.
SPONSORS AROUND ENSURING THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING TO CUT
OFF ON THE OTHER SOURCES OF CARE
AND IN SOME INSTANCES WHERE AS
WE'VE HEARD THAT. UNLIKE THE
REGIONAL CENTERS WILL SORT OF
BACK FILL AND FOR THESE I AM
CASE MANAGEMENT AND BEHAVIORAL
MANAGEMENT CODES AND JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT IN THE PROCESS
OF.
.
PUTTING ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN
FOR THESE SERVICES WHICH WE
DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND AND AND
ACKNOWLEDGE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE'RE NOT.
YOU KNOW CREATING NEW PROBLEMS.
I COMMEND.
MEDICARE RIGHT NOW ANDERSON ON
PBS SURGERIES CENTER OUT UP
UNTIL THREE YEARS AGO ITEM WE
ONLY TO CARE CHILDREN BUT WE
WERE ACTUALLY ASKED BY OF THAT
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR PATIENTS UP TO
TWENTY FIVE. OF SPECIAL NEEDS
ARE AND AS HIGH AS WE COULD GO
AND BECAUSE WE'RE AWAY FROM. A
HOSPITAL UP TO TWENTY FIVE IS
WHAT WE DEEMED SAFE SO FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS WE'VE
SUCCESSFULLY PARTNERED.
WERENT DIG WITH WITH
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN AND BEEN
ABLE TO.
SEAT SPECIAL NEEDS PATIENTS TWO
MONTHS FOR TWO DAYS OUT OF A
MONTH AND ON THOSE DAYS WE CAN
ONLY SEE.
THREE PATIENTS A FOR PATIENTS
RATHER THAN USUAL TAN SO YEAH
IT'S IT'S KIND OF LIKE A MEDICAL
INTENSITY CHO TAKES LONGER
BODIES PATIENTS HAVE NEVER HAD
CARE BEFORE. OF WASTE WE WILL
ALSO CASE MANAGEMENT THEM AND
HELP OUT IF THEY THERE'S SOME
BLOOD WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
WE ASK THE FAMILIES TO COME IN
WITH THE THE VIALS THAT THEY
NEED FOR THAT.
WE CUT THEIR HAIR PARA THEIR
NAILS THINGS LIKE THAT SO I DO
HAVE A SUCCESS STORY TO SHARE
THIS FROM THIS WEEK WHERE
THERE'S NOT A MOM HAS TWO
DAUGHTERS THAT HAVE AUTISM. AND
THE FIRST TIME THE GIRLS CAME
THEY WERE TEN AND TWELVE AND
THEY FOUND THEY HAD A LOT OF
DECAY JUST FOURTEEN TO ABBOTT
EIGHTEEN CAVITIES BOTH OF THEM
WE'VE NOW SEEN THEM EVERY YEAR
THE LAST THREE YEARS AND THE.
BUT WANT ONE OF THE YOUNGEST OF
THE TWO GIRLS SHE IS LESS ARM
SHE HAS NOT A SEVERE OCT AUTISM
AS OF THIS LAST TIME WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA TRY. SINCE YOU
DIDN'T HAVE ANY CAVITIES AND ALL
THIS TIME AND THEY ARE
MAINTAINING OUR HER. DENTAL
HEALTH BUT THAT SHE'S GOING TO
TRY TO GET A X. RACING CLEANINGS
GOING FORWARD AT IT UP WITHIN
THE PROVIDERS THAT WE CAN'T JUST
BEFORE CAN I CATCH IT EARLY
ENOUGH THAT WE ARE ABSOLUTELY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THING.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE ELEVEN ON BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS.
DOCTOR WHAT.
JUST JUST PANIC
APPRECIATE SEEING DOCTOR
GLASSMAN AGAIN HERE SEEN.
FOR MANY YEARS NOW AND.
YOU KNOW.
CHALLENGING POPULATION.
TAKES MORE TIME AND.
TO PROVIDE THAT BUT THAT THAT
THAT INVESTMENT OF TIME YIELDS
HUGE HUGE BENEFITS MUCH MORE
THAN WHAT WOULD BE THE THAN THE
PROVIDES A BE REMUNERATED AND
SO.
YES YOU NOT SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF
THIS PROPOSAL I THINK IT MAKES.
COMPLETE SENSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR GLASSMAN FOR
THE PROPOSAL WILL HOLD ISSUE
ELEVEN OPEN THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS TRANSMIT HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE HEALTH PLAN OF SAN MATEO.
HEALTH PLAN OF SAN MATEO WAS A
COUNTY ORGANIZE HEALTH SYSTEM
THAT'S A MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
PLAN IT'S A PUBLIC NON PROFIT
PLAN I KNOW SOME OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT. MODEL WITH KOS IN
THEIR DISTRICTS AND YOU'VE JUST
HEARD PARTNERSHIP MEAN MENTION
THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THEM.
THE MODEL.
HEALTH PLANS ABOUT SAN MATEO
STRESSES PREVENTIVE CARE AYE
KEEPING PEOPLE HEALTHY THEREBY
SAVING MONEY COORDINATING CARE
GETTING PEOPLE INTO THAT TYPE OF
UP PREVENTIVE CARE.
FORTUNATELY IN SAN MATEO THE
UTILIZATION RATES FOR DENTAL
CARE FOR ELIGIBLE ENROLLEES IS
EVEN WORSE THAN THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE.
I BELIEVE IT'S FORTY PERCENT OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE ELIGIBLE AND
SEVENTEEN PERCENT OF ADULTS WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE RECEIVE DENTAL
CARE.
AND SO ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
SAN MATEO COUNTY THE ORAL HEALTH
COALITION WHICH CONSISTS OF
PATIENT ADVOCATES AND THE DENTAL
COMMUNITY. BEGAN TO GET TOGETHER
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET HIGHER UTILIZATION RATES AND
THEY.
APPROACHED THE HEALTH PLAN OF
SAN MATEO BE AN UNKNOWN ENTITY
THAT WAS ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH
THIS TYPE OF A STRUCTURE OF
GETTING PEOPLE IN TO RECEIVE
HEALTHCARE. AND SO THEY.
HAVE COME FORWARD WITH THE
PROPOSAL OF BEFORE YOU TODAY
WHICH. IS A PROPOSAL FOR A FIVE
YEAR PILOT PROGRAM WHEREBY THE
HEALTH PLAN A SAN MATEO WAS THE
HEALTH PLAN WOULD.
TAKE OVER OR ADD DENTAL.
SERVICES AS PART OF THEIR CARE
SO JUST LIKE PHARMACY OR MEDICAL
OR IMAGE SEEN.
DENTAL CARE WOULD BE PART OF IT
AND THEN THEY WOULD AS THE
HEALTHPLAN WHEN THEY'RE. A
REMINDING THEIR ENROLLEES IT'S
TIME FOR YOUR ANNUAL CHECKUP OR
YOUR MAMMOGRAM OR YOUR
CHOLESTEROL TESTS THEY WOULD NOW
BE IN A POSITION TO REMIND
PEOPLE IT'S TIME TO.
GET.
DENTAL EXAM OR A CLEANING.
THE WAY WE ENVISION NET AND WE.
WILL HAVE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR GUARD
GUIDANCE BUT WITH THE WAY WE
ENVISIONED IT WOULD BE THAT THEY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR A PER
PATIENT PER MONTH. CAPITATED
RATE THAT THEY WOULD BE AT RISK
FOR SUFFOLK COST MORE THAN WHAT
THEY ARE RECEIVING.
THE HEALTH PLAN WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE BALANCE.
BUT THROWING THAT INTO A.
COORDINATED DELIVERY MODEL WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT IT WILL PROVIDE
GREATER UTILIZATION BETTER
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND THAT. THE
HEALTH PLAN COULD ADD EVENTUALLY
SAVE MONEY BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE SEEING A LOT OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO GET A MORE
COMPLICATED HEALTH.
YOU KNOW. THINGS THAT THEY NEED
TO TREAT AND ARE MORE COSTLY AND
SO THEY'RE HOPEFUL THAT THROUGH
THIS PLAN THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
PREVENT SOME OF THOSE. THE PLAN
THEY DO ENVISION A REPORTING
MECHANISM WHERE THEY CAN STUDY
TO SEE IF THERE IS BETTER
UTILIZATION AND BETTER OUTCOMES
ON ON THE BACK AND. AND BE ABLE
TO REPORT THAT TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE STATE LEGISLATURE TO SEE
IF THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM IS IT IS
A SUCCESS SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SIR.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE TWELVE.
BREANNA PITTMAN SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE
ARE IN SUPPORT.
COME OVER LOCAL DENTAL
SOCIETIES IN SAN MATEO.
TWO I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND ARE IN
SUPPORT I'M WE'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN ON THE
PROPOSAL AND WHILE WE HAVE HAD
SOME QUESTIONS AROUND DENTAL
MANAGED CARE IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM IN THE PAST.
THIS.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE RISK
WOULD BE MANAGED LOOKS LIKE
SOMETHING NEW AND DIFFERENT TO
US AND WE DO LIKE THAT IT'S I'M
SERVE A FIVE YEAR CONTAINED
PILOT WITH MY VALUATION THAT WE
THINK WILL. AND HOPEFULLY IT
WILL TEACH US SOMETHING I AM
ABOUT WHAT INTEGRATION.
CAN LOOK LIKE
THE AGREEMENT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE HAVE NO
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT WOULD NOTE
THAT THE LEGAL AID OF SAN MATEO
DOES SUPPORT THIS. A WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS DIFFERENT
FROM SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO SEE THE
UTILIZATION RATE COTTON.
TO TO BE THE SAME AS I FOR
MANAGE CARROTS AT LEAST TEN
PERCENT LOWER THAN IT IS AND THE
FEE FOR SERVICE SIDE SO I WOULD
WANT TO SEE ROBUST DATA
COLLECTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM.
LIVE A CORRIVEAU ANDERSON AGAIN
REPS ANY PDF SURGERIES SENATOR
ESTES OR IN THIRTY THREE
COUNTIES AND WE WE JUST APPLAUD
THIS A PILOT PROGRAM I THINK ON
THE INTEGRATION IS SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO THERE SO
MANY RURAL COUNTIES IN SO MANY.
AREAS WERE NOT REACHING AND
WE'RE GOING TO NEED SOME COME
INNOVATIONS HOPEFULLY SOME GOOD
DATA COMES OUT OF THIS AND WE.
HAVE A NEW AND BETTER WAYS TO DO
IT SO THANK YOU.
HUMAN.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
TO BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
DOCTOR WHAT.
BUT OBVIOUSLY SEEN BETTER
INTEGRATION WITH MEDICAL DENTAL
CARE I THINK IS IS A IS A GOAL
THAT A LOT OF US. I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE.
AND THE.
WELL FAILURE OF IN MANY WAYS OF
OF A LOT OF WAYS OF THE CURRENT
PILOT PROJECT PROJECTS ON DENTAL
MANAGED CARE HAVE.
HAVE LEFT A LOT TO BE DESIRED
SO.
YEAH AND I. IT'S INTERESTING DE
I'M CURIOUS HOW.
ARE YOU SEE.
OTHER THAN COORDINATING HOW DO
YOU PLAN HOW THEY PLAN TO GET
PROVIDERS IN INVOLVED BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A SILLY
FAIRLY QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS
OR RURAL OR ARE THERE CLIP
CLINICS.
SO JUST TELLING PEOPLE YOU NEED
TO GO TO THE DENTIST IS IS NOT
GOING TO BE ADEQUATE.
YEAH FAIR FAIR QUESTION DOCTOR
WOULD AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS
BEEN A YEAR AND A HALF IN THE
PLANNING OF THE HEALTH PLANS SAN
MATEO WASN'T.
READY TO.
RUN TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT A PILOT PROGRAM WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT OF THEIR TO LOCAL.
DENTAL SOCIETIES THAT THE MY
MID POLL MID PENINSULA AND.
SAN MATEO COUNTY DENTAL
SOCIETIES AND SO THEY HAVE BEEN
TALKING WITH THEM AS PART OF
THIS ORAL HEALTH COALITION. FOR
A YEAR AND A HALF AND I THINK
BASICALLY THE HEALTH PLAN IT SAN
MATEO SAID LOOK WE'RE NOT
WILLING TO TACKLE THIS UNLESS WE
THINK WE CAN GET. BY AND FROM
THE LAW PROVIDER COMMUNITY TO.
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM
OTHERWISE THEY THEY WOULDN'T BE
HERE AND AND AGAIN FAILED TO
MENTION YOU'VE HEARD A LITTLE
BIT PART OF THAT WAS BY AND FROM
THE PATIENT ADVOCACY COMMUNITY
SO THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE A.
THE PEOPLE RECEIVING THE CARE
WOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THIS
BUT ALSO TO YOUR POINT THAT
THERE WOULD BE BY OFF FROM THE
PROVIDERS WHO WOULD BE WILLING
TO PARTICIPATE. THEY SEEMED TO
THINK THEY HAVE THE CRITICAL
MASS TO TO GET IT GOING BASED ON
THAT SUPPORT IN THE.
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION SO.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR CLIENTS A
LITTLE NERVOUS ESPECIALLY
ASSUMING SOME OF THE FINANCIAL
RISK THAT OF THEM THEY THEY
PARTICIPATE IN THESE THINGS IN
THE PAST WHERE THEY'VE ASSUMED
THE REST OF IT TO HOPEFULLY GET
SOME REWARD AND BE A LITTLE BIT
OF A TRAIL BLAZER AND SO.
THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
OR NOTHING LIKE A LITTLE SKIN IN
THE GAME TO HAVE A LITTLE
INCENTIVE RIGHT.
SO SO BUT BUT.
IT I'M I'M I I LIKE I LIKE THE
APPROACH I THINK IT MAKE I THINK
I THINK WHICH AGAIN MAKES SENSE
WITH THEIR PROPOSALS MAKE SENSE.
CLEARLY HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
GET GET PEOPLE THE CARE THEY
NEED AND THAT THE OTHER PILOTS
HAPPENED BEEN A SUCCESSFUL QUITE
FRANKLY. SO.
THE DATA WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THOUGH.
AT A FORD A PATTERN THIS AFTER
IF IT THE FUTURE FOR OTHER THE
OTHER COUNTY A.
OPERATE HEALTH SYSTEMS.
WE'VE GOT TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
BEING SUCCESSFUL AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT THERE ARE SOME DATA
CHECK IN POINTS ALONG THE WAY.
THAT WE'RE NOT WAITING FIVE
YEARS FOR THEM FOR THE ULTIMATE
DATA BECAUSE OF THAT WE NEED TO
KNOW WE'RE GONNA NEED TO KNOW
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER THAT
THEY WERE THAT THAT WE'RE HAVING
THOUGH SUCCESS METRICS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR. YEAH I'M THE
PROPOSAL.
LANGUAGE WHEN WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD IS REALLY KIND OF OPEN
ENDED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE'RE
LOOKING TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WITH SOME OF THAT BUT
IT IS TRUE THAT OUR INTENTION TO
HAVE SOME.
DATA CHECK IN POINTS.
WILL NEED A LITTLE TIME THAT TO
BUILD A NETWORK.
AND TO GET IT UP AND GOING AND
AND HOPEFULLY GROW IT BUT YEAH I
MEAN THAT THE DATA IS IMPORTANT
AND YOU'VE HEARD AGAIN.
PARTNERSHIPS DOING SOME UNIQUE
THINGS ARE SOME THINGS AND CAL
OPTIMUM ORANGE COUNTY THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO DO SO BUT ALL THIS
IS CONTINGENT ON. HAVING SOME
SORT OF A MODEL THAT THAT SHOW
SOME SUCCESS BEFORE EVERYONE CAN
CUT A DIVAN SO. THANK YOU.
I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEFORE US BUT WOULD HOPE
THAT BOTH THE DEPARTMENT AND
YOURSELF TO WORK WITH OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE. APPROPRIATE
METRICS BEFORE US AS WE GO
FORWARD.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWELVE OPEN INLAND ISSUE
THIRTEEN.
GOOD EVENING.
YOU CARE MEMBERS PLEASURE TO BE
HERE. OF THIS BILL BARNABY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION
ASSOCIATION PROVIDES NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION
TO PEOPLE'S MEDICAL NEEDS
JUSTIFIED I'M HERE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE MISTER STEVE HORN
WHO'S THE PRESIDENT OF C. EMPTY
A. AND HE WILL DESCRIBE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE KIND OF A
RECURRING THEME PROVIDERS WOULD
LIKE TO DO MORE. BUT IT'S NOT
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE UNDER THE
CURRENT THE SITUATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
PUBLISHED CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU.
BUT I'M STEVE HORN PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION ASSOCIATION. FROM
BEHALF OF THE CMT IN THE
PATIENTS WE SERVE MORE
RESPECTFULLY ASKING YOU UP FOR
RESTORATION OF THE A. B. DOT
NINETY SEVEN A TEN PERCENT CUTS.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN RESTORED A.
MADE WHOLE IF YOU WILL SINCE.
TWENTY ELEVEN.
NON EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION WE TRANSPORT THE
CHRONICALLY ILL OF THE MOBILITY
IMPAIRED THE ALLERGY ELDERLY AND
WHEELCHAIR BOUND PATIENTS TO AND
FROM THEIR MEDICAL SERVICES.
MOST OF OUR TRANSPORTS ARE
DIALYSIS PATIENTS.
AND THEY GO THREE TIMES A WEEK
FIFTY TWO WEEKS OUT OF THE YEAR.
AND ACCESS TO CARE ISSUE IS
GROWING OF FOR THE MEDICAL FEE
FOR SERVICE PATIENTS. AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS.
.
ITS DUAL LED DO SOLELY TO THE
LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND WE'RE
FINDING IT ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF
THE METROPOLITAN AREAS IN YOUR
MAJOR METROPOLITAN HUBS IT'S
THERE'S PLENTY OF PROVIDERS
THERE'S PLENTY OF ACCESS. BUT
WHEN YOU START GETTING OUT A
LITTLE BIT AND THEN OF COURSE
YOU RURAL AREAS. IF A PROVIDER
HAS TO DRIVE MORE THAN TEN MILES
TO GO PICK UP A PATIENT.
BECAUSE IN OUR INDUSTRY YOU GET
PAID WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY ON
PORT.
THEY ARE SPENDING MONEY OUT OF
THEIR POCKET TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE AND I BELIEVE THAT MR
WOULD HAVE MENTIONED EARLIER
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY.
DAYS AND WEEKS YOU CAN RUN AT A
LOSS AND SO LOT OF PROVIDERS ARE
DISCONTINUING SERVICE TO ANYBODY
IN THOSE OUTLYING AREAS. AND.
IT'S GETTING WORSE WITH THE
PUSH TO MANAGE CARE.
MANY OF THE PROVIDERS IN THE
PAST WHEN IT WAS PRIMARILY FEE
FOR SERVICE HAD TO FIND WAYS TO
MAKE IT WORK WELL NOW THEY HAVE
ON ANOTHER WHOLE PACE OF
PATIENTS THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO.
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICE AND
MAINTAIN THEIR BUSINESS AND NOT
HAVE TO RELY SO MUCH ON THE FEE
FOR SERVICE SIDE.
AND SO WE'RE SEEING THAT LESS
AND LESS PROVIDERS ARE ARE
ACCEPTING THESE PATIENTS IN
THESE OUTLYING AREAS. AND IN
YOUR MANAGED CARE COUNTIES.
MOST OF THE MANAGED CARE PLANS
ESPECIALLY THE ONES A COVER
RURAL AREAS ARE PAYING ABOVE
MEDI CAL FEE FOR SERVICE RATE
AND ABOVE BEFORE OR WHAT THE TEN
PERCENT CUT IT'S AND SO I WORK
WITH. COUNTY SUB PARTNERSHIP NOT
HEALTH PLAN THAT COVERS.
I WON'T DO A BUNCH OF WORK FANS
HAVE A LOT OF RURAL AREAS
THAT THEY COVER AND THEY PAY
WELL ABOVE THE.
HUNDRED PERCENT.
MEDICAID OUTBREAK THERE ADDING
ANOTHER FIFTEEN TO.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT ON TOP OF
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
MEMBERS ARE RECEIVING THE
TRANSPORTATION NOTHING NEED.
SO.
.
THAT'S REALLY IN A NUTSHELL I
KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN BUSY
WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
COME THROUGH HERE AND A LOT OF.
STORIES AND SO I DON'T WANT TO
WASTE YOUR TIME BUT.
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO BE RESTORED
TO PRE AB NINETY SEVEN IF I
COULD JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT ARE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO GO TO MANAGE
CARE THEN DROPOFF THERE'S A
CONSTANT TURNING. FOR ONE REASON
OR ANOTHER MISSING PAPERWORK
PLATE ELIGIBILITY WHATEVER THAT
NAY REVERT BACK INTO FEE FOR
SERVICE AND THEN THEY DON'T GET
THE SERVICE SAID ED THEY DON'T
THERE'D. THAT THEY CAN'T GET THE
NOT AMONG TO MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION THAT THEY NEED
AND THAT IT'S MONTHS BEFORE THEY
GET BACK ON THE MANAGED CARE
SOLIS. IT'S A CONSTANT PROBLEM
AT PARTICULARLY IN THE FEE FOR
SERVICE BUT BEFORE SERVICE DOES
AFFECT EVERYTHING OF THAT GOES
ON IN MEDI CAL SO THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT. THE NOT IMMATURE
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION WAS THE
FIRST
A PROVIDER GROUP TO SUFFER THE
TEN PERCENT CUT.
SO WHAT LOOKS LIKE PER MAY BE
THE LAST TO HAVE IT RESTORED BUT
WE'RE HERE TO SEE THAT RESULT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR. WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE THIRTEEN.
SAYING NON OF BRING IT UP TO THE
DYESS.
I REPRESENT ONE OF THOSE MORE
RURAL PARTS OF OUR STATE AND HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF MEETING WITH
SOME. MEMBERS OF CMT HAY AND.
THEY WERE ABLE TO ALSO SHARE
STORIES OF COMMUNITIES THAT I
KNOW AND CARE ABOUT THAT.
ARE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS YES YOU
MET WITH ALBERTANS HIS IN ALBERT
THAT HAS BEEN A PROVIDERS SENSE.
AND I BELIEVE THE INDUSTRY FIRST
STARTED IN THE MID TO LATE
SEVENTIES HE'S.
BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF.
WELL I REALLY APPRECIATED HIS
ADVOCACY AND YOURS TOO. WILL
HOLD ISSUE THIRTEEN OPEN IN THE
BOND ISSUE FOR TO. GET HAS TAKEN
THAT
.
IF YOU.
THANK YOU GO HIT OKAY.
GOOD EVENING RESEARCHER MEMBERS
AND THIS IS GALIEN WITH CHILDREN
NOW TERROR HERE TO ASK THAT YOU
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO ENSURE
ACCESS THE ASTHMA EDUCATION. AND
HOME ENVIRONMENTAL TRIGGER
ASSESSMENTS FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. PUT POORLY
CONTROLLED ASTHMA.
SPECIFICALLY THE REQUEST THAT
THE DEPARTMENT ENSURE MEDICARE
COVERAGE QUALITY MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR QUALIFIED NON
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS.
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES UNDER
THE SUPERVISORS UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A LICENSED
PRACTITIONER.
IMAGINE A FAMILY WERE FOUR YEAR
OLD HAS RECENTLY RETURNED FROM
HER. THIRD ET VISIT FOR OUTSIDE
AT THE DIRECTION OF THEIR DOCTOR
THEIR VISITED BY SYLVIA A WELL
TRAINED COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
WHO SPEAKS THEIR LANGUAGE.
TWO REVIEWS OF DOCTORS ASTHMA
EDUCATION ASTHMA ACTION PLAN TO
MAKE SURE THE FAMILY KNOWS HOW
TO RECOGNIZE SYMPTOMS OVERSEEING
ASTHMA. AND LOOKS AROUND THE
FAMILY'S HOME. THAT'S ISSUE
QUICKLY IDENTIFIES SEVERAL
ASTHMA TRIGGERS AND EDUCATES THE
FAMILY ABOUT HOW TO AT
PRELIMINARY FOR REDUCE THEM.
NO THAT'S OVER SUPPORT FOR THE
FAMILIES WORKS.
SUCH INTERVENTIONS INCLUDING
THOSE PROVIDED BY QUALIFY NON
LICENSED ROFESSIONALS HAVE BEEN
PROVEN IN A VARIETY OF STUDIES
TO REDUCE ASTHMA ET VISITS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES.
MANY STUDIES ALSO NOTE THE
FINANCIAL RETURN OF INVESTMENTS
FROM THESE INTERVENTIONS BY
REDUCING MORE COSTLY EDIE VISITS
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY ACCESS TO THESE
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA IS VERY
LIMITED.
INCREASING THE USE OF QUALIFY
NON LICENSED PROFESSIONAL IS AN
INEFFECTIVE WAY TO PROVIDE
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES.
POORLY CONTROLLED ASTHMA THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED WE THINK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU BUNDLE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M DELIVERS
WITH RAMP REGIONAL ASTHMA
MANAGEMENT AND PREVENTION. AND
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
REQUEST TO ENSURE MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES HAVE ACCESS TO
CRITICAL ASTHMA PREVENTION
SERVICES. ASTHMA SIX SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM AND DRIVER
OF HEALTH CARE COSTS
EFFECTIVE AS A MANAGEMENT
REQUIRES A COMBINATION OF FOR
VITAL COMPONENTS.
CLINICAL MANAGEMENT MEDICATION
PATIENT EDUCATION AND CONTROLLED
ENVIRONMENTAL TRIGGERS DESERVES
LAST TWO COMPONENTS ASTHMA
EDUCATION AND CONTROL THEM
GOVERNMENTAL TRIGGERS. WHERE
THERE IS A CRITICAL GAP AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS
IN ASTHMA CARE? ORGANIZATIONS
RAMP CHILDREN NOW IN THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK HAVE BEEN AN ONGOING
PROACTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
FOR OVER TWO YEARS
FROM PRIOR TO THE INTRODUCTION
OF AB THREE NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU LAST YEAR
THAT'S OUGHT TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. THROUGHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS OF THE BILL
AND NOW AND NOW AFTER THE BILL'S
VETO WE APPRECIATE THAT
ASSISTANCE DEPARTMENT HAS
PROVIDED ALONG THE WAY.
SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT HAVE SHED SOME
LIGHT ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
AUTHORITY ON THIS MATTER BUT THE
FACT IS THAT WE DON'T YET HAVE A
CLEAR AND SYSTEM WIDE SOLUTION
TO INCREASE ACCESS. TO THE
SERVICES THROUGH CLINICAL
DOLLARS.
AT LAST THURSDAY'S HEARING OF
THE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
A DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR JENNIFER
CAN'T INDICATED THAT DIRECTION
FROM THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE
BUDGET COULD BE USE A USEFUL
WAY.
TO INCREASING ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES.
SHE SPECIFICALLY REFERENCED THE
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM
WHICH WAS INCLUDED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET TRAILER BILL AS A
POTENTIAL MODEL FOR HOW TO
ADDRESS THESE NEEDED ASTHMA
SERVICES.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES HAVE
ACCESS TO BE SERVICES INCLUDING
WHEN THEY ARE PROVIDED BY NON
LICENSE INDIVIDUAL SUCH AS A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER.
SUPERVISED BY LICENSED PROVIDER
THANK YOU AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS FOR.
THANK YOU SIR. WILL NOT TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
FOURTEEN.
MY NAME'S MARY FRAZIER I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AND I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BREATH
MOBILE WE PROVIDE A MOBILE
ASTHMA CLINIC WITH A PROVIDER
AND. ASTHMA TRAINED STAFF.
AND WE SPEAK THE LANGUAGE OF
OUR.
CLIENTS.
AND I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THESE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE WORKERS
BEING TRAINED.
TO.
MAKE A LINK BETWEEN PROVIDERS
AND THE HOME.
ARE.
.
ASSOCIATION OF ASTHMA EDUCATORS
IS A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION. FOR
OUR GROUP AND
FOUR YEARS AGO I BEGAN WITH THE
GROUP FROM MINNESOTA TO MAKE.
THE EDUCATION PROTOCOL.
WHETHER THAT MODULES FOR
EDUCATING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS TO GO INTO A HOME AND
WORK WITH A FAMILY AND TALK
ABOUT ASTHMA.
AND THE TRIGGERS AND THE
BARRIERS TO CARE.
AND LEAVE PILOT AT THIS PROGRAM
WE'VE BEEN OFFERING IT IN
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THROUGH DIFFERENT GROUPS ARE
DOING IT.
BUT THE PEOPLE WERE TRAINING WE
ASK THEM TO GO OUT AS VOLUNTEERS
TO DO THIS.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS IS AN AREA OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IF WE CAN
TRAIN THESE HEALTH WORKERS.
THEY'RE NOT THEY DON'T HAVE
LICENSES BUT THEY WORK UNDER THE
SERVICE OF SOMEBODY WHO IS.
TRAINED IN IT.
AND.
WE GIVE SOME OF ENTRY LEVEL JOB
IN THE HEALTH CARE WE PAY THEM
WHAT THEY'RE WORTH TO GO INTO
FAMILIES AND SHOULD BE ENDED.
RESOURCE WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
FOR ASTHMA EDUCATION.
AND CONTROLLING ASTHMA.
IT'S AS MUCH A HUGE PROBLEM. IN
SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM ER VISITS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND.
IT'S BEEN SHOWN THAT THIS AND
OTHER STATES THAT ARE DOING THIS
THROUGH THEIR.
MEDICAID.
SERVICES THAT IT'S WORKING ON
DECREASING ER HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND ABSENTEEISM THANK YOU.
AGREEMENT.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MARILYN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL WE
OBVIOUSLY REGRET ANYTIME
CHILDREN SHOW UP IN OUR
EMERGENCY ROOM BUT IT'S EVEN
MORE REGRETTABLE WHEN IT'S FOR
SOMETHING THAT'S PREVENTABLE SO
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
REASONABLE PROPOSAL THINK YOU
CAN.
CAN REALLY COUNT THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF THIS PROPOSAL.
AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOTED
WE'VE BEEN IN PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON THIS ISSUE BUT.
REALLY WOULD LIKE GREATER
CLARITY ON THIS IF WE ALL AGREE
THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO THEN.
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR EXACTLY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT I'M WHAT INITIAL
THINGS THEY NEED FROM US IN
TERMS OF RESOURCES OR OUR OR
STATUTORY CHANGES OR TO MAKE
THIS I. THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MARIA VALDEZ LET HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA ONE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE SPONSORS OF
THIS PROPOSAL AND SEE PAN AND
AREN'T SUPPORT THINKING WE CAN.
ON A HAS SUPPLIED WITH THE
UNITED WAY THE CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
THINKING.
MEDICARE RIGHT NOW ANDERSON PP I
SURGERY CENTER AGAIN HUGE
PROBLEM IN THE THIRTY THREE
COUNTIES THAT WE SERVE AND WITH
THE FIRES ARE INTIMATELY
HAPPENED WE SEE A LOT OF THIS IN
THE SAME PATIENT POPULATION.
THE HUMAN.
SINGLE FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE FOURTEEN I'LL BRING IT UP
TO THE DYESS.
I WAS. TOUCHED BY ONE OF THE
COMMENTS HERE ABOUT SCHOOL
ABSENTEEISM AND RECOGNIZING THAT
FRESNO THE NUMBER ONE REASON WHY
KIDS MISS.
CLASS
HIS HOUSE MY EXACERBATIONS.
AND SO WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT IF I MADE TO HELP
ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS WE
HAVE. IN THE STAFF COMMENT
SECTION.
CERTAINLY AGAIN WERE NAY MULLIN
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
AND JUST I'M FOR CLARITY
PURPOSES SO WE TO COVER TODAY
UNDER THE MEDICAL PROGRAM.
.
ASTHMA AND.
DELIVERY OF ASTHMA SERVICES AS
WELL AS THE ABILITY FOR OUR HOME
ASSESSMENTS TO BE COMPLETED. ARM
THOSE ASSESSMENTS CAN BE
COMPLETED BY LICENSE
TISHAWN OURS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM I THINK
WHERE THERE'S A DISCONNECT IS
THAT UNDER OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM
WE DO NOT ANIMAL I'M LICENSED
PROVIDERS. SO THEY CAN'T
PRACTICE AS WELL AS.
COMMENTED ON BY ONE OF THE
OUTCOME.
PUBLIC TESTIFY OURS IS THAT
THROUGH A LICENSED PHYSICIAN OR
LICENSED NURSES THEY CAN DO
THEIR TRAINING AND PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT AND THE SUPERVISION OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. AND THEN THEY CAN BILL
FOR THOSE SERVICES OR IDENTIFY
THAT THOSE SERVICES WERE THEM
PROVIDED BY THOSE UNLICENSED
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
TRAINED AND WERE CERTIFIED. UP
UNDER THEIR DIRECTION AND
SUPERVISION TONIGHT GET OF THE
LEVEL OF CLARITY THAN.
.
WHERE WOULD OUR TEAS FALL IN A
LICENSED OR UNLICENSED?
R. T. RESPIRATORY THERAPIST SO I
THEIR LICENSE PROVIDE.
BECAUSE ARE LICENSED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE A
LICENSE TO PRACTICE THEIR
SERVICES. SO IN OUR MEDI CAL
STATE PLAN.
WE LIST CALLED LICENSED
PROVIDERS AND VOTE AND THERE ARE
PROVIDERS THAT ARE REQUIRED OF
US.
TO BE IDENTIFIED IN OUR STATE
PLAN BY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I'M ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS HERE WAS
DEALING WITH DIED CHANGES AND.
FEDERAL REGULATIONS DEALING
WITH THIS SERVICES THAT COULD BE
PROVIDED BY UNLICENSED CARE
PROVIDERS OR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. AGAIN THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE BUT FOR PURPOSES OF THE
MEDIC HOW PROGRAM. IF THAT
PROVIDER TYPE WHEN OUT TO RENDER
THAT SERVICE.
WE COULD LOOK TO ESTABLISH
BILLING CODES THAT INDICATED
THAT THIS WAS A SERVICE PROVIDED
MEANING THE HOMOSASSA MAN. UNDER
THE DIRECTION AND SUPERVISION OF
A LICENSED PROVIDER THEY CAN
BILL FOR THAT AND THEN REIMBURSE
THOSE I'M LICENSED PROVIDERS BUT
WE DON'T HAVE A MECHANISM TODAY.
TOO ON AND ROLL AND PAY FOR
THOSE ON LICENSE CARE GIVERS
DIRECTLY DO WE HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
WAS A COST ESTIMATE FOR THE
SERVICES AS PER AB THREE NINETY
ONE I WAS.
PLEASE TO SUPPORT THAT BILL LAST
YEAR AND WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IF
WE HAVE A COST ESTIMATE FOR THE
SERVICES.
MISTER CHAIR WHETHER OBAMACARE
US WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE A COST
ESTIMATE ESTIMATE FOR THIS AT
THIS TIME.
WE CAN MOM PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE EXTENT
NECESSARY WE DON'T SHARE ARE
ENROLLED BILLS REPORTS BUT WE DO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I'M TO
DEVELOP ESTIMATES. WHEN BILLS
ARE HEARD AND.
FISCAL COMMITTEE.
I AM IF WE CAN GET THAT BY MAY
REVISION THAT WOULD HELP US TO
MAKE APPROPRIATE DECISIONS.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT FROM
THE DYESS WILL HOLD ISSUE
FOURTEEN OPEN THE BOND ISSUE
FIFTY
.
MS CHEN I THINK IT JUST THE ROOM
I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR MY
VOICE WILL COME BACK AND.
WELCOME BACK.
SORRY MISTER CHAIR.
CAN REALLY CHEN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK.
.
I'M THAT ON BEHALF OF SEA PEN
AND THE SOUTHEAST FUTURE
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
EXPAND. THIS AGGREGATED
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA COLLECTION FOR
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER I
THINK CITIES.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST ASIAN AMERICAN AND
SECOND LARGEST NEED APPLY IN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER POPULATIONS.
THESE ARE THESE POPULATIONS ARE
THE FASTEST GROWING GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WITH THE PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX BY MR
BONTA TWICE SIXTEEN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WILL NOW BEGIN COLLECTING AND.
DISAGGREGATED DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
FOR THE API SUBGROUP
POPULATIONS.
BUT AS PART OF THAT BILL.
WE AGREED TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ADMINISTRATIVELY TO
INCLUDE THIS.
WITHIN DH CS.
WITHOUT GRANULAR DISAGGREGATED
DATA AT MANY SUBGROUPS WITHIN
THE API POPULATION DISTINCT
HEALTH DISPARITIES REMAIN
UNADDRESSED AND SUBPOPULATIONS
BEAT REMAIN UNACCOUNTED FOR.
SO THE FIRST STEP IN BEING ABLE
TO IDENTIFY AND REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES IS THE ACCURATE
COLLECTION. AND REPORTING OF
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DATA OF THOSE
ENROLLING IN HEALTH COVERAGE.
THROUGH WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WE WERE I ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE EXACT AMOUNT ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION ORANGE
INCLUDES.
IN THE PROGRAM.
.
WE ARE PLEASED TO ALSO HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS.
IT IN THE SUPPORT IN THIS
PROPOSAL.
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
NOW POLITICIZING THE SENSES WITH
A CITIZENSHIP QUESTION. IT IS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A LEADING
ROLE IN ENSURING WE MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR DIVERSE POPULATION
AND NOT MEANS MAKING SURE
EVERYBODY COUNTS AND EVERYBODY
IS INCLUDED. WE URGE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO MAKE THIS A
CRITICAL INVESTMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FIFTY.
GOLIA WITH THE SOUTHEAST ASIA
RESOURCE ACTION CENTER WE WERE
ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX I AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. WERE
IN FULL SUPPORT AT THIS AND I
REQUEST.
CAN.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
PHENOMENON POVERTY IN SUPPORT WE
CAN.
MARY VALDEZ HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT BECAME.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
AMMO BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS
AND. JUST THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING THIS I'M THE ONLY
QUESTION I HAVE IS WHY ONE TIME
AS THIS. IS IT. YES HELP SET UP
THE SYSTEM MORE ABSOLUTELY IT'S
THE ONE TIME COST TO MAKE THE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES IN THE CAL
HERE'S AND MET SYSTEM SO THAT
THOSE INPUTS CAN BE COLLECTED
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ROLE. GREAT
FOOD REPRESENTING A I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING A
COMMUNITY WHERE WE HAVE A LARGE
MUNG POPULATION AS YOU ARE AWARE
AND. OFTENTIMES THEY GET LOST IN
THE API DISCUSSION AND REALLY
DO.
BELIEVE THAT DISAGGREGATED DATA
HELPS US WITHOUT SOME WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FIFTEEN OPEN
IN THE BOND ISSUE SIX
SO AGAIN FOR NAY MULLIN PROPER
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. SO I JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE I'M AND THIS
IS DEALING WITH OUR PROPOSAL
REGARDING THAT THREE FORTY BE
PROPER. THE AGENDA DOES
THOROUGHLY AND.
APPROPRIATELY COVER THAT THREE
FORTY BE PROPOSAL WHICH IS
BASICALLY FORCED TO ELIMINATE
THE USE OF THESE DRUGS.
IN TERMS OF SERVING MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. AND FOR PROVIDERS
FARM AND FOR PHARMACY PROVIDERS
TO THEM BILL US IN ACCORDANCE
WITH OUR CURRENT POLICIES ON
PHARMACY AND CLINIC
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR DISPENSED
DRUGS. PLUS THE APPLE COUPLE
DISPENSING FEE.
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA THERE ARE
VERY SIGNIFICANT ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS THAT ARE PLACED ON THE
DEPARTMENT IN TERMS OF HOW THE
PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERED. AND WE MUST HAVE
PROCESSES IN PLACE TO HELP
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE NO
DUPLICATE DISCOUNTS AND TO
COMPLY WITH OUR PROVE STATE
PLAN.
REGARDING THE USE OF AYE
DISPENSE THREE FORTY BE DRUGS.
WE DO RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THE
THREE FORTY BE AYE PROGRAM TO
COVERED ENTITIES AND TO THE
POPULATIONS THEY SERVE. HOWEVER
IT WASN'T UNTIL.
OUR FIRST PROPOSAL IN TERMS OF
DEALING WITH CONTRACTS
PHARMACIES AND NOW THIS ONE DID
WE WERE REALIZE THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE REVENUE THAT IS GENERATED.
BY THE COVERED ENTITIES WHICH IS
ACHIEVED BASED UPON WHAT IS
CLAIMED TO THE MEDICAL PROGRAM.
WE DIRT DO COULD CAR EMPIRE IN
TERMS OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM ALEJO THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE TRANSPARENCY. IN TERMS
OF THE REVENUES GENERATED BY THE
COVERED ENTITIES AND HOW SUCH
RESOURCES ARE USED. RELATIVE TO
THE PROVISION OF THE SERVICES
AND THE MATTER HOW PROGRAM.
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE PRESENT
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION TO OUR
PROPOSAL. AND WE REMAIN.
DILIGENT AND OUR DESIRE OF
WORKING COLLABORATIVE WITH THEM
REGARDING THE IMPACTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND THEN TO ALSO
CONSIDER ON POTENTIAL
APPROACHES.
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE US TO
CONSIDER AND ALSO IS DISCUSSING
THE AGENDA WE ARE WORKING ON A
SAVINGS ESTIMATE RELATIVE TO
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
CATCHER MEMBER SERGIO I GO WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SO
FIND AT THAT THE POOR PROPOSAL
TO ELIMINATE THE THREE FORTY P.
DRUG REIMBURSEMENT THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. HOW'D VOCAL ALLOW THE
STATE TO COMPLY WITH THE COULD
THINK BETTER REQUIREMENTS.
HELPS PROTECT PROGRAM INTEGRITY
AND REDUCE UNNECESSARY
OVERPAYMENTS ALLOW THE STATE TO
COLLECT ADDITIONAL DRUG REBATES
NOTHING MITIGATES ABOUT OF TIME
AND RESOURCES SPENT ON RESOLVING
DISPUTE THROUGH LATE AT THREE
FORTY BE DRUG CLAIMS.
WE ARE AS THEM WITH MULLIN
MENTIONED CURLY PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A FISCAL AT THE MET
FOR THE IMPACT OF THE STATE. AND
DO INTENTA RELIEF ANATHEMA UP
FROM A REVISION HOWEVER WE DO
KNOW SOME SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
TO DEVELOPING A FISCAL ETHNIC ON
THE IMPACT TO COVERED ENTITIES.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE LACK OF
DATA.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU SIR.
AMBER.
I THINK YOU MANY OF THEM ARE
OUGHT AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT OVER FOUR HUNDRED
HOSPITALS ACROSS THE STATE.
INCLUDING ONE HUNDRED HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE HOSPITALS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THE THREE FORTY
THE PROGRAM.
WHAT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT CONGRESS
ENACTED THE THREE FORTY THE
PROGRAM BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO?
AND THE STATED COMPRESSIONAL
INTENT OF THE PROGRAM AND I
QUOTE IS TO STRETCH SCARCE%
FEDERAL RESOURCES AS FAR AS
POSSIBLE REACHING MORE ELIGIBLE
PATIENTS AND PROVIDING MORE
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE
THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM HOSPITAL
MUST BE EITHER A NOT FOR PROFIT
ENTITY OR A PUBLICLY OWNED
ENTITY. AND MUST SERVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID PATIENTS.
SOME OF THE SERVICES THAT ARE
FUNDED WITH SAVINGS FROM THE
THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM. INCLUDE
OUTPATIENT CHEMOTHERAPY CENTERS
MOBILE AND PRIMARY CARE CLINICS
DIABETES SCREENING HEPATITIS C.
TREATMENT AND HIV CLINICS.
THESE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES ARE
REACHING DIRECTLY INTO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND FOR SOME OF THE SMALL AND
RURAL HOSPITALS ACROSS OUR
STATE.
THE SAVINGS REALLY DO MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN KEEPING THEIR
DOORS OPEN AND HAVING THE CLOSE.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE THREE FORTY BE
PROGRAM FOR MEDI CAL BUT NOT
ONLY REDUCE ACCESS TO VITAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. IT WOULD
ALSO SEVER A LIFELINE THAT
PROVIDES FREE DRUGS TO
VULNERABLE PATIENTS.
IF HOSPITALS ARE NO LONGER ABLE
TO PURCHASE DRUGS THROUGH THE
THREE FORTY PROGRAM. THEY WILL
BE FORCED TO PURCHASE THEM AT
THE WHOLESALE ACQUISITION COST.
WHICH CAN BE MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE THREE FORTY BE PRICE.
AND THIS IS PER A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT THAT SAYS THREE
FORTY BE COVERED ENTITIES CANNOT
PURCHASE DRUGS THROUGH GROUP
PURCHASING ARRANGEMENTS
SO THEY REALLY WOULD BE PAYING
THE HIGHEST PRICE ON THESE DRUGS
IN THE MARKET.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THE PROPOSAL
WOULD COST HOSPITAL'S HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND THAT THE STATE WOULD THEN BE
ABLE TO CLAIM THE REBATES ON
THESE DRUGS THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT THAT WILL OCCUR.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY AS THE LA.
REPORTED THE STATE ONLY GETS TO
KEEP ABOUT A THIRD OF THOSE
REBATES.
MEANING THAT TWO THIRDS OF THE
DOLLARS WOULD BE SENT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND INSTEAD OF KEEPING THESE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN SAVINGS WITHIN OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
WE SEND THEM TO WASHINGTON DC.
WHICH IS INCREDIBLY CONCERNING
FROM A POLICY PERSPECTIVE.
NATURALLY THAT IF THERE ARE LESS
DOLLARS IN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THERE IS GOING TO BE AN IMPACT
ON ACT.
AND THOSE THREE FORTY THE
HOSPITALS THAT TREAT THE LARGEST
PORTION OF MEDICAL PATIENTS.
WILL BE DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARMED BY THIS PROPOSAL AND THEY
WILL BE FORCED TO REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE SERVICES. AND THERE
WILL NOT BE ACCESS TO THESE FREE
DRUGS FOR THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
BUT THERE OUR SOLUTIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
RELEASED A REPORT.
THAT STUDIED HOW THIRTY SEVEN
DIFFERENT STATES HAVE FOUND WAYS
TO IDENTIFY THREE FORTY BE
CLAIMS IN MEDICAID MANAGED CARE
CLINICS.
AND ONE EXAMPLE.
WAS THAT HOSPITALS HEALTH PLANS
CLINICS VENDORS COULD SUBMIT A
FILE TO THE STATE THAT GIVES
THEM ALL OF THE DATA THEY NEED
TO IDENTIFY THE THREE FORTY BE
CLAIMS AND EXCLUDE THEM FROM
THEIR REBATE REQUEST.
AND IN FACT
CALIFORNIA APPROVED A MODEL THAT
DOES JUST THAT IF WITH
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN BACK IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND THAT MODEL HAS BEEN IN PLACE
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS AND IT
DOES REQUIRE THAT THE STATE
RECEIVE A FILE. WITH THE
NECESSARY ELEMENTS SO THAT THEY
CAN IDENTIFY AND EXCLUDE THREE
FORTY BE DRUGS FROM THEIR REBATE
REQUESTS.
WHICH REALLY BRINGS INTO
QUESTION WHY CAN'T NOT TYPE OF A
MODEL BE EXPANDED ACROSS THE
STATE. SO WE CAN PRESERVE THE
PROGRAM AND ENSURE FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE.
AND FINALLY I'D LIKE TO MENTION
THAT LAST MONTH THE STATE DID
RELEASE A DRAFT ALL PLANNED
LETTER FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND ONCE STATED PURPOSE ABOUT
APL WAS TO CLARIFY THE PLANS
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
REPORTING DRUGS PURCHASED
THROUGH THE THREE FORTY PROGRAM.
THE A CAL CLEARLY OUTLINES THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PLAN
IDENTIFY THREE FORTY BE DRUGS AT
THE CLAIM LEVEL USING NATIONALLY
STANDARD INDICATORS.
AND IT ALSO REQUIRES THE PLANS
HAVE FORMAL POLICIES IN PLACE TO
PREVENT DUPLICATE DISCOUNTS WITH
CONTRACT PHARMACIES.
IN OUR OPINION THAT IT FELT
PROVIDE SOME VIABLE SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS THE DEPARTMENT'S
CONCERNS AND WE REALLY DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. TO SEE HOW WE CAN
MAKE THESE SOLUTIONS A REALITY.
HOSPITALS ARE COMMITTED TO BEING
GOOD STEWARDS OF THE THREE FORTY
BE PROGRAM AND WE SUPPORT
REPORTING MODIFICATIONS THAT
WOULD STRENGTHEN PROGRAM
INTEGRITY AND.
BUT THE PROPOSED ONE FRONT ABOUT
THAT FAR TOO EXTREME.
AND IT WOULD HAVE A DETRIMENTAL
EFFECT ON ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BY SAYING
THAT NO OTHER STATE IN THE
COUNTRY HASN'T ACTED SUCH A
HARMFUL POLICY. AND I ASK THAT
THIS COMMITTEE PLEASE REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FOR.
WE GIVE THEM.
COOPER.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
HEALTH CENTER PERSPECTIVE ON
THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM AND THE
IMPORTANT ROLE IT PLAYS IN
SUPPORTING ACCESS TO CARE.
MY NAME IS PRETTY GUERRERO I'M
THE CEO OF THE SACRAMENTO NATIVE
AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER A
NONPROFIT FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTER. PROVIDING CARE TO
OVER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND PATIENTS IN AND AROUND
SACRAMENTO.
I'M A PROUD THEM A PROUD BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY
CARE ASSOCIATION. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HEALTH NETWORK AND THE
CONCERTS THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM FOR URBAN INDIAN
HEALTH.
TODAY I'D LIKE TO START BY
SHARING MY HEALTH CENTERS THREE
FORTY BE STORY. AND THEN PROVIDE
SOME STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE THREE
FORTY BE PROGRAM. FOR THE OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER SITES THAT SERVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE HIGH
QUALITY CARE TO SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE THAT'S ONE IN SIX
CALIFORNIANS.
OUR HEALTH CENTER HAS BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THE THREE FORTY
P. PROGRAM SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE.
THE BEST SERVER PATIENTS WE
HAVEN'T INTO IN HOUSE PHARMACY
AND SEVENTEEN CONTRACT
PHARMACIES.
THIS MODEL ALLOWS OUR PATIENTS
TIMELY ACCESS TO
PHARMACEUTICALS.
INCLUDING SPECIALTY DRUGS
PATIENTS CAN PICK UP THEIR
MEDICATIONS RIGHT AFTER THEY SEE
THEIR PROVIDER OR SUBMIT A
REFILL TO A PHARMACY CLOSER TO
THEIR HOME.
SNACK WHICH IS THE ACRONYM FOR
HEALTH CENTER DEPENDS ON THREE
FORTY BE SAVINGS TO EMPLOYMENT
BIRDS OF OUR CARE TEAMS SUCH AS
CARE TEAM NURSES CASE MANAGERS
REFERRAL COORDINATORS AND OTHER
POSITIONS THAT ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR REIMBURSEMENT.
THESE CARE COORDINATION SERVICES
ARE CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE THE
COMPLEX NEEDS OF OUR PATIENT
POPULATION ARE BEING MET BY
CONNECTING PATIENTS WITH
COVERAGE ENROLLMENT
TRANSPORTATION TRANSLATION
SERVICES.
IN IN NETWORKING OUT A NETWORK
SPECIALISTS AND OTHER SUPPORT OF
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
THEREFORE UNABLE TO CONTINUE
PARTICIPATION IN THE THREE FORTY
BE PROGRAM UNDER FEE FOR
SERVICE.
AND MANAGE CARE MEDI CAL WE MAY
ALSO NEED TO CLOSE OUR IN HOUSE
PHARMACY.
THIS WOULD DISRUPT
PHARMACEUTICAL ACCESS FOR ALL OF
OUR PATIENTS AND FOR MANY
RAISING COSTS WE PROVIDE LOW IN
FREE MEDICATION THE UNINSURED.
AS RESPONSIBLE PARTICIPANTS IN
THE THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM WE'VE
CONTRACTED A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. WHO HELPED TO
TRACK OR THREE FORTY BE DRUGS
AND HELPS TO ELIMINATE DUPLICATE
DISCOUNTS UNDER THE THREE FORTY
PROGRAM?
WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE STATE
PHARMACIES PLANS AND OTHER
COVERED ENTITIES.
ON WAYS TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE DRUG DISCOUNT
INFORMATION IS BEING REPORTED AN
AUDIT.
FEW THINGS I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
US FIRST THE STATE WHY PROPOSAL
AND PURSED HER STATEWIDE
PERSPECTIVE ON THREE FORTY BE.
IF ENACTED THIS PROPOSAL WILL
HAVE DIRECT AND IMMEDIATE IMPACT
ON HEALTH CENTERS IN THE
ULTIMATELY HARM ACCESS FOR LOW
INCOME AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
WE LIKE OUR THREE FORTYB.
ENTITY COVERED POT COLLEAGUES.
ON THIS PANEL ARE CONCERNED WITH
A HASTY PROPOSAL.
THE ADMINISTRATION ARGUES
THEY'RE PROPOSING NEW
LEGISLATION TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A MINT AT
MISINTERPRETATION OF THE OF THE
CURRENT LAW.
FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE
ELIMINATION OF THE PROGRAMMING
MEDICAID.
BUT RATHER CLAIMS THAT STATES%
HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO
IDENTIFY TRACK OUGHT IN AUDIT
THREE FORTY BE CLAIMS.
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER STAND READY TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE A
SYSTEM THAT INSURANCE PROGRAM
INTEGRITY. WERE ALL THREE FORTY
BURKE BE DRUGS ARE APPROPRIATELY
CODED CLAIMED AND THEREBY CREATE
ASSURANCE THAT THE STATE WILL
HAVE NO DUPLICATE DISCOUNTS.
BUILDING THE SYSTEM TOGETHER
WILL HELP TO HELP THE STATE
RECEIVE MORE REBATES LOWER COSTS
AND OUR COMMUNITY SOME PATIENTS
WILL CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE
BENEFITS. PRINT COVERED ENTITIES
PARTICIPATING AT THREE FORTY P..
THERE ARE MODELS IN OUR STATE
AND OTHER STATES WERE THREE
FORTY BE CLAIMS ARE IDENTIFIED
TRACKED AND AUDITED AND WE ARE
CONFIDENT WE CAN BILL FROM THOSE
SYSTEMS ALREADY IN PLACE.
IN CLOSING THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR CREATING A SPACE
FOR THIS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
WITH OF FEDERAL POLICY
ENVIRONMENT THAT CONTINUES TO
THREATEN AND DESTABILIZE
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
ENVIRONMENT. CALIFORNIA.
NEEDS TO BE INVESTING AND
SUPPORTING BOTH COVERAGE AND
ACCESS AND NOT TAKING AWAY ONE
TO SUPPORT ANOTHER.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU AM THAT
WE'VE EXPECT WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE THREE FORTY BE
PROGRAM. AND AS YOU CONTINUE
YOUR DELIBERATIONS.
THE HEALTH CENTER COMMUNITY
LOOKS FORWARD TO BEING A
RESOURCE TO YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM.
FULLY OF.
I'VE BEEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA
SHOW UP THIS WINTER WE CONDUCT
ANALYSIS OF THE GOVERNOR'S THREE
FORTY BE.
PROPOSAL AND.
ULTIMATELY CAME TO RECOGNIZE A
LOT OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
CHALLENGES ARE CAUSED BY THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE PROGRAM
AND THE MEDICAID DRUG REBATE
PROGRAM CHALLENGES THAT HAVE
GROWN I THINK IN RECENT YEARS.
AND WE WE CAME WE ALSO AGREED
THAT THAT THE PROPOSED
ELIMINATION THE PROGRAM WOULD
LIKELY RESULT IN IN SAVINGS
WHICH WE LOOK FORWARD TO AN
ESTIMATE.
AT THE MAY REVISION THESE RICH
THESE HIGHER SAVINGS WE
RECOGNIZE WOULD.
BE IN PLACE OF A OF A PORTION
OF THE SAVINGS THAT THREE FORTY
BE COVERED ENTITIES DO GET TO
RETAIN THROUGH THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM.
AND ALL WE FOUND THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOES MEET
MERIT SERIOUS CONSIDERATION DUE
TO THE SAVINGS THAT WOULD BE.
GENERATED.
THE REDUCTION IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHALLENGES AND
THE.
CUT COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
LAWS AND RULES ABOUT PREVENTING
DUPLICATE DISCOUNTS.
WHICH WHICH WOULD BE ACHIEVED
UNDER THE PROPOSAL.
SINCE THE SAVINGS WOULD
ULTIMATELY BENEFIT THE GENERAL
FUND WE WE BELIEVE THESE EX
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM
PRESCRIPTION DRUG DISCOUNTS
WOULD DIE GIVE ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE FLEXIBILITY OF HOW
TO TARGET THESE RESOURCES.
AND TO PURSUE ITS PRIORITIES
AND BELIEVE THAT WOULD ALLOW A
WOULD MAXIMIZE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF HOW THESE DISCOUNT
SAVINGS.
ARE ULTIMATELY TARGETED IN USED
SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DO WITH THE
SAVINGS INCLUDE AUGMENTING OF
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM IN NEW WAYS
YEAH OR A COULD BE TO
DEDICATING.
RESOURCES TO THE COVERED
ENTITIES THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED
BY THAT THAT THE CHANGES THAT
WOULD OCCUR UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
TO ENSURE THAT ACCESS DOESN'T
BECOME. A PROBLEM FOR.
CERTAIN THE HOSPITALS OR
ENTITIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BENEFITING UNDER THE PROGRAM. WE
DO RECOMMEND THAT BEFORE
REACHING A DECISION.
THE LEGISLATURE REQUEST FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT'S THE
SAVINGS ESTIMATE AND ALSO THAT
IT TO GET DOES GATHERADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON HOW THE PROPOSED
CHANGES WOULD DIE. WOULD IMPACT
COVERED ENTITIES AND THEN
FINALLY OUR REPORT DOES PROVIDE
A BRIEF ANALYSIS OF CERTAIN
ALTERNATIVES TO THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL WHICH WE CAN GET INTO
IF IF THE LEGISLATURE IF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUES SIXTEEN.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS
TERRY CALGARY HILL ON BEHALF OF
THE HUMOROUSLY COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
PATIENTS WHO HAVE RARE BLEEDING
DISORDERS SUCH AS HEMOPHILIA VON
WILLEBRAND DISEASE.
WE SUPPORT STRONGLY SUPPORT OUR
HEMOPHILIA TREATMENT CENTERS
THOSE ARE GENERALLY CLINICS THAT
ARE LOCATED WITHIN CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS UNIVERSITY MEDICAL
CENTERS THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
STAND ALONE. BUT THEY BASICALLY
PROVIDE THE CARE FOR OUR
PATIENTS WHO NEED TO SEE THEIR
HEMATOLOGIST AT LEAST ONCE A
YEAR FOR THE COMPREHENSIVE CARE
PLAN.
THE HTC'S ARE OPERATING UNDER
VERY STRICT FEDERAL LAWS SO THEY
HAVE TO REPORT TO HER CELL WEPT
WHEN THEY RECEIVE GRANTS AND SO
THEY HAVE TO REPORT ALL OF THEIR
INCOME AND. FACTOR FOR OUR
HEMOPHILIA PATIENTS IS CARVED
OUT OF MEDI CAL FEE FOR SERVICE
AND IS PAYER EXCUSE ME OUT ABOUT
IT HOW MANAGED CARE AND IS PAID
DIRECTLY THROUGH FEE FOR SERVICE
ON A SEPARATE. WILL TALK ABOUT
THE FACT IRATE LATER BUT
BASICALLY ALL OF THE ON ABILITY
FOR THE HUMANLY TREATMENT
CENTERS TO PURCHASE THAT IT
DISCOUNT ALL OF THE PROFITS ARE
REINVESTED INTO THOSE HEMOPHILIA
THINGS SUCH AS. THE ULTRASOUND
MACHINES THAT LOOK INTO THE
JOINTS OF THE HEMOPHILIA
PATIENTS THAT LEAD INTO THEIR
JOINTS THE OLD DAYS WE JUST HAVE
THE HEMATOLOGIST PRESCRIBE MORE
CLOTTING FACTOR. IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE AND SO NOW THE DOCTORS
AND THE STAFF AT THE TREATMENT
CENTERS CAN LOOK INTO THE JOINTS
AND SEE HEY MAYBE WE CAN JUST ON
ORDER SOME PHYSICAL THERAPY OR
NOT AS MUCH FACTOR. TO PREVENT A
FURTHER PLEASE AND JOINT DAMAGE
SO THE MONEY THAT COMES TO BACK
INTO THE CENTERS IS USED VERY
WISELY AND RESPONSIBLY THEY HAVE
TO RESPOND TO THE FEDS AND SO.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT I'M POSITIVE
SOLUTIONS THANK YOU.
I CAN.
BRENT SPENCE ARE BEHALF THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT CONCERNS THE
PROPOSAL AS WELL. UP GRANDPARENT
HEALTH CENTERS OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HEALTH CENTERS ROCK
CALIFORNIA SERVE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PATIENTS ANNUALLY
PASSED EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT OF
THOSE PATIENTS ARE. FROM ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL LAST YEAR
THE LAST YEAR FEDERAL THREATS
ASIDE YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
FINANCIAL BAND BALANCING ACT WE
FACE WITH. PROVIDING QUALITY
SERVICE FOR PATIENTS WHILE
MANAGING OVERHEAD COSTS AS A
SAFETY NET PROVIDER. TODAY
PLANNED PARENTHOOD HEALTH
CENTERS OPERATE IN THE CONTEXT
OF A FEDERAL MINISTRATION
SEEKING THE CITY S. WASTE
OVERCOME. COME AFTER OUR
PATIENTS AND THE BASIC HEALTH
CARE WE PROVIDE.
OUR DOORS OPEN ALL CALIFORNIANS
FOR A WIDE RANGE OF HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE THREE FORTY BE
PROGRAM IS A VITAL PART OF THE
CONTRACEPTION VACCINATION STI
TREATMENT SERVICES WE OFFER.
OVER YEARS AFFILIATES HAVE
PARTNERED WITH DEPARTMENT ON
PROPER BILL WHEN YOU SING. IN UT
MODIFIERS
WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO USE THAT
THIRTY THREE FORTY BE.
S. HAVE. USED THEIR THREE FORTY
BE SERVE OUR PICK MEDICAL
PATIENTS SO WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OUR PATIENTS WILL
EXPERIENCE AND THIS TYPE OF
PROPOSAL. THEREFORE WE URGE
CAUTION AS YOU PROCEED
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
PROPOSAL. I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
ALIGN MYSELF WITH ALL THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
WITH A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. AND JUST ADD THAT
WE ARE.
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO HELPING
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
WITH HEALTH PLANS TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN I HANDLE AND SO RESOLVE
ISSUES AROUND DUPLICATE
DISCOUNTS. BUT PHILIP THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSALS A VERY
INEFFICIENT WAY TO DO THAT IT
WOULD EFFECTIVELY TAKE TWO
THIRDS OF THE BENEFIT OF THE
PROGRAM ON THE MEDICAL SIDE OUT
OF THE STATE AND SEND THEM
ELSEWHERE SO IF THIS IS ABOUT
MORE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. IT'S
NOT AN EFFICIENT WAY TO DO THAT
IF IT'S ABOUT A BETTER OVERSIGHT
OR TRANSPARENCY IT'S NOT AN
EFFICIENT WAY TO DO THAT.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT THING JUST I'D
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE IS THAT THREE
FORTY PROGRAM IS REALLY IT'S NOT
A COST TO THE DEPARTMENT IT'S
NOT ACOSTA THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
AND IT'S NOT ACOSTA TAXPAYERS.
THE WAY THAT THE PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED IS BAD ALL PAYERS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE WE CONTINUE
TO REIMBURSE. HOSPITALS FOR THE
COSTS OF THE DRUGS THAT THEY
PROVIDE OUT THE WAY THAT THEY
HAD AT THE COST THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN REIMBURSING.
THE SAME TYPE DRUG COMPANIES
HAVE TO SELL THOSE DRUGS AT A
LOWER PRICE AND WHAT THAT DOES
IS CREATE A GAP.
WHERE THE HOSPITAL HAS EXTRA
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO PROVIDE?
BUT PROGRAM NOT TAXPAYERS THIS
IS A VERY YOU KNOW EFFICIENT
SYSTEM ARE ESPECIALLY AT HEMERY
ABOUT DRUG PRICES AND FEEL THE
DRUG COMPANIES MAY BE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF PATIENTS THIS IS
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF PROPOSAL WE
SHOULD BE. A TRYING TO EXPAND
NOT SHRINK AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE YOU TO REJECT IT
AND WE DO COMMIT THAT WE WILL
WORK OUT TO FIND HIM A BETTER
SOLUTION THAT'S MORE WORKABLE.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M FAIR MAKE THEY TING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES MY REMARKS ARE
ALSO I'M IN MIND WITH THE URBAN
COUNTIES. OF CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATION AS WELL WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE THE THREE
FORTY BE PROGRAM I THINK THAT'S
REASONS STATED PREVIOUSLY SAY AT
ALL THERE'S SOME VERY GOOD
ARGUMENTS. COUNTIES ARE
COMMITTED TO SETTING UP THE
TABLE WORKING WITH PLANS
PROVIDERS AND THE EIGHT CS TO
COME UP WITH A TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE WAY TO CONTINUE THE
THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS IN CHAIR AND MY NAME IS
ANGELA GILYARD MY REPRESENT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA HEALTH
SYSTEM.
WE'VE EIGHTEEN HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS AND FIVE
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS THESE
THE MEDICAL CENTERS PROVIDE
ACCESS TO SPECIALIZED INPATIENT
AND OUTPATIENT CARE FOR MEDI
CAL.
AND UNINSURED PATIENTS SUCH AS
COSTLY CHEMOTHERAPY
IMMUNOTHERAPY AT INFUSION
CENTERS.
SPECIALIZED SURGICAL PROCEDURES
AND TREATMENT FOR CHILDREN WITH
LIFE THREATENING CONDITIONS LIKE
CANCER GENETIC DISEASES HEART
JUST DEFECTS IN EPILEPSY. YOU
SEE MEDICAL CENTERS ARE RENOWNED
FOR OUR OFFERING HIGH QUALITY
TERTIARY. AND QUATERNARY
SPECIALTY SERVICES SUCH AS HEART
KIDNEY LIVER AND LUNG AND
PANCREAS. ARE TRANSPLANT
SERVICES ADVANCED STAGE CANCER
TREATMENTS NEUROSURGERY IN
CARDIO THORACIC SURGERY THE SIR
THE SERVICES WOULD NOT BE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE WITHOUT THE
SUPPORTING SAVINGS FROM THE
THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL INSTEAD ENCOURAGE A D.
H. CS TO WORK WITH SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS PATIENTS. AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ESTABLISH BETTER
MECHANISMS TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
WITHIN THE THREE FORTY BE
PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MEGAN LOW BROW BEHALF OF
THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
DISTRICT MUNICIPAL HOSPITALS WE
TWO WOULD URGE. THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL WE WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS AND THAT MANY OF OUR
HOSPITAL AND.
PARTNERS AT OUR HOSPITALS ARE
VERY DIVERSE AND SOME ARE RULING
CRITICAL ACCESS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED OTHERS ARE I AM URBAN
AND SUBURBAN BUT. HAVE ON BEHALF
OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM WE'VE AFFORD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON AN ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL. HAVE
BUT WE DO URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO REJECT THIS ONE BECAME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY NAME IS STEPHANIE DANCE
GROWN I'VE A THIRTY ONE YEAR OLD
SON WAS SEVERE HEMOPHILIA SO I'M
HERE TO GIVE A NAME A FACE AND
VOICE TO THE ISSUE AT HAND.
HEMOPHILIA TREATMENT CENTERS
VIRTUALLY SAVED MY SON'S LIFE.
BECAUSE WHEN HE WAS DIAGNOSED
AT THAT TIME HE WAS PART OF A
CLINICAL TRIAL HE WAS SPARED
FROM HIV AS WELL AS HEPATITIS C.
WHICH AT THAT TIME WAS CALLED
HEPATITIS NON A. NON B.. WHO
SPARED FROM MANY INTER CRANIAL?
HEMORRHAGES THAT COULD HAVE LED
TO.
BRAIN DAMAGE OR EVEN WORSE
DEATH.
HEMOPHILIA TREATMENT CENTERS
SAVED HIS JOINTS HE'S ON.
HE WAS ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL HIS
NOW AND A PRODUCTIVE.
A EMPLOYED CITIZEN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE
SOCIAL WORKERS. WHO ALSO PROVIDE
EXPERT EXPERTISE?
THE INFO YOU TREATMENT CENTER
HELP OUR ENTIRE FAMILY SO THAT
ALL OF US ARE EMPLOYED.
TAX PAYING CITIZENS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I URGED THE STATE
TO FIND ANOTHER WAY. TO TO.
LOOK AT THE ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM BUT DO NOT AFFECT THE
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE THAT RELY
ON THIS KIND OF INCOME THANK
YOU.
I CAN.
GOOD EVENING LARRY ARE THERE
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WITH US RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND OUR
COMMENTS ALLYING WITH MANY OF
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
STATED THANK YOU MEDINA.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS CHIANA
CITY ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OR STRICT
THREE FORTY PM MEDICAL THINK IF.
WE CAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MEGAN SUPERSONIC HAVE OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN THE COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
AND CLINICS RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. I'M I
FIRST WANT TO START BY SAYING I
THINK YOU KNOW YOU'VE HEARD FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THIS EVENING
THAT. THIS PROPOSAL WILL JUST
MAKE IT LESS BURDENSOME PERHAPS
FOR THE STATE TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM AND ALSO THAT THE STATE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF SOME OF THE DOLLARS.
AND PERHAPS THEY WOULD I JUST
GO INTO THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND
THERE'S NO OF REQUIREMENT RIEBEN
RECOMMENDATION THAT THESE
DOLLARS GO BACK IN THE MEDI CAL.
WHICH I THINK IS A A BIG CONCERN
FOR THOSE OF US WHO ARE LOOKING
AT THE FACT THAT THESE DOLLARS
ARE CURRENTLY. BEING USED BY
COVERED ENTITIES TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT THEY OTHERWISE
CANNOT AFFORD AND SO IF WE ARE
TAKING THAT OFF THE TABLE AND
SAYING WE ARE WE NEED TO TAKE
THESE DOLLARS TO GIVE TO THE
STATE. BUT THE STATE MAY NOT
GIVE THEM BACK TO YOU TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES ON THE
BACK AND THAT'S A BIG CONCERN SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE. JUST FOR
THE RECORD AVAIL OURSELVES
AVAILABLE FOR EVERYONE WE WE
HOPE TO I'M. HOPE THE STATE
DETERMINE A LESS BURDENSOME WAY
TO TRACK THESE REBATES RATHER
THAN ON THE MAIN THE PROGRAM
THANK YOU BECAME.
GOOD EVENING I'M SIR HAS GET
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS ALSO RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE. GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WE A TWO WOULDN'T WHAT
ECHO MIKE I WOULD SYMPATHIZE AN
ECHO ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES.
I'M COMMENTS HERE TODAY AND WE
JUST HIGHLIGHT TWO QUICK THINGS
ONE IS.
THIS THE MORE MEDI CAL PATIENTS
THAT WE SEE THE GREATER THE
IMPACT OF THIS PROPOSAL IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
SAFETY NET PROVIDERS. AND REALLY
CAN IMPACT THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE TODAY.
SECOND WE TO STAND READY TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE STATE AND
COMING UP WITH SOME ALTERNATIVES
THAT CAN BOTH PRESERVE THE
PROGRAM'S INTEGRITY. AND ALLOW
US TO COME INTO FEDERAL
COMPLAINTS THINKING BECAME.
KELLY BRICKS ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
RIVERSIDE SANTA CLARA AND
VENTURA COUNTIES ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND BEHALF
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. ALL IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION.
ONE THING ALL MY CLIENTS HAVE
IN COMMON IS THAT THEY'RE PUBLIC
ENTITIES OPERATING ON VERY THIN
MARGINS THIS PROPOSAL WILL BE
VERY DEVASTATING TO SOME OF
THEM.
FOR HOPEFUL THAT THERE THERE'S
AN ALTERNATIVE THAT COULD BE.
PURSUED AND THAT THE
CONVERSATION MAY TAKE A
DIFFERENT TURN AND I THINK YOU
THE COMMAND.
THOUGHT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION ON
HFS THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF CARE
AND TREATMENT OF PEOPLE WITH HIV
IN THE WORLD. EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PATIENTS
WORLDWIDE IN FORTY COUNTRIES BUT
A VERY LARGE PRESENCE HERE IN
OUR HOME STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE THREE FORTY BE PROVIDER OF
THOSE FUNDS ARE IMPORTANT FOR A
COUPLE REASONS ONE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO CANNOT PAY
WHO ARE NOT COVERED BY MEDICAL
ON WHO WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO
SECOND IS WE PROVIDE A WIDE
RANGE OF SERVICES THAT GO BEYOND
WHAT IS ALLOWED UNDER CURRENT
LAW.
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT RANGE OF SERVICES
KEEPS PEOPLE ON THEIR TREATMENT
REGIMEN. I'M WE HAVE A VIRAL
LOAD UNDETECTABLE RATE AT AGE
HALF OF EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. AND
THAT'S REMARKABLE GIVEN WHERE IT
IS THEN THE REST OF THE STATE.
ON TOP OF WHICH THAT HAS A HUGE
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT BECAUSE IF
YOUR VIRAL LOAD UNDETECTABLE YOU
ARE NOT TRANSMITTING THE VIRUS.
ON VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THESE
FUNDS CONTINUE TO.
TO SUPPORT THOSE SERVICES WE DO
SUPPORT A NEGOTIATION ON ON
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT CONVERSATION BUT WOULD HAVE
TO REJECT THE.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THINK
IT'S HER.
I A MATCHING TRULY FROM THE
CENTER FOR INHERITED BLOOD
DISORDERS AND HEMOPHILIA
TREATMENT CENTERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. ARE CENTER WAS A
THREE FORTY BE LEAD IN PRACTICE
SAY. AND WE WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
STATE TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM
INTEGRITY WE'VE ALWAYS ACTED IN
BUT THAT THAT'S INTEGRITY OF THE
PROGRAM. WE USE OUR FUNDS TO
FIND IT
DREAMILY GOOD OUTPATIENT
SERVICES WE HAVE TO ELIMINATE
THESE PROGRAMS AND OUR PATIENTS
WOULD END UP BACK IN THE
HOSPITAL. SO PLEASE.
SAY THE PURPOSE.
THANK YOU SIR.
AFTERNOON CRAIG PULLS FROM
BEHALF OF A KILLER HEALTH IN THE
CALIFORNIA HIV ALLIANCE FOR A
COALITION OF EIGHTEEN HIV
SERVICE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE.
HERE IN STRONG OPPOSITION AS
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER ONE
IN THE NATION FOR HIV. AND STDS
THESE FUNDS ARE CUR THESE.
SAVINGS ARE CURRENTLY IS TO
EXPAND HIV AND STD SERVICE HAS
INCLUDING CASE MANAGEMENT PROP
NAVIGATION AND AS TO THE
TREATMENT AND PREVENTION AND
MANY OTHER SERVICES. AND THERE'S
CERTAINLY NO GUARANTEE THAT
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE REINVESTED
SO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE PROPOSED ON THESE
EPIDEMICS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR.
HI DEVON ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CEMETERY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO THE ELIMINATION OF THE
PROGRAM WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS AND ALSO AT THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY. HEALTH SYSTEM.
ANTICIPATES A TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO PERCENT INCREASE IN
MEDICAL PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS
HOME IF THIS WERE TO GO THROUGH
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE COMMAND.
MICHAEL MORTAL MEN ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THREE FORTY BE
PROPOSAL AND URGING YOU TO
REJECT IT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI MY NAME'S RAN REGAL I'M A
SEVERE FACTORY CAN FEEL THAT
COUP IS ACTUALLY PATIENT AT THE
INFILL TREATMENT CENTER THAT
STEPHANIE DANCER WORKS AT.
I'M IN OPPOSITION TO THE CUTS
TO THIS PROGRAM AND PROGRAMS
THAT WOULD TAKE WITH FUNDS FROM
THE EXXON SERVICES I GET AT THAT
HEMOPHILIA TREATMENT CENTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE SIXTEEN I'LL BRING IT
UP TO THE DYESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REVIEW. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU.
COMING UP AND TESTIFYING.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
I HEARD SEVERAL THINGS AND I
WILL TRY TO. OF.
ASK SPECIFICALLY UP THERE WERE
IS A COMIC ABOUT COST SAVINGS
FOR THE STATE.
AND I DON'T I'M NOT QUITE SURE.
IF.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE COST
SAVINGS WOULD I BE BE REALIZED
IF YOU CAN EXPLAIN THAT TO. US
ABSOLUTELY SO.
A DRUG CAN EITHER RECEIVE A
DISCOUNT.
YOU CAN EITHER PLAY DISCOUNT
THAT ESSENTIALLY THAT DRUG
MANUFACTURERS PAYING FOR.
EITHER TO A COVERED ENTITY
THROUGH THE THREE FORTY BE
PROGRAM OR THROUGH A MEDICAID
DRUG REBATE SO THESE ARE TWO
SEPARATE PROGRAMS AND.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS AND ISSUES
IS THAT WE'RE HAVING A CHALLENGE
OF.
AT SOMETIMES ACCIDENTALLY OR
ARE UNINTENTIONALLY.
GET IT GET IT TRYING TO GET
DISCOUNTS ON BOTH AND SO.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS THAT WE
WOULD GET THE MEDICAID DRUG
REBATE?
AND THAT COVERED ENTITIES WOULD
HAVE TO FOREGO THE THREE FORTY
BE DISCOUNT.
YES BUT THAT HOW DOES THAT GIVE
US GIVE THE STATE SAVINGS.
.
BECAUSE.
MY UNDERSTAND OUR UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THESE WORK IS BAIT THAT
DISCOUNTS ARE ACTUALLY PRETTY
COMPARABLE AND HOW THEY'RE
CONSTRUCTED IT SAGA IT'S A
PERCENTAGE DISCOUNT OR.
THE REQUIREMENT FOR DRUG
MANUFACTURERS TO PROVIDE THE
BEST PRICE.
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO ANY SORT OF
MOST PRIVATE PAYERS AND A LOT A
LOT OF PUBLIC PAYERS TO. THAT
THE ESSENTIALLY THE STATUTE OF
THE STATUTORY DISCOUNT IS THE
SAME FOR BOTH THE THREE FORTY BE
ENTITY AND FOR THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM IT'S JUST THAT YOU CAN
ONLY HAVE ONE OF THE PRO ONE GET
IT AND THE OTHER CANNOT FINISH
AND I WOULD. LIKE I COULD JUST.
NO I UNDERSTAND THAT PART I
THINK WHAT I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING
IS HOW WOULD THAT DIRECTLY
BENEFIT THE STATE ARE HOW WHAT.
WHO WHO WOULD GET THE DISK WHO
WOULD GET THE COST SAVINGS WILL
HELP WITH THAT IT WOULD BE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
MEDICARE MEDICAID LIKE I OWE YOU
AN APOLOGY?
SO THE THE.
FOR ALL MEDICAID REBATES FOR
MEDI CAL.
WE COLLECT THE DHS COLLECTS
THOSE REBATES AND THEY OFFSET
GENERAL FUND SPENDING IN THE
PROGRAM AND SO IT ESSENTIALLY
WOULD REDUCE THE GENERAL FUND
OBLIGATION TO SORT OF FIND. MEDI
CAL ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
AND SO THAT WOULD FREE UP
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES FOR. FOR OTHER USES.
OKAY BUT BUT IF THE SO SO BUT
THREE FORTY BE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS THAT THAT.
THEY WOULD GET THE DISCOUNT BUT
THEN IN THE MEANTIME THE THREE
FORTY BPM.
IS BEING PAID TO THE CLINICS
INTO THE.
.
HOSPITALS
BUT.
OKAY.
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
THESE THE SAVINGS WOULD BE IN
PLACE OF SAVINGS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OUT RETAIN TO AT LEAST
SOME EXTENT BY THREE FORTY BE
ENTITIES AND POTENTIALLY OTHER
PARTICIPANTS IN THAT IN IN THE.
IN SORT OF STUFF UP THE PAYMENT
CHAIN.
OKAY BUT IF AN AND I'M AGAIN I'M
STILL TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS
BECAUSE. IF
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THOUGH IS IT
FROM PREVIOUS COMMENTS WAS THAT
IT WAS BEING DOUBLE. A REBATED
SO THE STATE IS TALKING THE
REBATE AND THEN SO WAS THAT
THREE FORTY BE.
PROVIDERS ARE STILL GETTING SO
SOFT.
I CAN'T WRAP MY HEAD AROUND HOW
THE DISCOUNT WOULD HAPPEN IF
YOU'RE STILL GETTING BUT THIS
COUNTS ANYWAY WHAT YEARS WHAT
I'M HEARING IS THAT THERE'S
DOUBLE REBATES. AND SO THE STATE
IS STILL GETTING THE THE
DISCOUNT OR THE.
THE.
THE SAVINGS THAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
OKAY SO LET ME JUST UNDERSTAND
THE SOUL SO PART OF THE ISSUE
FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN READING AND
FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING IS
THAT THERE'S DOUBLE AHA
DISCOUNTS.
TO ME THAT MEANS THE STATE STILL
GETTING THE DISCOUNTS ARE STILL
GETTING THE REPEATS.
CORRECT AND SO IF THEY'RE
GETTING THAT I KNOW AND I'M
TRYING TO KIND OF VERBAL AND
THAT HERE SO IF YOU'RE STILL
GETTING THE BUT DISCOUNT AND
THEN THE THREE FORTY BE. ABOUT
FOLKS ARE GETTING THE DISCOUNT
YOU'RE ALREADY GETTING IN MY
MIND YOU'RE ALREADY GETTING.
THAT SAVING
BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY BEING
REALIZED BY WHAT I UNDERSTAND
THE DOUBLE.
OUT WE A REIMBURSEMENT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
AND FEDERAL ROUTE RULES BAR US
FROM GETTING THE DOUBLE
DISCOUNTS AND SO THERE ARE
PROCESSES IN PLACE.
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
NO NO I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT IN
THE MEAN RIGHT THIS MINUTE THERE
WERE STILL GETTING THE REBATES
THE STATE'S THEY'RE GETTING THE
REBATES AND THE POINT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING THE REBATE SO THEN. THE
SOUL I DON'T SEE WHERE THE
SAVINGS WOULD COME FROM BECAUSE
WE'RE ALREADY RECEIVING THE.
BUT REPEAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT WE'RE NOT COLLECTING THE
MEDICAID REBATE ON THE ON THE
VAST MAJORITY PROBABLY OF THE
THREE FORTY BE DRUGS THAT ARE
TAGGED THAT WAY BUT I WOULD
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT. SO
BRING A MONOLOGUE SO. WHEN DRUGS
ARE BUILT TO THE DEPARTMENT
WE HAVE CERTAIN PRICING
METHODOLOGIES FOR HOW.
PHARMACIES CLINICS ARE SUPPOSED
TO BELLA'S.
IF THEY PARTICIPATE IN THE THREE
FORTY BE PROGRAM.
IT NEEDS TO BE SUBMITTED IN THE
CLAIM THAT THIS DRUG THAT HAS
BEEN DISPENSED COME REIMBURSED
IS A THREE FORTY BE DRUG.
WE DO NOT HAVE THAT TRANSPARENCY
IN TERMS ABOUT REPORTING FOR
THOSE DRUGS SO WHEN WE ENTER
INTO REBATE AGREEMENTS WITH
MANUFACTURERS AND THEN WE WORK
OUT. THE DRUGS THAT HAD BEEN.
AND REIMBURSE THE DEPARTMENT IF
THEY'RE NOT IDENTIFIED AS BEING
A THREE FORTY BE WE SUBMIT AN
INVOICE TO THAT MANUFACTURERS
THEY WILL COME BACK IN DISPUTE
AND SAY NO. THERE ARE THREE
FORTY BE DRUGS ON THIS INVOICE
AND SO THEN THEY LOOKED AT THE
DEPARTMENT TO RECONCILE WHICH OF
THOSE DRUGS ORDER IN THAT
INVOICE ARE ACTUALLY THREE FORTY
BE DRUGS VERSUS NOT. AND UNTIL
WE CAN CLARIFY. INCORRECT THAT
DISPUTED INVOICE WHERE THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO COLLECT THE REBATES
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RIGHT BUT THEN IT SOUNDS TO ME
LIKE THAT IT'S A DEPARTMENT
ISSUE. BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
THE PROPER.
FLORIDA CALLS OR WHATEVER IT IS
TO NOT SEND WELL THAT HAVES WE
HAVE STATE LAW THAT REQUIRES
PARTICIPATING ENTITIES IN THE
THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM. TED BILL
PASSED AT THE RATE IN WHICH THEY
ACQUIRED THE DRUG RIGHT UNDER
THREE FOUR GB SO IF IT'S NOT
BEING. COMMUNICATED TO WHAT'S.
AND THEY'RE REIMBURSING NOT OR
THEY'RE CLAIMING TO US A
DIFFERENT AMOUNT WE DON'T KNOW
WHICH OF THOSE DRUGS ARE
ACTUALLY THREE FORTY BEAVER SAYS
NOT SO WE THEN DON'T PUT THOSE
CLAIMS. INTO THE SAME BUCKET
PROCLAIMING THE REBATES OR THE
DISCOUNTS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A WAY TO BE ABLE TO
TRACK THOSE.
UP DRUGS I MEAN WHAT ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES BECAUSE IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER WAS ALSO
AROUND THE USE OF CONTACT
PHARMACY.
AND ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS
UNDER HER CELL WHICH OVERSEES
THE THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM IS
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS
A. CONTRACT PHARMACY ARRANGEMENT
BOTH THE THREE FORTY BE ENTITY
THAT CONTRACT PHARMACY AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE TO INTO. ENTER
INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH ONE
ANOTHER IT WAS MENTIONED THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE CONTRACT
PHARMACIES THAT ARE IN USE. BUT
WE ONLY HAVE ONE AGREEMENT RIGHT
NOW THAT WE ARE WHERE OUT WITH
THE HEALTH PLAN WITH PARTNERSHIP
HELP OKAY SO THEN. SO WE HAVE SO
SO.
THE CHALLENGES CONTRACT
PHARMACIES.
MAY NOT RECOGNIZE OR REALIZE
THAT FOR THE CLAIMS THAT THEY
ARE SUBMITTING TO THE DEPARTMENT
THAT THERE ARE ACTUALLY A THREE
FORTY BE DRUG. SO THEY ARE NOW
BILLING US AT A HIGHER OUR.
RATE.
AND THAT WERE NOW REIMBURSING
THEM AND THEN ON THE BACK AND
THERE WAS A RECONCILIATION
PROCESS THAT IS HAPPENING
BETWEEN THE MANUFACTURER AND THE
THREE FORTY BE ENTITY. AND THAT
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF WHAT WAS
REIMBURSED SAID THAT PHARMACY
PROVIDER AND THAT RECONCILED A
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS THAT
SAVINGS. THAT IS BEING GENERATED
AND MAINTAINED BY THE THREE
FORTY BE ENTITIES TO DO THE
THINGS THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE
SPOKE ABOUT TED RIGHT BUT THEN
SO THEN TURNED. TO ME AND AGAIN.
I'M A TEACHER NOT A. MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL BUT.
FOR ME WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE IS.
AND THAT'S JUST IN SIMPLE TERMS
AND OBVIOUSLY THE EXPERTS CAN
HELP ME LATER.
BUT DON'T WE CAN'T WE JUST SAY
YOU CAN'T USE THE CONTRACT
PHARMACIES LET'S JUST IF YOU
WANT TO MAINTAIN THAT REFER TO
BE INSTEAD OF ELIMINATING THE
THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM
ALTOGETHER BECAUSE OF THOSE ARE
THERE ISSUES I MEAN. IT. I MEAN
AGAIN I'M.
COMPLETELY JUST TRYING TO.
GRAPH THE ISSUE IF I COULD
RESPOND TO THAT OUT WE HAVE
SEVENTEEN CONTRACT PHARMACIES
AND WE HAVE A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR. AND THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR TRACKS ALL
OF OUR THREE CORE AB MEDICATIONS
THROUGH OUR NPI NUMBER AND ALL
OF THOSE PHARMACEUTICALS THAT
ARE DISTRIBUTED OUT OF ANYONE OF
THOSE CONTRACT PHARMACIES ARE
RECONCILED MONTHLY. AND ANNUALLY
SO THAT'S THAT SYSTEM ALREADY
EXISTS AS A PATH FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER THERE'S
A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE REPORTING
TOOL.
OKAY UP SO THEN OKAY SO THAT'S
ONE ISSUE AND I THINK.
WE ALL AGREE THAT.
THIS IS A BIG ISSUE THAT CAN'T
BE SOLVED.
HERE ON. THE OTHER.
COMMENT I GUESS IS WE TALK
ABOUT THESE SAVINGS BEER BEING
REALIZED AND BEING ABLE TO USE
THOSE SAVINGS FOR OTHER PROGRAMS
BUT BY THE TIME WE REALLY
REALIZE THOSE SAVINGS.
IF THEY MAGICALLY APPEAR HOWEVER
WE PLAN ON APPEARING THEM.
.
IT COULD BE.
SAY A YEAR SO WE WOULDN'T BE
USING ANY OF THOSE SAVINGS
ANY TIME SOON ON TOTAL SAVINGS
ARE REALIZED IN THE MEANTIME.
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE. I WILL BE
IMPACTED BECAUSE SERVICES WON'T
BE ABLE TO BE PROVIDED WE CAN
AUGMENT THE. MEDICARE MEDICAID
WHATEVER.
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE HOPING TO
AUGMENT WHAT THE SAVINGS UNTOLD
FAIR YEAR MAYBE ANOTHER YEAR AND
A HALF IN THE MEANTIME I'VE
COMMUNITIES THAT. ARE GOING TO
BE.
HUGELY IMPACTED
BY THIS.
TRANSITION SO.
I I A AGAIN.
WANT TO BE TRANSPARENT BY.
AT WHAT COST IN THE MEANTIME I
THINK THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT IT
SEEMS LIKE EVERYBODY'S WILLING
TO SIT DOWN AND TALK ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS AND THEY
DON'T.
THERE COMPLICATED I THINK WERE
OVER COMPLICATING THEM BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
THERE'S.
FOLKS THAT ARE ALREADY WORKING
WITH. ART THERE PROVIDERS OR OR
PHARMACIES AND THEN SOMEBODY
THAT THAT THIRD PARTY LIKE
MANAGEMENT PERSON THAT IS TAKING
CARE OF THAT SO IT JUST SEEMS TO
ME THAT THAT COULD BE. A
SOLUTION FOR US AS WELL ON.
ANYTHING BUT THAT'S JUST MY
COMMENTS BY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALL OF THESE
ISSUES. WAYS OF FIXING IT OR NOT
FIXING ADD.
ELIMINATING IT RIGHT AWAY
DOESN'T THAT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE
WE'RE PREPARED TO ELIMINATE IT
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
REALLY TALKED ABOUT.
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS POSSIBLE
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN THE
HEALTH CENTERS ALL OF THEM.
AND THE STATE AND TRYING TO.
I FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN DO THIS
WITHOUT BUT THE LEAST IMPACT.
YES ON THE THE.
PROVIDERS OF THE SERVICES BUT
ULTIMATELY THE FOLKS THERE
RECEIVING THEIR CERTAIN THE
SERVICES WON'T BE RECEIVING THE
SERVICES BECAUSE ALL OF THESE
HEALTH CENTERS. ARE BEING
IMPACTED SOLD.
I CAN GO ON AND WE CAN CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW POINT
OF.
MY LONG WINDED.
I CONVERSATION AS.
TO.
EXPRESS HOW MUCH MORE WE NEED TO
WORK ON TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T IMPACT.
MAINLY FOR ME THE BIGGEST
CONCERN IS AS THE COMMUNITIES
THAT I REPRESENT. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK THAT WE.
THE BRAKES ON THAT FOR NOW UNTIL
WE CAN.
ALL SIT DOWN AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE BEST.
SOLUTION WOULD BE.
FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED BUT AGAIN
FOR ME THE MAIN CONCERN IS THE
PUBLIC AND THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT I SERVE THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS.
ENOUGH AXES THAT'S IT IS AND
THEN IT WOULD THE IMPACT WOULD
HAVE WAY LET'S AXES AND SO
INSTEAD OF HELPING OR HURTING
THEM EVEN IF IT'S.
TEMPORARY BECAUSE IT SOUNDS
THAT EVEN THOUGH.
EVEN IF WE ELIMINATE THE PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW THOUGH SAVINGS WON'T
BE REALIZE FOR AT LEAST ANOTHER
YEARS ON THE MEANTIME WHAT OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES DO.
TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT HOW THE
CONSERVE THE THE THE
POPULATIONS.
I WANNA ECHO MANY OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVEALS COMMENTS AND SAY
THAT IF WE HAD ANOTHER MEMBER
HERE I MIGHT ASK FOR EMOTION AND
SOME ACTION TODAY.
BECAUSE I FIND WHAT IS BEING
PROPOSED FAR TO EXTRACT NOT TIME
TOMORROW MORNING FOR YOU WANT TO
CALL A SPECIAL MEETING.
AS WELL AS DETRIMENTAL TO ACCESS
AND WANT TO REITERATE WHAT WAS
SAID EARLIER TODAY.
THE FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE
ELIMINATION IT REQUIRES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROGRAM
INTEGRITY.
SO I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT IF I CAN ARE THERE
ANY OTHER STATES THAT ARE
CONSIDERING THE ELIMINATION. OF
THE THREE FORTY BE PROGRAM.
NOT NECESSARILY THE ELIMINATION
BUT STATES HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
HOW TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE IT IS AN ISSUE I'VE
NATIONALLY AND IN PARTICULAR IN
MANAGED CARE ELIVERY SYSTEMS.
BECAUSE OF THAT. THAT WORK WITH
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND CONTRACT
WITH THE PROVIDERS AND SO.
THERE'S THIS DISPARITY IN TERMS
OF THE INFORMATION THAT MAY BE
REPORTED BACK TO THE MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND BASED UPON.
.
YOU KNOW STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE AND AUDIT FINDINGS AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL THEY HAVE
RECOGNIZED THE CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF MANAGING THE THREE
FORTY BE PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR
WITH CONTRACT ARRANGEMENTS. AND
THEY OFFER NO IDENTIFIED
SOLUTIONS THAT STATES COULD AT
LEAST YOU KNOW SIT DOWN AND HAVE
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT.
JUST BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITIES
OF THE PROGRAM THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL THOUGH CAME
OUT WITH A VERY DETAILED REPORT.
HIGHLIGHTING WHAT OTHER STATES
ARE ATTEMPTING TO DO.
AND I WONDER WHY WE DON'T LOOK
TO THEIR RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS
TO REQUIRE CLAIM LEVEL. METHODS
AND I'M TRYING TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT EXPLICITLY. WHY ARE
WE NOT CONSIDERING THAT PROPOSAL
THAT? WE ARE LOOKING AT ALL.
.
CONSIDERATIONS OUT WE DO HAVE A
MEETING THAT'S BEING PLANNED
WITH EYES SOME OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES HERE TODAY
REGARDING THE THREE FORTY BE
PROPOSAL SO WE DO REMAIN
COMMITTED AND TIMES OF WORKING
WITH INDIVIDUALS. REGARDING THE
PROPOSAL THAT IS ON THE TABLE
BUT BECAUSE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE EXPERIENCED AS WHY
WE HAVE THE PROPOSAL ON THE
TABLE TODAY.
IT THUMB WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO WAS SPEAKING IT DOES SEEM
THAT THE PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN
IS A POTENTIAL MODEL FOR US TO.
LOOK AT AS A AN EXAMPLE OF PILOT
IF YOU WELL THAT HAS WORKED
WELL.
ARE THERE ANY PROBLEMS THAT
YOU'RE EXPERIENCING WITH THAT
SPECIFIC HEALTH PLAN AND WHY
AREN'T WE CONSIDERING THAT AS A
POTENTIAL. PATH FORWARD I MEAN
THAT IS ONE OPTION BUT I THINK
AGAIN ONE OF THAT THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES HERE IS. THAT SAVINGS
THAT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED BECAUSE
THERE IS A CEILING PRICE FOR
THREE FORTY BE DRUGS.
WE'VE THE STATE DO NOT KNOW WHAT
THAT CEILING PRICES.
WE'LL LEARN ABOUT
WHITE
THE.
ENTITIES WHAT THEY CLAIM TO US
WHAT IS REIMBURSED BUT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE CEILING PRICES SO
THERE IS A CEILING PRICE OF
THREE FORTY BE. THERE'S SOME
DIFFERENCE IN BETWEEN THERE AND
MOM WE REIMBURSE FOR.
.
MEDICATIONS IN THE PROGRAM WE'RE
LOOKING TO REIMBURSE AB WHAT THE
DRUG WAS ACQUIRED FOR.
SO IF YOU ACQUIRED THE DRUG JUST
AS AN EXAMPLE FOR TEN DOLLARS.
WE WOULD THEN LOOK TO REIMBURSE
YOU WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THREE
FORTY BE.
AT THAT TEN DOLLARS PLUS THE
DISPENSINGFEE NOT SOME NUMBER
THAT FROM TEN DOLLARS MAYBE UP
TO SAY TWENTY DOLLARS
BECAUSE IT'S THAT DIFFERENCE
MATT'S BREAD. THAT IS THEM BEING
MAINTAINED BY THE THREE FOUR TO
BE ENTITIES TO DO THE THINGS
THAT PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HERE BUT. THERE IS NO. FOR
TRANSPARENCY IN TERMS OF HOW
THOSE MONIES ARE THEN BE AND
UTILIZE WHETHER IT'S FOR THE
MEDICAID PROGRAM OR FOR
POPULATIONS THAT ARE UNINSURED
TODAY.
SO THAT THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT.
HAS COME TO OUR ATTENTION AND
THAT WAS ALSO IDENTIFIED FROM LA
OR RECOMMENDATIONS BUT AGAIN WE
DO WERE REMAIN COMMITTED. IN
TERMS OF SITTING DOWN WITH FOLKS
TO TALK THROUGH SOME OPTIONS
THAT WE MAY WANT TO RECONSIDER
AND MAY LOOK TO PRESENT AT MAY
REVISE WHAT DOES THE STATE
EXPECT WILL HAPPEN TO THE FQHCS
OUR SAFETY NET. HOSPITALS
WITHOUT THE THREE FORTY BE
PROGRAM.
AGAIN WE WOULD BE LOOKING THAT
REIMBURSING THEM AT COST
FOR FOR PURPOSES OF THAT.
DISPENSING OF MEDICATIONS
SO WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND A
FOR REIMBURSING THEM ACT
BECAUSE.
THEN WHAT'S THE LOS
TO THOSE CLINICS WHAT THE LAW
SAYS IS THE DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF THEM THAT THE SAVINGS THAT
THEY GENERATE BECAUSE THEN WE'RE
BEING BILLED. AT A HIGHER RATE
THEM WHAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
THEM WHAT THE DRUG WAS ACTUALLY
ACQUIRED.
THE.
I'M STRUGGLING A BIT WITH THAT
ANSWER AND DO YOU HAVE TO SHARE
THAT SENTIMENT THAT I. BELIEVE
THIS WILL BE DETRIMENTAL TO
ACCESS AND. AFFECT MANY OF OUR
AGE FQHCS THAT.
MY COMMUNITY NEEDS AND REALLY.
.
STRUGGLE WITH THAT ANSWER BUT
WILL LOOK TURF HAVING FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THAT
UNDERSTOOD BUT IF IF I CAN. WEEK
WE HEARD THAT THE STATE GETS TO
KEEP A THIRD OF THE SAVINGS AND
WE'RE GIVING BACK TWO THIRDS.
I WAS HOPING YOU COULD EXPAND ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT TO.
EXPLAIN WHY THAT WOULD BE BETTER
FOR OUR STATE.
THEN WHAT WE HAVE NOW.
I MEAN PART OF IT IS WHAT WE'RE
WORK HARD TO GET BACK TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NUMBER
SHARING IN SAVINGS BECAUSE THE
PROGRAM IS FINANCE.
IN PART WITH FEDERAL DOLLARS
SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
FEDERAL SHARING RATIO THAT'S
JUST A REQUIREMENT A
PARTICIPATING AND ON THE FEDERAL
REBATE PROGRAM WE ALSO HAVE A
STATE REBATE PROGRAM WHICH IS
SEPARATE AND APART. FROM THE
THREE FORTY BE BUT THE GOAL OF
THREE FORTY BE WISE TO.
MAXIMIZE.
.
YOU KNOW IT LOW COST
IN TERMS OF PROGRAM OPERATIONS.
TO IF WE'RE GIVING A TWO THIRDS
OF THE DOLLARS BACK DOES THAT
BENEFIT OUR SYSTEM.
WELL YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT WHERE
WE ACTUALLY THEN SPENDING FOR
THE COST OF THOSE SERVICES
BECAUSE NOW RIGHT NOW IT WOULD
APPEAR THAT WERE.
OVER SPEND.
AND I I RECOGNIZE THAT THE
CONCERN RAISED BY A PART OF IT
IS HOW THE REBATE PROGRAM WORKS
BUT THEN IF THERE ARE SAVINGS
BECAUSE THERE ARE SAVINGS THAT
ARE OUT THERE. BETTER NOT BE
INPUT AND FIND THE LEGISLATURE
WHAT THEY MAKING THEM DECISION.
WHAT?
WOULD YOU ANTICIPATE THOSE
SAVINGS WOULD BE USED FOR.
WHY THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE A
DECISION FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TOTAL WHEN I AM WHO I AM I
READING GENERAL FUND THEN
BECAUSE I? GUESS BECAUSE WE DO
NOT CONTROL THE USE OF THE
GENERAL FUND SO I STRUGGLE WHEN.
OUR SYSTEMS ARE STRESSED AS THEY
ARE TO CONSIDER THAT WERE
TAKING.
LIMITED HEALTHCARE DOLLARS AND
SENDING TWO THIRDS OF THEM. BACK
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THEN POSSIBLY RE DEDICATING THE
OTHER THIRD TOWARDS OTHER
SOURCES.
THERE WERE ACTUALLY IMPROVING
ACCESS TO CARE INSTEAD OF.
INHIBITING IT IN SOME TRYING TO
REALLY GET A SENSE.
.
IF NO OTHER STATES ARE TRYING TO
DO THIS IF.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AND WE
HAVE A POTENTIAL PATH FORWARD
WITH A PLAN IN OUR COMMUNITY
WIRE WE NOT LOOKING AT THAT.
AS OUR PATH FORWARD.
RATHER THAN THE ELIMINATION.
I THINK AGAIN THAT THAT
SOMETHING FOR CONSIDERATION I
DON'T THINK THAT THEY'RE YOU
KNOW STATES. IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN PUT FORWARD TO SEE
A MASS THEY HAVE OTHER STATES
HAVE PUT FOR REQUIREMENTS WHERE
THEY DO A LEMONADE. AYE THE USE
OF CONTRACT FORMS.
SO THERE AS MORE OF A A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP OF WHAT THE
PROVIDERS WILL ACTUALLY BELL AND
THEN IDENTIFY FOR THOSE SURPLUS.
OUT AND WITH THIS IF I CAN
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THE MOTHER WHO
TESTIFIED SAID IT BEST.
SHE SAID TO URGE THE STATE TO
FIND AN ALTERNATIVE.
WITHOUT AFFECTING OUR CENTERS
FOR EXCELLENCE.
I THINK THAT SAYS IT WELL AND I
HOPE THAT DEPARTMENT FINDS AN
ABILITY TO. REACH OUT TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND FIND A
SOLUTIONS THAT BEST FOR THE
STATE.
I JUST WANT ONE OUR LAST
QUESTION THERE IS A COMMENT
ABOUT.
BECAUSE SOME OF THESE CLINICS
CAN PARTICIPATE IN THREE FORTY
BE THAT THEY HAVE. EITHER A
REALLY EXPENSIVE.
.
A ACCESS OR NO ACCESS TO SOME OF
THESE DRUGS AND HOW. DO WE
ACCOUNT FOR THAT FOR SOME OF
THESE FOLKS ARE IF I HEARD YOU
CORRECTLY IS.
IF HOW WOULD WE.
THE ABLE ACCESS OR SOME OF THESE
FOLKS BE ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
NEEDED.
UGH DRUGS IF NOW THEY CAN'T
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM AND
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
DRUGS.
BUT THREE FORTY BEE IS JUST ONE
WAY IN TERMS OF GETTING DRUGS
PROVIDED. OTHERWISE THROUGH OUR
REIMBURSEMENT POLICIES WE THEN
REIMBURSE AT THE COST OF THE
DRUG THAT WAS ACQUIRED BY THE
ENTITY. THEIR REIMBURSE AT THAT
AMOUNT PLUS THE DISPENSING FEE.
IT OKAY IF YOU COULD CLARIFY FOR
ME BECAUSE I'LL BE HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT SO AND THE MODEL THAT RAINY
IS REFERRING TO IS IN THAT FEE
FOR SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM. SO
TODAY COVERED ENTITIES DO NOT
READ ANYTHING YOU THINGS FROM
THREE FORTY BE. IN FEE FOR
SERVICE WHICH IS ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE MEDI CAL BOOK
BUSINESS. THE REMAINING EIGHTY
PERCENT THOUGH IS REIMBURSED
BASED ON PRIVATELY NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS BETWEEN HEALTH PLANS
AND HOSPITALS SOMETIMES AS
HEALTH PLANS PACKED WITH THE XIN
COST FROM THEM THEY PAY MORE
SOMETIMES AT LAST THAT'S ALL
PART OF THE NEGOTIATION. BUT IF
WE CAN NO LONGER PARTICIPATE IN
THREE FORTY BE FOR THIS MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE BOOK OF BUSINESS.
THAT MEANS THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
AYE THREE FORTY HOSPITALS
PURCHASE THOSE DRUGS AT
WHOLESALE ACQUISITION COSTS
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL RULES SAY.
YOU CANNOT BE PART OF A GROUP
PURCHASING ORGANIZATION IF YOU
ARE A THREE FORTY BE COVERED
ENTITY.
SO YOU KNOW THE BEST WAY I CAN
EXPLAIN IT PERHAPS AS. WE CAN
EVEN GO TO COST GOING GET THESE
DRUGS WE HAVE TO GO TO RITE AID
AND GET THEM NOW AND THAT IS THE
MOST EXPENSIVE DRUG ON THE
MARKET RIGHT NOW. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GET PAID BY THE
DEPARTMENT NOT AT. OUR.
ACQUISITION BECAUSE IT STILL PER
THAT CONTRACT THAT WE NEGOTIATED
WITH THE PLAN SO THE PLAN THIRTY
TOLD US WERE PAYING YOU TWENTY
DOLLARS FOR THAT DRUG WE DON'T
CARE IF YOU BOUGHT IT AT RITE
AID FOR FIFTY DOLLARS OR IF YOU
BOUGHT IT AT COSTCO FOR FORTY OR
ON. THREE FORTY BE FOR TEN. IT
DOESN'T MATTER TO US WE'VE
NEGOTIATED THAT THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING PAID FOR THAT
DRUG SO WE WILL HAVE TO PAY
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE IF WE CAN'T
BUY THESE JOGGED THREE FORTY BE.
AND THAT'S GOING DEBT. AGAIN BE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR HOUSE.
THANK YOU AND THE AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE THE NEXT.
STEP WOULD BE BUT I THINK THAT.
I THINK OF DOCTOR WOULD
EVERYBODY ELSE WAS HERE THAT WE
EXPRESS AND I PERSONALLY I WILL
THAT THIS REQUIRES WE MORE
CONVERSATION AND ELIMINATING
THIS. YOU KNOW FROM ONE ONE DAY
TO ANOTHER WHICH IN.
HOSPITAL TIMES YOU KNOW SIX
MONTHS IS ONE DAY TO ANOTHER
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO PLAN
FOR THE.
FOR THE REST OF THE YEAR FOR
THE. FUTURE YEARS WE NEED TO HOW
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION IN
AGAIN NIGHTS CLEAR THAT THERE'S.
ROOM MANY EXPERTS NOT ME.
THAT ARE WILLING TO SIT DOWN
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT SOLUTION I
KNOW THAT THERE WERE SOME. AYE
DISCUSSION OVER IN THE SENATE.
ABOUT.
THE POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES SO
IT'S NOT JUST THE ASSEMBLY
THAT'S HAVING ISSUES WITH THAT
IS THE SENATE ONE MEAN.
REALLY GO BOTTOM LINE FOR ME IS
THAT ALLOW LOSS OF CARE FOR THE
KINGDOM WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THE MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
BUT THEN IN THIS CASE.
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT REALLY TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AND YOU
KNOW I HOPE THAT WE CAN NEVER
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE THAT
WEEK.
THAT SOME POINT TALK ABOUT THE
HUMAN FACTOR IN THIS AND YES
FELLOW BOTTOM LINE IN THE
SPREADSHEETS ARE GUIDED BY THE
HUMAN FACTOR IN THIS IS THAT MY
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS I THINK
ALL OF CALIFORNIA TO BE QUITE
HONEST I DON'T THINK WE'RE
UNIQUE DOCTOR ROBILAR AYE YOU
NEED TO THE. FACT THAT THERE'S
POOR PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THE SERVICES AND SO IF
WE CAN ASK THAT THE HUMAN FACTOR
BE. AYE LEAST PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AS OPPOSED TO UST
THE MONEY FACTOR.
ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND ARE
LOOKING FOR RESOLUTION BY AT
THIS POINT I. REALLY WOULD HOPE
THAT WE HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
WITH THE THE STAKEHOLDERS.
BECAUSE MY STAKEHOLDERS AND
MICE DISTRICT CAT COME UP HERE
AND DON'T HAVE A SEAT AT THAT
TABLE THIS ISN'T THE FEET THAT
THEY. HAVE AT THE TABLE IS
THROUGH THEIR EYES AND SO.
.
RESPECTFULLY ASK AGAIN THAT WE
DON'T DO THIS.
RIGHT AWAY I THINK WE CAN TKE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
TO ASK OFFICIALLY YOU BACK WE
DON'T DO.
THANK YOU.
SEEING AS A SEVEN O'CLOCK AT
NIGHT AND WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
TAKE ACTION TODAY.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE MAY
REVISE BUT IN MUCH THE SAME WAY
AS. YOU'RE FINDING IT DIFFICULT
TO CATEGORIZE THREE FORTY BE.
AYE WANTS TO ENSURE THE NUMBERS
WE GET FROM.
THE DEPARTMENT ARE ACCURATE.
THAT THE REAL.
THAT THE SAVINGS CAN BE TRACKED
AND SO REALLY WILL BE LOOKING TO
YOU TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE IF WE CAN
HAVE A PATH FORWARD.
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SIXTEEN OPEN END OF ON THAT
ISSUE SEVENTY
.
SITEMAP OKAY.
THANK YOU AND I.
ARI TIMES THEIR BROOKS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO THE AGENDA ITSELF
DOES COVER AT THE G. HPP BOB
BUDGET IN GENERAL. ON THE
GENETICALLY HANDICAPPED PERSONS
PROGRAM PROVIDES COVERAGE FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE CONDITIONS SUCH
AS CYSTIC FIBROSIS HEMOPHILIA
SICKLE CELL OR HUNTINGTON'S.
PRETTY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
CASELOAD IS A PROCESS
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE AT THIS TIME. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SHOWS FOR
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
COSTS OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
BECAUSE OF SMALL CASELOAD SIZE
AND HIGH COSTS OF TREATING THESE
CATASTROPHIC CONDITIONS COST
CAMPUS FLUCTUATE SIGNIFICANTLY
AND SO YOU DO SEE THAT IN THE
BUDGET ITSELF. AND THERE WAS A
REQUEST FOR AT ADDRESSING OF
BLOOD CLOTTING FACTORS WILL
ADDRESS THAT IN THE NEXT AND THE
NEXT TIME AGENDA ITEM IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH YOU ABSOLUTELY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELIA.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
SEVENTEEN.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SEVENTEEN OPEN TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE A TO.
WE CAN MAKE. FACE
.
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LINDA TAKE AMHERST I
GRADUATED WITH A DOCTORATE IN
PHARMACY FROM USC IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE.
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS I'VE
BEEN A CLINICAL PHARMACIST IN
FRESNO WORKING WITH HEMOPHILIA
PATIENTS.
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE POTENTIALLY DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES.
BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PROPOSED CHANGE TO
MEDI CAL PHARMACY REIMBURSEMENT
FOR FLOOD FACTORS.
COULD HAVE ON PATIENTS WITH
BLEEDING DISORDERS SUCH AS
HEMOPHILIA.
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES ARE AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
HEMOPHILIA CARE BECAUSE PATIENTS
WITH BLEEDING DISORDERS REQUIRE
SPECIAL CARE.
THE APPROPRIATE MANAGEMENT OF
HEMOPHILIA IS CRITICAL IN
MINIMIZING AND PREVENTING LONG
TERM COMPLICATIONS THAT CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO HIGHER HEALTHCARE
COSTS.
HISTORICALLY PATIENTS TREATED
BLEEDING EPISODES ON DEMAND.
TODAY HOWEVER PROPHYLAXIS
TREATMENT HAS GAINED IMPORTANCE
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN ASSOCIATED
WITH BETTER OUTCOMES.
INCLUDING REDUCE JOINT BLEEDS.
JOINT REPLACEMENT SURGERIES ARE
A COMMON COMPLICATION FROM NOT
PROACTIVELY TREATING THE
HEMOPHILIA PATIENTS JOINT
BLEEDS.
BECAUSE OVER TIME THE REPEATED
BLEEDING INTO THOSE JOINTS CAN
CAUSE SEVERE DAMAGE.
AS A RESULT PROACTIVE CARE AND
SPECIAL SERVICES PROVIDED BY
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES
SUCH AS CREATING CARE PLANS ARE
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO IMPROVED
OUTCOMES AND REDUCE COSTS.
AT OUR PHARMACY WE MONITOR
PATIENT RESPONSE TO THERAPY BY
RECORDING BELIEVES BY TYPE
LOCATION AND BECAUSE.
AND PROACTIVELY REACH OUT TO THE
PATIENT'S HEMOPHILIA TREATMENT
CENTER TO ALERT THEM OF ANY
PROBLEMS.
WE WORK WITH.
THE PATIENTS HTC TO DEVELOP
TREATMENT PLANS FOR HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS FOR SURGERIES
OBSTETRICS DENTAL PROCEDURES
EXCEPT FOR.
TO MAKE SURE THE PATIENT HAS
ADEQUATE PRODUCT AVAILABLE FOR
THE GIVEN PROCEDURE.
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES IT TREAT
BLEEDING DISORDER PATIENTS
PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR HOUR ACCESS
TO CONSULTATION WITH THE
CLINICAL PHARMACIST.
THIS ALLOWS PATIENTS TO HAVE A
SUPPLY OF FACTORY HOME SO THEY
CAN COMPLY WITH THEIR
PROPHYLAXIS AND TREAT A BLEEDER
EARLY SHOULD OCCUR.
THEREBY KEEPING THEM OUT OF THE
ER OR HOSPITAL AND PREVENTING
COSTLY COMPLICATIONS SUCH AS THE
JOINT REPLACEMENT.
THE D. H. CS PROPOSED
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY FOR
BLOOD FACTORS FOR MEDI CAL
PATIENTS.
WOULD THREATEN BLEEDING DISORDER
PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY BY
LIMITING ACCESS TO CARE.
THE NEW REIMBURSEMENT WOULD MAKE
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO REMAIN
IN BUSINESS AND WILL NOT BE VERY
ATTRACTIVE TO LARGER SPECIALTY
PHARMACIES EITHER.
IT DOES NOT COVER THE COST OF
KEEPING FACTOR IN STOCK
OR PROVIDING SERVICES FOR THE
PATIENTS.
THIS WILL RESULT IN DECREASED
PATIENT CHOICE OF PHARMACY AND
ACCESS TO CARE.
WITHOUT AVAILABLE CLOTTING
FACTOR IN SERVICES PATIENTS MAY
RESORT BACK TO TREATING ON
DEMAND. I'M GOING TO HE OURS FOR
THEIR INFUSIONS.
HE OURS ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
PREPARED TO HANDLE A PATIENT
WITH A BLEEDING DISORDER.
MOST DO NOT STOP CLOTTING
FACTOR.
AND THE STAFF IS NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE DIFFERENT PRODUCTS AND
HOW TO APPROPRIATELY DOES THEM.
AS A RESULT OUR PHARMACY HAS
BEEN A RESOURCE FOR MOST OF THE
E. OURS IN THE FRESNO AREA FOR
THIS VERY REASON.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
PREVENT D. H. CS FROM IMPOSING
THEIR.
OPPOSED BLOOD FACTOR
REIMBURSEMENT CUTS TO SPECIALTY
PHARMACIES WHO SERVE HEMOPHILIA
PATIENTS.
THE GOOD DOCTOR HURST.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE EIGHTEEN.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS
TERRY COVER HILL AGAIN FOR THE
MONTHLY COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE FOUR THOUSAND
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
HEMOPHILIA AND RELATED BLEEDING
DISORDERS. WE HAD HISTORICALLY
SUPPORTED THE CURRENT RATE THAT
IS ON THE BOOKS AND I THINK
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CONTACTED THE STATE
INSTEAD. THEY NO LONGER WILL BE
ALLOWING THAT RATE AND SO THEY
DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO COME UP
WITH A NEW RATE. THE COUNCIL
DOESN'T HAVE A SPECIFIC POSITION
ON WHAT THAT RATE SHOULD BE OR
LEAVING IT TO THE THREE FORTY BE
PHARMACIES IN THE SPECIALTY
PHARMACIES BEFORE YOU TO COME UP
WITH THAT SOLUTION. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING
FOR LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
FOR YOU TO BE AWARE THAT THE
RATE THAT WAS INITIALLY PROPOSED
WE'RE HEARING IS.
INADEQUATE THERE ARE A LOT OF
ANCILLARY SERVICES THAT GO INTO
THE DELIVERY AND DISPENSING OF
CLOTTING FACTOR TO THE PATIENTS
IN THE HOME SETTING. WE WORKED
WITH ON KILEY MITCHELL ON THE
STANDARDS BILL IT'S STILL ON THE
BOOKS THAT WAS PUT FORTH IN
TWENTY TWELVE. SO THERE ARE
STANDARDS AROUND THE DISPENSING
OF THE STORAGE OF FACTOR SO
THAT'S ALL GOOD THAT'S ALL STILL
ON THE BOOKS AS I MENTIONED BUT
AS FAR AS THE NEW RATE IT HAS TO
BE ABLE TO COVER THE SHIPPING
SO.
IF THERE ARE.
.
THIS THE COSTS RELATED A
SHIPPING INCLUDE TRANSPORTATION
INCLUDE ICE PACKS IN THAT
EXPENSIVE FACTOR SO THAT IT
DOESN'T.
GET DESTROYED OUT IN THE HEAT
IN FRONT OF SOMEONE'S DOORSTEP
SO THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS THAT
GO INTO THE ANCILLARY COSTS THAT
THE SPECIALTY PHARMACIES IN
THREE FOUR TO BE PHARMACIES. CAN
ARTICULATE BETTER THAN I CAN WE
JUST HOPE THAT. YOU KEEP AN EYE
ON WHAT IS GOING ON IN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
ARE ALL INVOLVED IN A SOLUTION
THANK YOU BECAME.
I'M JOHN MARTINEZ FROM FRESNO I
HAVE TWO SONS WITH SEVERE
HEMOPHILIA DOT WITH MILD
HEMOPHILIA.
AND WHEN MY SON WAS BORN THERE
WAS NOBODY IN THE HOSPITAL WHO
COULD EXPLAIN TO US MY WIFE'S
PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS SPANISH.
THEY COULD TALK WAS EXPLAIN
EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING ON SO WE
MADE SOME BAD DECISIONS WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY INFORMATION AND
MY SON WENT TO A GREAT DEAL OF
TRAUMA IN THE HOSPITAL. BECAUSE
THE DOCTORS DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THEY WERE DOING AND THEY DIDN'T
A THE RIGHT TEST AT THE
BEGINNING SOME SAY THEY'VE BEEN
FIND OUT THAT AND LOOK AT THE
PTT LEVELS UNTIL. OUR SEVERAL
DAYS LATER WHEN THE FIGURE
FINALLY OUT AND IT WAS DURING
THAT PROCESS THAT WE SORT OF
HAVE TO ADVOCATE FOR OURSELVES%
AND LEARN BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL WE
WERE ABLE TO GET CONNECTED WITH
ESPECIALLY PHARMACIES AND SOME
ADVOCATES FROM THOSE. PHARMACIES
THAT WERE ABLE TO GIVE US THE
INFORMATION CONNECT US WITH THE
RIGHT RESOURCES SO THAT WE CAN
START TO MAKE SOME EDUCATED
DECISIONS WITH HIS CARE. AND HE
WENT FROM BEING IN A WHEELCHAIR
ONCE A MONTH TO PLAYING SPORTS
AND BEING BECOME REGULAR CHILD
FOR THE MOST PART. AND THAT WAS
DUE TO THE ACCESS THAT WE HAD WE
ARE I URGE YOU. TO DO I FAIR
COMPENSATION PLAN THAT WILL
ALLOW THAT TYPE OF ACCESS FOR
EVERY PATIENT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK WITH YOU AND APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THIS EVENING.
I ALSO HAVE AN ADULT BROTHER AND
A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD SON WITH
HEMOPHILIA.
I AM OPPOSED TO THE MEDICAL CUTS
THAT WE'RE TRULY THREATENED
HEMOPHILIACS TO OUR PATIENTS AND
OUR STATE.
I'VE GROWN UP AN IMMENSELY A
COMMUNITIES THROUGH SOME VERY
DIFFICULT TIMES.
AND I UNDERSTAND FIRST HAND THE
CHALLENGING BUT VITAL ROLE THAT
SPECIALLY PHARMACIES PLAY.
HAEMOPHILIA SEND A SPECIALLY
PHARMACIES ARE VITAL PARTNER IN
OUR COMPREHENSIVE CARE.
THEIR STAFF HAVE THE LEVEL OF
KNOWLEDGE NEEDED TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL TIME SENSITIVE AND
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE CARE FOR
OUR COMMUNITY.
PLEASE KNOW THAT DUE TO THE HIGH
COST OF THE MEDICATIONS FACTOR
MEDICATIONS ARE NOT ST
KEPT IN HOSPITAL PHARMACIES AND
AVAILABLE THE EMERGENCY ROOMS
GENERALLY. AS A MOTHER I CAN
TELL YOU STORY AFTER STORY OF
HOW ARE SPECIALLY PHARMACY WAS
THE FIRST RESPONDER IN OUR TIMES
OF NEED.
I CAN SHARE WITH YOU HOW THEY
PERSONALLY HAND DELIVERED FACTOR
TO THE IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM TO
TREAT A HADLEY THE COULD HAVE
PROVEN THAT AND ACTUALLY HELP
PREVENT BRAIN DAMAGE FROM MY
SON.
I CAN ALSO TELL YOU ABOUT THE
FRIDAY NIGHT DELIVERY WHERE THEY
MET US AT EIGHT O'CLOCK AT NIGHT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAD ENOUGH
PRODUCT TO GET THROUGH THE
WEEKEND BECAUSE MY SON HAD AN
ACTIVE NEW PLEADED THEY KNEW WE
WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL DOSES.
THEIR EXPERTISE AND SERVICES
PROVIDED ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
COMPREHENSIVE CARE BUT IT NEEDS
TO BE NOTED THAT THEY ALSO DO
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASE THE
OVERALL LIFETIME CARE NEEDS AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH DEALING
WITH THEIR TREATING A PERSON
WITH A BLEEDING DISORDER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CURRENT
PROPOSED COST FACTOR
REIMBURSEMENT THE CUTS WOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
SPECIALLY PHARMACIES TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE FOR THIS RARE
DISORDER. AND OUR COMMUNITY.
AS A MOTHER I ASK YOU TO REJECT
THEIR PROPOSED BUDGET CUTS
FOR PHARMACY AYE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES TO BLOOD CLOTTING FACTORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
BEGIN.
HI MY NAME IS THERE'S CHARMIN I
AM A CARRIER FOR SIPPING
HEMOPHILIA I HAVE. A THREE YEAR
OLD AND A SIX YEAR OLD AND
NEPHEWS THAT HAVE SEVERE
HEMOPHILIA AS WELL AS MY DAD.
AND MY DAD HAS DEVELOPED AN
INHIBITOR AS WELL AS MY YOUNGEST
NEPHEW. AND WE INFUSE THEN THE
HOMIES A SPECIALTY PHARMACY MY
YOUNGEST NEPHEW AND MY DAD HAVE
TO INFUSE EVERY DAY. AND GO
WHICH FROM MY DAD IT TAKES ABOUT
FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO AN HOUR
AND IF HE HAS A BLEED IT'S EVERY
TWO HOURS. SOMETIMES THAT COULD
LAST A COUPLE WEEKS MY NEPHEW
HAD TO DO FACTOR EVERY TWO HOURS
FOR TWENTY SIX DAYS.
I CAN'T EVEN CONCEPTUALIZE
WHAT IT WOULD BE TO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT IN YOUR HOME.
TO GO TO AN EMERGENCY ROOM THIS
WILL TAKE US BACK
TWENTY YEARS AND THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
JUST UNACCEPTABLE. I PLEASE.
HOPE THAT YOU.
HERE WHAT WE HAVE TO SAY I THINK
IT
EGGMAN.
ARE. MY NAME'S TERRY RICE I'M A
PERSON WAS APPEARING APHELIA
FACTORY DEFICIENCY I'M AGE FIFTY
SIX.
PER PERSON TO BE FIFTY SIX WHEN
MY SEVERITY OF DISEASE I'M LIKE
A UNICORN YOU DON'T SEE ME THAT
OFTEN.
A MY DEMOGRAPHICS.
PEERS OF THE SIXTIES SEVENTIES
AND EIGHTIES THERE EITHER
DECEASED ALSO SEVERELY.
DISABLED THAT.
.
THERE ARE AMBULATORY ISSUES ARE
DRAMATICALLY IMPACT IN THE
QUALITY OF LIFE.
I LOOK THROUGH ALL OF THE
ADVANCEMENTS OF HEMOPHILIA
THERAPIES FROM ESSENTIALLY
NOTHING IN THE EARLY SIXTIES. TO
THE AMAZING FACT REPLACEMENT
THERAPIES THAT WE HAVE TODAY.
THAT DUBBED I. DO USE AN
ECONOMIC TERM WHEN YOU WERE
HAVING A BLEED. AND THE PAIN OF
THEM OF A JOINT LEAD YOU CAN'T
EVEN I'M ACTION.
AND I WENT TWO HUNDRED ZIP UP
THEM.
AND.
WHEN YOU'RE HAVING THAT BLEED
LET ME TELL YOU FROM AN ECONOMIC
STANDPOINT THAT'S.
BUT I STUDY.
.
FACTORS SUBSTITUTES FOR
EVERYTHING AND NOTHING
SUBSTITUTES FOR IT FULL OF THE
PAIN RELIEF AND WHAT IT CAN DO
FOR YOU.
I AT THE. TWENTY YEARS AGO I HAD
BOTH OF MY LOOK MY KNEES HAVE
BEEN REPLACED
MY ANKLES HAVE NO DOOR SUPPLYING
AFFLICTION NO CIRCUMFLEX ION
IT I'M WALKING ON ESSENTIALLY
BONE ON BONE.
THAT THE PAIN IS EXTRAORDINARY.
I'M JUST STUBBORN.
ANY DELAY IT THE CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY THAT'S
BEEN PUT FORWARD BY THE EIGHT CS
WELL. BY ANYBODY'S ASSESSMENT
WILL CURTAIL ACCESS TO CARE.
ANY CURTAILMENT TO THE ACCESS TO
CARE THAT WE CURRENTLY ENJOY
WILL SET US BACK DECADES MY OLD
DECADES WITH MY RESULTS.
OF EITHER MY PEERS WHICH I'VE
EXPLAINED OR MYSELF IN A VERY
COMPROMISE QUALITY OF LIFE
SITUATION.
I'LL GIVE YOU A JUST A QUICK
EXAMPLE OF WHAT ANY DELAY ON ONE
PLEAD CAN DO PERSONALLY. I WOULD
INFER THAT CUT.
AT FOUR YEARS OF AGE ON THAT
HAND.
THEY TRIED ASPIRATED VINI
PUNCTURE OF FULL BOTTOM THE
SAMPLING CASE I MIGHT NEED A
TRANSFUSION IN THAT PROCESS THEY
INFILTRATED THE VEINS IN MY LEFT
ARM. THE ONE DOCTOR THAT KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT HIM THE PHILLY AT
THE TIME WAS ON VACATION FOR THE
WEEKEND. BY THE TIME HE GOT BACK
FORTY EIGHT HOURS LATER IN THE
THERAPY I NEED WHICH WAS A
PRECURSOR TO THIS REMARKABLE
FACT REPLACING THE RECALL CRY
PRECIPITATE BUT IT WAS VERY
EFFECTIVE. IN AND OF ITSELF.
BY THE TIME HE GOT BACK I HAD
HATE OPENS CONTRACTURE AYE IT
HAD A COMPARTMENT SYNDROME. AND
FOR THE LAST FIFTY YEARS I'VE
HAD ESSENTIALLY THIS ARM
HANGING.
THAT WAS BECAUSE OF THE LATE OF
ONE BELIEVE.
FROM CRIER PRECIPITATE WAS
LITERALLY TWO FLOORS ABOVE ME
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T GET INTO MY
BODY IN A TIMELY BASIS THAT IS
WHY IT'S SO CRITICAL. THAT
PATIENTS HAVE RENTAL ACCESS TO
CARE NO INTERRUPTIONS NO WAY TO
STOP THAT FROM HAPPENING HAVING
IT IN THEIR HOME BECAUSE IT IS
THE DELAY TO THAT FACTOR GETTING
INTO A PERSONAL BLEEDING
DISORDER.
AT ANY ANY DELAY WHATSOEVER
WHICH WILL CAUSE IRREPARABLE
PERMANENT DAMAGE THAT WILL.
COMPLETELY CHANGED THEIR LIVES
AND NOT FOR THE BETTER I URGE
YOU TO FIND A BETTER MECHANISM I
KNOW THAT THEIR UNDER
CONSTRAINTS BY CMS TWO THREE
FOUR. AT FTA THAT THE FINAL
RULE.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER STATES WHO'S
MEDICAID PROGRAMS HAVE LOOKED AT
THIS ISSUE SPECIFICALLY FOR
FACTORY AT FOR A BLEEDING
DISORDER THERAPIES AND IT FOUND
A BETTER SOLUTION. TO COMPLY
WITH BOTH CMS AND THEY'RE
REGULATION AND WE DO HAVE A
STATE LAW HERE IN CALIFORNIA
FROM TWO THOUSAND FOUR. THERE IS
A BETTER WAY AND MY SUGGESTION
IS THAT WE FIND IT BECAUSE THIS
CURRENT PROPOSAL WILL DO NOTHING
MORE THAN CURTAIL ACCESS TO
CARE.
AND I AM THE PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
WHAT THAT WILL MEAN.
GOOD EVENING I'M DOCTOR AMY
ALERS ON AND THE DIRECTOR OF
PHARMACY TO SPECIALTY PHARMACY
IN TO MY KILL OUT RIGHT CARE FOR
HAVE CARED FOR PATIENTS WITH
HEMOPHILIA FOR THE PAST ELEVEN
YEARS.
SPECIALLY PHARMACIST TRAINING
BLEEDING DISORDERS PROVIDE THE
INDIVIDUALIZED CARE NEEDED TO
ALLOW PATIENTS TO FOLLOW THEIR
TREATMENT PLANS AND HOW THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF FACTOR ON
HAND AT ALL TIMES.
BY MINIMIZING THE RELATED
COMPLICATIONS UNPLANNED E. R.
VISITS AND HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS
PATIENTS HAVE A HIGHER QUALITY
OF LIFE AND THE STATE SAVE
HEALTHCARE DOLLARS.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF PATIENTS ON
HAVING ACCESS TO AN EXPERT
SPECIALTY PHARMACY TEAM CAN BE
SIGNIFICANT.
MY PATIENT IN HIS EARLY FORTIES
UNDER ONE HIP REPLACEMENT DUE TO
REPEATED UNTREATED BLEEDING
EPISODES IN HIS TEENS AND
TWENTIES.
DEAR COMPLICATIONS OF THE
INITIAL PROCEDURE HIT A TOTAL OF
THREE HIP SURGERIES IN SIX
MONTHS
HE WENT FROM INFUSING AS BY
FACTOR WEEKLY TO ALMOST DAILY
DURING THIS TIME.
THIS LACK OF A CONSISTENT
QUALIFIED SPECIALTY PHARMACY
TEAM. CONTRIBUTED TO NEGATIVE A
FAX ON HIS PHYSICAL HEALTH
PERSONAL LIFE FAMILY JOB IN
FINANCES.
THE D. H. C. S. PROPOSED SEVENTY
FIVE TO NINETY PERCENT REDUCTION
MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR BUD
FACTOR PRODUCTS WOULD NOT ALLOW
ME TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MEDI
CAL PATIENTS. WITH THE OUTREACH
EDUCATION AND PATIENT CARE
SERVICES THAT ARE CURRENTLY DO.
PATIENTS WILL BE FORCED TO
UTILIZE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
WHICH ARE NOT EQUIPPED WITH A
VARIETY OF LIKE CUTTING FACTORS
OR THE TRAINING TO TREAT THESE
PATIENTS. I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO PROVIDE DEEP SEA ES ROOM
POSING THESE DRASTIC CUTS IN
BLOOD FACTOR REIMBURSEMENT
ESPECIALLY PHARMACIES. TO
SERVICE THE THING AFFILIATE
PATIENTS THINK YOU'RE WELCOME.
STEPHANIE DOWN SCORE AGAIN AS I
NOTED I OF AN ADULT SOME WAS
SEVERE HEMOPHILIA WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT REIMBURSEMENT RATE
FOR CLOTTING FACTOR.
THE AT THIS WILL.
AFFECT ACCESS TO LIFESAVING
MEDICATION AND TO THE SPECIALTY
TREATMENT CENTERS WHO PROVIDE
CARE TO THESE COMPLEX PATIENTS.
THE MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATE
BUT ALSO AFFECT CHILDREN WHO ARE
COVERED BY CCS AND G. H. PP MANY
PATIENTS WITH HEMOPHILIA. CANNOT
GET PRIVATE INSURANCE IF THE
COST IS PROHIBITIVE. THEY RELY
ON CCS NGH PP AS WELL AS MEDI
CAL.
I KNOW HOW EXPENSIVE CLOTTING
FACTOR IS FOR THE STATE BUT THIS
METHODOLOGY.
COULD ACTUALLY CREATE EVEN A
GREATER EXPENSE AS WELL AS HARM
TO THE PATIENTS.
GAME.
HI I'M RYAN REGAL AND I'M A
SEVERE FACTORY HEMOPHILIAC NAM
ALSO A PATIENT WITH A SPECIALTY
PHARMACY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HEARD IN PHARMACY.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE A. F. A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO PREVENT
THE PROPOSED MEDICAL CUTS TO
SPECIALTY PHARMACIES FOR OF.
BLOOD FACTORS.
THE BLEEDING DISORDER COMMUNITY
IS VERY SMALL THERE'S ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND I FEEL ACTS IN
AMERICA SO WE ARE A. VERY CLOSE
KNIT COMMUNITY AND WE LOOK OUT
FOR EACH OTHER AND THE SPECIALTY
PHARMACIES THAT I'VE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THAT COMMUNITY.
.
JUST TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE.
THE SPECIALTY PHARMACY THAT I'M
A PATIENT OF WAS STARTED BY
HEMOPHILIACS FOR HEMOPHILIACS.
AND THE UNDERSTAND LIVING WITH
HEMOPHILIA IN A WAY THAT NO
OTHER ORGANIZATION COULD.
UNLESS YOUR HEAD LIKE YOU
BELIEVE AS MY MONTHLY ORDER FOR
FACT WAS AWAITING AUTHORIZATION.
NOT PLACE TO CALL THE HERNDON
AND THEY HAD SOMEBODY WITH A
BREAK TO THOSE OF FACTOR TELL ME
TREAT THAT IF YOU BELIEVE DRIVEN
UP TO MY HOUSE AND THEY TURNED
AROUND A DROVE RIGHT BACK A SIX
HOUR ROUND TRIP JUST MAKE SURE
THAT I HAD ACCESS TO. OTHER
FACTOR I NEED TO TREAT THAT
LEAD.
AS HEMOPHILIAC YOU UNDERSTAND
DAMAGE THAT CAN BE DONE IF THAT
FACTOR IS NOT DELIVERED
PROMPTLY.
TOUCH WON'T SAY A LIVING WITH
HEMOPHILIA IS MUCH LESS OF A
BURDEN THAN IT OTHERWISE WOULD
BE. THANKS TO MEDI CAL G. H. PP
AND THE SPECIALTY PHARMACY THAT
I RELY ON FOR THESE FACTORED
LIVE.
DELIVERIES.
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT I HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S DIAGNOSED
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE
CONDITION I HAVE HAS MEDICINE
AVAILABLE TO TREAT MY DIAGNOSIS.
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT I LIVE IN
A PLACE WHERE THE MEDICINE IS
AVAILABLE TO ME.
.
I I JUST WANNA SAY THAT THE
THOUGHT OF NOT HAVING ACCESS TO
PROPHYLACTIC TREATMENT IS
TERRIFYING.
I'M I'M A PRODUCTIVE TAXPAYING
CITIZEN TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
PROPHYLACTIC TREATMENTS I
RECEIVED THROUGHOUT MY LIFE.
AND TO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
AS A PERSON WITH A BLEEDING
DISORDER IS.
THAT A CONDEMNATION IT DAVID THE
AYE THE IDEA WOULD BE
TERRIFYING.
WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS SHELLY JUDGE JAY AND
I AM THE MOTHER OF TWO SONS ONE
OF WHICH HAS SEVERE HEMOPHILIA.
I WAS NOT AWARE OVER SECURING
AIR INTO MY SON WAS BORN TWENTY
THREE YEARS AGO.
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT HAEMOPHILIA
WAS BUT ALONE HOW IT WAS GOING
TO RAISE A CHILD WITH THIS
DISEASE.
AFTER COUNTLESS TRIPS TO THE ER
FOR INFUSIONS I WAS FORTUNATE TO
MEET THE SPECIALTY CARE PHARMACY
OWNERS.
AT MY FOLLOW UP VISIT AT THE
HTC.
SHE TOOK THE TIME TO EXPLAIN TO
ME WHAT A SPECIALTY PHARMACY
DOES AND HOW THEY COULD HELP ME
WITH THE WELL BEING OF MY SON.
A SPECIALTY CARE PHARMACY HAS
THE HONOR OF COMING INTO
PATIENTS HOMES THEIR PLEASURE
PLACES OF EMPLOYMENT AND THEIR
SOCIAL SURROUNDINGS.
THEY GET TO MEET THE FAMILY AND
LEARN ABOUT THIS PERSON OUTSIDE
OF THEIR DISEASE STATE.
THIS FOSTERS A UNIQUE EXPERIENCE
THAT ENABLES THE SPECIALTY CARE
PHARMACY TO ACCESS THE NEEDS OF
THE PATIENT AND THEIR FAMILY AND
CONNECT THEM TO RESOURCES THAT
THEY MAY NOT. HAVE THE AWARENESS
OF.
HAVING A THOUGHTFUL AND
RESOURCEFUL SPECIALTY CARE
PHARMACY IN MY SON'S LIFE SINCE
THE AGE OF TWO HAS ENABLED HIM
TO BE JOINT FREE.
NOT ONLY DOES OUR SPECIALTY CARE
PHARMACY ENSURE THAT IS FACTOR
IS DELIVERED MONTHLY THEY ALSO
ENSURE THAT HE IS BEING
COMPLIANT WITH HIS INFUSIONS.
INFUSING DALY IS NOT SOMETHING
ANYONE WANTS TO DO HOWEVER WITH
THE SUPPORT OF OUR SPECIALTY
CARE PHARMACY MY SON STARTED
SELF INFUSING AT AGE SIX.
WITHOUT OUR SPECIALTY CARE
PHARMACY EDUCATING US ON
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TREATMENT
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS AVAILABLE
RESOURCES WE WERE UNAWARE OF. MY
SON WHO IS NOW TWENTY THREE MAY
NOT HAVE TURNED OUT TO BE THE
SIX FIVE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POUNDS YOUNG MAN HE IS TODAY.
I DID NOT HAVE A CHOICE WHEN I
GIVE THE HIM AFFILIATED JEAN TO
MY SON BUT I DO HAVE A CHOICE ON
CHOOSING A SPECIALTY CARE
PHARMACY.
I BEG YOU PLEASE DO NOT TAKE
THIS AWAY FROM US AND ANY OTHER
FAMILY THAT CHOOSES TO USE OUR
SPECIALTY CARE PHARMACY.
FAMILY IS NOT ABOUT BLOOD IT'S
ABOUT WHO IS WILLING TO HOLD
YOUR HAND WHEN YOU NEED IT THE
MOST AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT A
SPECIAL PETER. SPECIALTY CARE
PHARMACY DOES THANK YOU BECAME.
GOOD EVENING THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME MY NAME IS DIEGO FAIRBANKS
I'M VICE PRESIDENT SOLO HEALTH A
NATIONAL COMPANY BUT WE ALSO
PROVIDE PART PARTICULAR HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
FOLLOWING ALL THE STORIES AS WE
THEY MENTION IT'S A SMALL
COMMUNITY. BUT WE PAPA KEEPING
HER ANOTHER TWELVE HOURS SOME
GET SCARED WE WANT WITH A LOT OF
STORIES THERE'S THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT GOES ON INVOLVED IN IN
TAKING CARE OF THESE PATIENTS
FAMILIES AND AVOIDING. SOME OF
THE THE SITUATIONS I CAN THAT.
WITHOUT THE ACCESS
THE ARM WE DO A LOT MORE TO THE
BOTTOM LINE IS WE DO A LOT MORE
THAN JUST PROVIDING FACTOR BUT
WE HAVE CLINICAL TEAMS PROVIDING
GOOD OUTCOMES.
ARE AND THIS IS PART OF THE
WHOLE COALITION NOT TO SOLELY
HEALTH AND ON BUT THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY. BUT OUR LANGUAGE
CULTURAL ARM ACCESS
I'M ADVOCATES IN THE FIELD THAT
WORK IN THE HOME TO ENSURE THAT
NEW PAID NEW PARENTS OR.
OLDER PATIENTS OUR ADHERENCE TO
THEIR PRODUCT THERE REGIMEN FOR
M. IN INFUSING FACTOR.
WITHOUT DOING THAT.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST A ARE
LOOKING AT INCIDENTS AND HOW HOW
MUCH BACK TO THEIR USING BUT
IT'S LOOKING AT WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT EDUCATION IN THE
HOME.
AND AND EDUCATION THAT'S
M. THAT LOOKS AT THE CULTURE AND
LOGIC AND THE THE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS THAT THERE MIGHT BE AS
WELL. SO REALLY WANT TO SOLVE IT
TAKE A LOOK.
AT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE THIS ACCESS IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL SO WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT.
THE PROPOSED METHODOLOGY AND AND
STEP BACK AND SAY WHAT WE NEED
TO DO TO MAKE THIS WORK FOR
EVERYONE. THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN MY NAME'S MATCHING
TRILLIUM FROM THE CENTER FOR
INHERITED BLOOD DISORDERS WE ARE
THE LARGEST HEMOPHILIA TREATMENT
CENTER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ONE THING YOU MAY NOT KNOW IS
THAT WE LOSE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN OUR CLINICAL CARE EACH YEAR.
AND IT'S WE MAKE UP FOR IT BY
OUR THREE FORTY BE PHARMACY
PROGRAM.
REPORTS THAT CARE.
SO WE'RE JUST ASK HERE ON
BEHALF.
OF ALL THE HIM FISHING IN
CENTERS JUST TO COME UP WITH
MODEL THAT WORKS TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE PROPERLY COMPENSATED FOR
ALL THE CARE THAT WE DO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD EVENING COME MY NAME IS
CRAIG MAYOR SAM WITHOUT HAVE
OCCASION FOR ACCESS SPECIALLY
PHARMACY COALITION AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR STAYING IN THIS
LATE HOME. GIVEN US ACCESS AND
HEARING OUR VOICES.
SO SPECIALLY PHARMACIES DO IS DO
THE SAME THING AND THEY PROVIDE
ACCESS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS OF THE
YEAR. THEY PROVIDE THAT HUMAN
FACTOR.
OF MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
PATIENTS LIVES.
THERE'D THERE ON A FRIDAY NIGHT
IF YOU AS YOU'VE HEARD.
HELPING A PATIENT ACCESS THEIR
PRODUCT THEY'RE THERE WHEN A
CHILD WAKES UP IN THE MORNING IN
NEEDS THE PRODUCT BEFORE THEY GO
TO SCHOOL. SO THEY CAN BE AT
SCHOOL AND PLAY WITH THEIR
FRIENDS AT SCHOOL. THEY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN PATIENTS LIVES
EACH AND EVERYDAY.
WE'VE ASKED FOR A COUPLE OF
THINGS ARE PROPOSAL IS BUDGET
NEUTRAL ACTUALLY THE METHODOLOGY
ROUTE WE'VE PROPOSED. WILL SAVE
THE STATE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
FROM THE CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY THAT EXISTS TODAY.
ARE ALSO ASKING FOR OVERSIGHT
WE'VE MET WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
I WE'VE HAD SOME STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WE PROVIDED DATA THAT
THEY REQUESTED AND ALL THAT
COMMUNICATIONS STOPPED AFTER WE
PROVIDED THAT DATA.
SO WE HAVE A REALLY WE DIDN'T
HAVE A STAKEHOLDER MEETING WERE
SUPPOSED TO IN JANUARY.
AND SO EVERYONE IS REALLY.
ANXIOUS.
CONCERNED.
THE THIRD THING I'D LIKE TO ASK
IS IS THAT THERE BE A SAFETY
STUDY DONE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WANTS TO
SEE IF THIS IS IMPLEMENTED A
PATIENT ACTUALLY DIE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO CLIENT
FACTOR.
LIKE THEY DO TODAY AND A SIMPLE
SAFETY STUDY MAY BE ABLE TO SHOW
THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR AND WELCOME TO THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
WE HAVE SEVERAL.
SUBCOMMITTEE QUESTIONS AND ARE
WONDERING IF YOU CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE.
YES THANK YOU I'M.
IN TERMS OF THE PROPOSAL I I DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S CLEAR TO
EVERYONE THAT THE A PROPOSED
CHANGE. I THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAD PUT OUT AND DATING GAUGE
WHAT STAKEHOLDERS WAS AS A
RESULT OF AS WAS MENTIONED WHAT
THE FIRST ON PUBLIC COMMENT. AS
A RESULT OF A FEDERAL RULE THAT
CAME OUT WHERE WE HAVE TO MAKE
CHANGES IN OUR DRUG
REIMBURSEMENT POLICIES
SO BLOOD CLOTTING FACTOR IS ONE.
WE DID PUT OUT JUST THAT A
PROPOSAL WE HAVE BEEN AYE TAKING
BACK.
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED TO DATE AND THAT'S WHY
FOLKS HAVE NOT YET HEARD BACK
FROM US IS BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING
THOSE UNDER CONSIDERATION. AND
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO US SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WERE AWARE
THAT.
THE PROPOSAL WAS SOMETHING THAT
WE WANTED TO HAVE ENGAGEMENT
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON AND IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE COME OUT
AND SAID YES THIS IS IN FACT
WHAT WE ARE DOING. WE ARE
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO COME UP WITH A
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY AND
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
DOING. IS TECH BREAKING APART
ARM THAT REIMBURSEMENT UP THE
DRUG ITSELF AND THEN ALSO DOING.
A BETTER JOB OF DELINEATING
WHAT THOSE CANCEL LARRY SERVICES
ARE BECAUSE TODAY THE WAY THAT
THEY'RE REIMBURSED. IS BASED
UPON AVERAGE SALES PRICE OF THE
DRUG PLUS TWENTY PERCENT.
SO IT'S TWENTY PERCENT OF THAT
DRUG PRICE AND SO WHAT SEE A
MASSIVE SAYING. THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY ARE OVERPAYING FOR
CLOTTING FACTOR WE HAVE TO DO IS
COME UP WITH THE METHODOLOGY
THEY HAVE NOT DICTATED WHAT THAT
METHODOLOGY SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
BUT IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING THAT
MEETS THEIR REQUIREMENTS AND
THAT WE HAVE TO PUT IN FRONT OF
THEM WE DON'T HAVE A TIMELINE
HOWEVER WHEN THEY DID APPROVE
OUR STATE PLAN AMENDMENT. FOR
OUTPATIENT COVER DRUGS BY A
PHARMACY PROVIDERS.
THEY DID INDICATE IN THAT LETTER
THAT THEY WERE EXPECTING TO SEE
SOMETHING FROM US IN THE THIRD
QUARTER. OF THIS YEAR BUT WE
HAVE ALREADY INDICATED TO THEM
WE WILL NOT HAVE SOMETHING TO
PUT BEFORE THEM AND THAT WE ARE
JUST WORK PART TO THEM REPORT
BACK TO THEM IN TERMS OF THE
STATUS. OF WHERE WE'RE AT AND
MAKING A PROPOSAL FOR MAKING
CHANGES TO OUR PLANT PUTTING OUR
REIMBURSEMENT METHODOLOGY.
I'M SAYING THAT THERE'S NO
SPECIFIC DEADLINE WHAT OTHER
OPPORTUNITY WILL WE AS A
LEGISLATURE HAVE TO. PROVIDE
INPUT.
AND WHY I BRING IT UP IS I WAS
ON THE RECEIVING END OF.
MANY OF THE HEMOPHILIACS WHO
WERE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS.
TIMELY. MEDICATIONS
AND RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A
COST TO OUR STATE. WHEN WE ARE
NOT PROVIDING. THE APPROPRIATE
CARE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
AND SO. WILL WE HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO.
PROVIDE INPUT OR TWO. AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE SPECIALTY
PHARMACIES THAT DO PROVIDE A
NEEDED SERVICE FOR COMMUNITIES.
HE YES THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT INPUT TODAY
WE DO HAVE STATE STATUTE. THAT
TALKS ABOUT AND THIS WAS ALSO
MENTION.
THE EXISTING STATUTE TODAY SAYS
WE SHALL NOT PAY MORE THAN A S.
P. PLUS TWENTY PERCENT THAT'S
KIND OF LIKE OUR FRAMEWORK THAT
WERE WORKING WITHIN. IT COULD BE
SOMETHING GLASS FAN HOW MUCH
LESS THAN WE DO NOT HAVE THOSE
DECISIONS MADE AS OF YET.
SO THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC
PROCESS WE WELCOME.
AND THE ENGAGEMENT AND THE
INTERACTION WITH BOTH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE
WELL I HOPE YOU WILL WORK WITH
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE I'M ENGAGED ON
THIS ISSUE. AND WOULD LIKE TO
FOLLOW YES WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE EIGHTEEN OPEN AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR HURST FOR
COMING
.
SARAH BRICKS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
AGAIN THAT AENDA DOES COVER
BESEECH EP ESTIMATE IN GENERAL.
SEATS TO BE AS A PREVENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT DELIVERS PERIODIC
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS AND SERVICES
TO LOW INCOME CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN CALIFORNIA.
PER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
EXPECTED NUMBER SCREENS FOR
STATE FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IS THIRTY SIX. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SHOWS THE
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
NINETEEN.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
NINETEEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TWENTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS THE
LAST TIME YOU'LL HEAR FROM
REMAIN TODAY. SECCO BUSINESS ON
EVERY BOMBING COUNTS PROGRAM
ESTIMATE AGAIN THE.
AGENDA DOES PLAY OUT THE
PROGRAM I WILL NOTE THAT.
FOR BUDGET YEAR WERE EXPECTING
A CASELOAD OF APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT THERE HAS
BEEN AN INCREASE IN THE.
BUDGET FROM I'M THE ESTIMATE OF
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN OUT OF THREE MILLION
DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY AND IT'S
RELATED TO I'M INCREASE ACCESS
TO SERVICES WE DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S REALLY TIGHT TO.
THE PROVISIONS THAT WERE LAID
OUT AND ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
NINETY FIVE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE WAY. OF TRACKING THAT TO
OUR CLAIMS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA A.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
TWENTY.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE
TWENTY ONE.
RIGHT SARA BOOKS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AGAIN THE AGENDA DOES
COVER THE CCS BUDGET IN GENERAL.
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN SERVICES
PROVIDES HEALTH CARE TO CHILDREN
UP TO AGE TWENTY ONE FOR CERTAIN
QUES CONDITIONS SUCH AS CYSTIC
FIBROSIS HEMOPHILIA CEREBRAL
PALSY HEALTH DISEASE. CANCER OR
TRAUMATIC INJURY. THE CCS COSTS
IN THE FAMILY ESTIMATE ARE FOR
CHILDREN WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
MEDI CAL.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR FISCAL
YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AS FOR
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE CHILDREN AND IS
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE CHAIR DID ASK FOR AN UPDATE
ON S. B. FIVE EIGHTY SIX AS
WELL.
I'M S. B. FIVE EIGHTY SIX
IMPLEMENTS THE WHOLE CHILD MODEL
UNDER WHICH SOME MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE HEALTH PLANS IN
COUNTY ORGANIZED HEALTH SYSTEM
COUNTIES. WILL BECOME
RESPONSIBLE FOR SERVICES
CURRENTLY COVERED BY COUNTIES TO
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES.
THE WHOLE CHILD MODEL IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES WITH FIVE HEALTH PLANS
INTO DIFFERENT PHASES.
THE FIRST PHASE WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED KNOW SOONER THAN
JULY ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT
SECOND JANUARY ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN. THIS TRANSITION
REPRESENTS APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND CHILDREN.
DH YES IS ISSUING GUIDANCE TO
HELP PLANTS AND COUNTIES IN THE
FORM OF AN ALL POUND LIGHTER AND
COUNTY INFORMATION NOTICE. THESE
DOCUMENTS DO DESCRIBE
REQUIREMENTS FOR BOTH ENTITIES
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF A
TRANSITION PLAN A REQUIREMENT TO
ENTER INTO A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING AND FOR HEALTH
PLANS REQUIREMENTS PERTAINING TO
WRIST STRATIFICATION AND
CREATION OF. OF INDIVIDUAL CARE
PLANS FOR FOR BENEFICIARIES.
BUT NO WITHIN THE SCRIPT CHOIR
MINTZ'S I NOTED THE TRANSITION
PLAN IS KEY. IT DOES DESCRIBE
REQUIREMENTS PERTAINING TO
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE TWO
ENTITIES COUNTIES EMPOWER.
HEALTH PLANS ON THE TRANSFER
CASE MANAGEMENT CARE
COORDINATION PROVIDER REFERRALS
AND SERVICE AUTHORIZATION
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS TO THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS.
I'M IT ALSO ADDRESSES
COMMUNICATIONS THE BENEFICIARIES
REGARDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
AUTHORIZATIONS PROVIDER NETWORK
CASE MANAGEMENT AND ENSURING
CONTINUITY OF CARE AND SERVICES
FOR BENEFICIARIES IN THE PROCESS
OF AGING OUT OF CCS.
DHS IS IN THE PROCESS OF GOING
TO READINESS REVIEWS FOR BOTH
THE COUNTIES AND HEALTH PLANS.
I NETWORK RIG READINESS IS ONE
COMPONENT OF THIS REVIEW HEALTH
PLANS MUST DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY
HAVE ADEQUATE NUMBERS OF
PROVIDERS TO ENSURE TIMELY
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE CARE FOR
BENEFICIARIES.
EACH HOLE CHILD MODEL HEALTH
PLAN MUST HAVE AN ADEQUATE
NETWORK OF CCS PANEL PROVIDERS
FOR EACH OF THE FOLLOWING
PROVIDER TYPES IN FACILITIES
JUST READ THEM QUICKLY PHYSICIAN
SPECIALIST PROFESSIONALS.
PROFESSIONAL HIGHLIGHTED MEDICAL
SUPPORT PERSON HOSPITALS
POTENTIALLY CARE SETTLES CENTER
SPECIALIZED DME PROVIDERS AND
HOME HEALTH.
UMPIRE CHIP KANSAS NING
BENEFICIARIES WILL RECEIVE A
NINETY SIXTY AND THIRTY DAY
NOTICE. OF THESE NOTICES DO
SPECIFICALLY CALL OUT CONTINUITY
OF CARE REQUIREMENTS FOR
BENEFICIARIES WITH THAT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
BERMAN UPON UNTIL IT.
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE ISSUE
TWENTY ONE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY ONE OPEN IN THE BOND
ISSUE TWENTY TWO.
HI LINDA HARRINGTON FOR THAT
PART OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
SO I THINK THEIR AGENDA DOES A
GOOD JOB LATE IN THE EVENING SO
I WILL JUST SAY THAT I HAVE THIS
IS A PROPOSAL REQUESTING TWENTY
ONE RESOURCE IS A CONVERSION
AND.
OF.
NINE POINT FIVE CURRENT LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS THE ADDITION OF
TWO NEW PERMANENT POSITIONS AS
WELL AS THE ADDITION OF
NINE-POINT FIVE THREE YEAR
LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS.
A FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
HOSPITAL QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE
PROGRAM AND AGAIN THERE'S NO
GENERAL FUND ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS REQUEST ADDITIONALLY
THERE'S TRAILER BILL ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE CAP
LIMITATION THAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY IN TRAILER BILL. AND
LIMITS AND THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
WE CAN USE OUT OF THAT THE
SPECIAL FUND TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PER QUARTER THIS
WOULD RAISE IT TO PICK.
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PER
QUARTER TO ALLOW US TO DEFINE
THESE RESOURCE THIS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EARLIER.
IN PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
TWENTY TWO.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWICE TO OPEN IN THE BOND ISSUE
TWENTY THREE. AND IT'S A FOR
ISSUE TWENTY THREE AGAIN AND WE
ARE LOOKING FOR AND TO PERMANENT
RESOURCE IS.
AGAIN AT A COST NOT TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
AND THESE RESOURCES WOULD GO TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW I'M GRADUATE
MEDICAL EXPENSE.
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF
CMS.
DETERMINE THE FINANCIALLY.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE TWENTY
THREE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOPE HOLD
ISSUE TWENTY THREE OPEN IN THE
BOND ISSUE TWENTY. FAIR BRETT'S
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES I'M DHS IS
REQUESTING POSITION AND CONTRACT
FUNDING FOR THE ONGOING EFFORTS
TO IMPLEMENT THE MEDICAID AND
CHILDREN'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PROGRAM MANAGED CARE FINAL RULE.
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES ARE SET TO EXPIRE ON
JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THIS PROPOSAL
CONTINUES THE SAME LEVEL STAFF
RESOURCES PERMANENTLY AS FOLLOWS
NINE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY EQUIVALENT
TO FOUR POSITIONS AND
CONTRACTUAL FUNDING OF ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
TOTAL FUNDING REQUEST IS THREE
MILLION NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELIA.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
TWENTY FOUR.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY FOUR OPENING ROUND ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE
.
IN YOU'RE. KIDDING I BURST NAM
W.
DIRECTOR HEALTH CARE SERVICES
OFFICE INVESTIGATIONS.
A HARPER PULLED OR REQUESTING TO
YOUR LIMITED TERM FINDING OF
NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
TWO POINT TWO FIVE MILLION OF
WHICH IS GENERAL FUND. I IN
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND UP TO TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
UP TO TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. FISCAL
YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT NOTE THAT WE'RE
LEVERAGING SEVEN FIVE PERCENT
FISCAL FOR A FEDERAL FUNDING
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. GENERAL
FUND.
I THIS PROPOSAL EXPANDS ON THE
H. CS IS DATA ANALYTICS
CAPABILITIES CONSISTENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S
COMMITMENT TOWARDS INNOVATION.
AND IMPROVED METHODS TO SHRINK
AND PROGRAM INTEGRITY HAVE
WITHIN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
THIS ALSO IS MORE SPECIFICALLY
STRENGTHENS THE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY. STOP AND
PREVENT FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE BY
DIRECTING MY STAFF.
A TO THE MOST CRITICAL CASES IN
WITH THE HIGHEST POTENTIAL FOR
FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE AND
HIGHEST DOLLARS TO THE PROGRAM.
IT ALSO ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
MORE EFFECTIVELY TO ANALYZE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. AND COMPARED
TO A MORE LABOR INTENSIVE.
APPROACH OF REVEALING
INDEPENDENTLY.
AND FIFIELD THAT INVESTIGATIONS.
IT ALSO ALLOWS DCS TO.
ACCESS NUMEROUS PROPRIETARY
DATABASES.
I BEGIN ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT PROVIDERS TO IDENTIFY IN
PER PRIORITIZE ESTIMATES
CATIONS.
ULTIMATELY WE BASED UPON PAST
EXPERIENCES WE ESTIMATE A
PROTECTION PROJECTED SAVINGS OF
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER A
COUPLE YEARS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ELLIOTT.
I'M BEN BEN JOHNSON AT THE LA A
A WE ARE COME CURRENTLY
COMPLETING OUR ANALYSIS OF THE
SITE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL AND
WERE NOTIFIED LEGISLATURE IF WE
HAVE ANY ISSUES.
UP ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE.
SEEING NONE.
HAVING DONE INFORMATICS FROM MY
HOSPITAL I'M QUITE INTERESTED IN
THIS PROPOSAL. AND.
AM EXCITED FOR THE POTENTIALS
FOR RETURN ON INVESTMENT FROM
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS.
AND JUST WOULD WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE CHECK INS.
TUB MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA AND
METRICS ARE BEING FOLLOWED THAT
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU.
SARAH VETS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES DHS IS
REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
AND ON GOING. THE FUNDS WILL BE
USED TO PROCURE A NEW CLOUD
BASED CUSTOMER CUSTOMER
RELATIONS MANAGEMENT SOFTWARE AS
A SERVICE SOLUTIONS SOLUTION FOR
THE MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
OMBUDSMAN. CHAPTER FIFTY TWO OF
SENATE BILLS NINETY SEVEN FROM
LAST YEAR INCLUDED A REQUIREMENT
TO PROVIDE QUARTERLY REPORTING
ON CALLS RECEIVED BY THE MEDI
CAL MANAGE CRIME BATSMEN.
INCLUDING A REQUIREMENT TO
REPORT ON DEMOGRAPHIC DATA.
THESE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA ARE
CURRENTLY NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND NEW SERUM IS
NECESSARY TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
OF S. B. NINETY SEVEN.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EARLIER.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
TWENTY SIX.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY SIX OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN.
THAT I THINK YOU AND SO ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN WE HAVE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL THAT WOULD.
REPEAL THE.
FREESTANDING NON HOSPITAL
CLINIC SUPPLEMENTAL
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM AND AS
WELL AS A LIVE MANY A.
A FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE AND THAT
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED IT'S WE NO
LONGER NEED THAT APPROPRIATION
AND ESTHER REPEAL THE PROGRAM
UNFORTUNATELY BETWEEN THE TIME
THAT THE. THE PROGRAM WAS
INSTITUTED IN STATUTE WE WERE
ABLE TO RECEIVE FULL CMS
APPROVAL THERE'D BEEN
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE
PROGRAM. AND AND THERE'S A VERY
LIMITED.
ELIGIBILITY FOR THIS PROGRAM SO
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH CLINICS TOOK
TO SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS AND FOR THIS PROGRAM SO
WE'RE LOOKING TO REPEAL IT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN.
SEEING NONE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN OPEN AND THAT
CONCLUDES TODAY'S HERE THANK YOU
THANK YOU